SUBCOMMITTEE.
UNTIL WE HAVE OUR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM -- WE
HAVE SOME OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAD
SPEAKING MAKING ENGAGEMENTS THIS
MORNING BUT THEY WILL BE HERE
SOON AS THEY HAVE COMPLETED
THOSE.
SO WEIRD.
WE ARE GOING IN FILE ORDER WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CHANGES TO THE
AGENDA -- AND WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS ON CONSENT.
AND WE ARE GOING TO START WITH
SB.
TWENTY TWO SENATOR LEYVA.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
SENATE BILL TWENTY TWO BUILT
UPON THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT YOU
MADAM CHAIR LET'S SEVERAL YEARS
AGO THE PROMPT TESTING OF RAPE
KITS OR AS YOU TOLD US LAST TIME
SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS WE REMEMBER.
AS YOU MAY REMEMBER GOVERNOR
BROWN VETOED SB FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE LAST YEAR.
BUT I KNOW THAT WE ALL REMAIN
COMMITTED TO MAKE THE PROPER
TESTING OF GREAT KIDS A REALITY
HENCE WHY I'M BEFORE YOU TODAY
WITH THIS RE INTRODUCTION.
THOUGH THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR
SEEM TO BELIEVE THAT A SIMPLE
AUDIT OF EXISTING RAPE KITS WAS
ENOUGH I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
SINCE THE BUT IT DOES NOTHING TO
ADVANCE AS CLOSER. TO ENSURING
JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS THE CORE
OF SB TWENTY TWO IS ACTUALLY
VERY SIMPLE BUT IT WILL HELP HOW
IT WILL HAVE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT
ON THE LIVES OF VICTIMS.
AND HELP REQUEST BEHIND BARS.
THIS MEASURE SIMPLY CHANGES ONE
WORD IN EXISTING LAW BYSAYING
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND FORENSIC LABORATORIES SHALL
FOLLOW INSTEAD OF SHOULD FOLLOW
AS IT CURRENTLY STATES LISTED
TIME FRAMES FOR SUBMITTING AND
ANALYZING RAPE KIT EVIDENCE.
MEMBERS MEMBER MANY OF YOU MAY
KNOW THAT JUST A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED SB
EIGHT THIRTEEN WHICH ELIMINATED
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ON
RATE.
THOUGH THAT WAS CERTAINLY A HUGE
VICTORY THE ROAD TO JUSTICE FOR
VICTIMS OF RAPE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT WILL BE INCOMPLETE IF
THE RAPE KITS ARE NEVER TESTED
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
ALL RAPE VICTIMS DESERVE TO HAVE
THE RAPE KITS TESTED WITHIN THE
SPECIFIED TIME FRAME WHICH CAN
IN TURN HELP TO ENSURE JUSTICE
FOR VICTIMS.
IDENTIFY SERIAL PERPETRATORS AND
EVEN EXONERATE THE WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED.
AS WE ALL KNOW RAPE IS ONE OF
THE MOST TRAUMATIZING THINGS
THAT CAN HELP TO HAPPEN TO
SOMEONE.
AND THEN AFTERWARDS WHEN YOU
SUBMIT YOURSELF TO HAVING A
SEXUAL ASSAULT KIT A RAPE KIT
DONE WHICH TAKES MANY MANY HOURS
AND O THINK THAT THAT IS NEVER
TESTED AND TO THINK THAT THAT IS
SITTING ON A SHELF SOMEPLACE.
IS JUST INEXCUSABLE.
I'D LIKE TO REMIND EVERYONE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE
WHICH SAID THAT HE THOUGHT WE
SHOULD DO THE ODD AT FIRST.
AND THEN WE WOULD GO FROM THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR
BECAUSE I THINK HE MISSED THE
ENTIRE POINT OF THE BILL WHICH
WAS TO MAKE SURE WE NEVER HAVE A
BACKLOG OF RAPE KITS AGAIN.
SO I HOPE GOOD MOVING FORWARD
THIS GETS TO OUR NEW GOVERNOR
AND HE SIGNS IT INTO LAW.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
HAVE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY AND
AMANDA STEVENS OF THE JOYFUL
HEART FOUNDATION THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
A GOOD MORNING.
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE AGAIN
IN FRONT OF THE SENATOR SKINNER
AND THE COMMITTEE -- AS SENATOR
SKINNER KNOWS IN THE COMMITTEE
KNOWS THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
NOW.
ABOUT -- TRYING TO ENSURING THAT
ALL SEXUAL SOCKETS ARE TESTED.
OF A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHEN SENATOR
SKINNER WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY SHE
LED YOU LED THE EFFORT TO HAVE
THEM TESTED IN THE COMPROMISE
WAS SHALL AS OPPOSED TO SHOULD.
AND SINCE THAT TIME WE STILL
KNOW THAT KIDS ARE NOT BEING
TESTED.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT -- WE DO
KNOW ALSO THAT THROUGH A VOTE.
ALMOST AN INCOMPLETE BECAUSE THE
FAILURE OF SOME OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO RESPOND
TO THE SURVEY BY JOYFUL HEART.
THAT THERE ARE STILL KIDS ARE
SITTING IN EVIDENCE ROOMS THAT
ARE NOT BEING SUBMITTED.
IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT CALIFORNIA
MAKE THIS ISSUE AND THESE CRIMES
A PRIORITY AND WE IT SENATOR
KNOWS THAT IN MY OWN COUNTY.
SEVERAL YEARS BACK WE IDENTIFIED
NINETEEN HUNDRED KIDS THAT WERE
UNTESTED THAT WENT BACK MANY
YEARS WE HAVE NO BACKLOG IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE'VE CLEARED
THAT UP.
A NUMBER OF YEARS BACK BUT I
MILITIA I AM -- BEING MILITANT
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT ALL KIDS
GO TO THE CRIME LAB FOR TESTING
AND AS A RESULT WE'RE ABLE TO
SELL MORE CASES NOT JUST. FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL CASE WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BUT ALSO TO
LINK SERIAL RAPIST TO OTHER
CASES.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT
BENEFITS OF THE FORENSIC
EVIDENCE OF SO FOR LL THOSE
REASONS THAT IT THE TIME IS CALM.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL A AS A
SPONSOR IN ALSO URGING AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE FIRST
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME SENATOR
SKINNER CENTER MORLOCK. FOR TO
TALK ABOUT RIGHT TESTING RIGHT
GETS IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M AMANDA STEVENS A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION AND RESIDENT OF THIS
GREAT STATE.
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE CHAIR SENATOR
SKINNER FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE TODAY.
AND OF COURSE THANK YOU TO
SENATOR LEYVA AND HER STAFF FOR
THEIR FEAR SUPPORT OF SURVIVORS.
JOYFUL HEART WAS FOUNDED BY LAW
AND ORDER ACTICIN ADVOCATE
MARCIA HARGETT KAY AND IS A
PROUD SPONSOR OF SENATE BILL
TWENTY TWO WHICH REQUIRE TESTING
OF ALL SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS.
CONNECTED TO REPORT A CRIME.
IT WILL ALSO EXPAND ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS AND MAKE CALIFORNIA A
SAFER.
DNA EVIDENCE CONTAINED IN SEXUAL
ASSAULT KITS IS A POWERFUL TOOL
TO SOLVE AND PREVENT CRIME.
WHEN TESTED IT CAN IDENTIFY
UNKNOWN OFFENDERS AND LINK
CRIMES TOGETHER?
TESTING IN DETROIT OF TEN
THOUSAND RAPE KITS HAS UNCOVERED
MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED SERIAL
RAPIST WHO HAVE COMMITTED ALL
KINDS OF CRIMES IN FORTY OTHER
STATES AND DC.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA KEITH ASBURY
JUNIOR OF ANTIOCH SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AT LEAST FIVE WOMEN
OVER NINE YEARS EVENTUALLY
MURDERING ONE OF HIS VICTIMS.
ACCORDING TO PROCTOR PROSECUTORS
ASBURY KIDNAPPED AND RAPED TWO
YOUNG WOMEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD AND A
NINETEEN YEAR OLD.
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS
COLLECTED FROM THESE VICTIMS SAT
UNTESTED FOR YEARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HE
ATTEMPTED RAPE OF A FORTY SIX
OLD WOMAN AND A FEW WEEKS LATER
BURGLARIZED HOME RAPING AND
MURDERING A THIRTY SEVEN YEAR
OLD STUDENT.
SEVERAL OF THESE CRIMES COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED WITH A
TIMELY TESTING OF A SINGLE
SEXUAL ASSAULT KIT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT THANKS TO DL
MALLEY FOR TESTING THE CATS IN
THESE CASES.
I COULD READ HEADLINES LIKE
DETROIT AND THE ASBURY CASE FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR HOURS.
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW SAYS LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD SEND IDS FOR
TESTING.
THIS WAS A WELL INTENTIONED LOG
BUT IT JUST ISN'T WORKING JOYFUL
HEARTS ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT
HAS ISSUED OPEN RECORDS REQUESTS
TO EIGHT JURISDICTIONS.
AND FOUND THAT SIX OUT OF THE
EIGHT ARE NOT FOLLOWING THE
ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE LAW OR HAVE
NO WAY OF KNOWING HOW MANY KIDS
THEY ARE RECEIVING.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
BY PASSING SB TWENTY TWO AND
CHANGING THE SHOULD TO A SHALL
AND TESTING ALL SXUAL ASSAULT
KITS CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE
DANGEROUS VIOLENT OFFENDERS OFF
THE STREET.
IT WILL ALSO DEMONSTRATE A
COMMITMENT TO SURVIVORS TO HELP
THEM FIND A PATH TO HEALING AND
JUSTICE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH YOU TO PASS THIS
MUCH NEEDED LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO BE OF
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JUST COME UP TO THE MIKE AND MY
MANAGER RYNE SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANKS.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I JUST THOUGHT LESLIE CALDWELL
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WE HAD WITHDRAWN OUR
OPPOSITION I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMITTEE KNOWS
PRE SHEET THAT.
ALRIGHT SO SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION -- I
WILL I MAKE A COMMENT NO SEE IF
ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS -- OUR
LANGUAGE IS A VERY POWERFUL
THING AND WHILE THE WORD K<c.cyan></c>
IS REFERRED.
TO THINGS LIKE TOOL KIT AND
SHAVING KITIT DOES TEND TO
REFER MORE COMMONLY TWO ITEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH FEMALES SEWING
KIT MAKE UP KITS THINGS LIKE
THAT [inaudible]
AND WELL WE KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS THE DATA SHOWS THAT THAT.
THESE -- THAT THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE IS NOT TESTED IS
BECAUSE IT IS COMMONLY.
A FEMALE WHO HAS EXPERIENCE THE
ASSAULT [inaudible]
AND UNFORTUNATELY.
WHETHER IT'S IMPLICIT BIAS WHO
KNOWS.
THE BY I SHOULD SAY WHO KNOWS
THERE IS A VERY STE RESEARCH BUT
I CAN ASIDE BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
IN FRONT OF ME.
THESE CRIMES ARE NOT TAKEN AS
SERIOUSLY SO THAT'S THE EVIDENCE
IS NOT PUT INTO THE DNA DATABASE
AND WE DON'T GET THE CRIMES
RESOLVE.
THE FACT IS IS THAT THERE'S A
VERY LARGE PERCENT OF WOMEN
STILL.
MEN AND WOMEN BUT WHO DO NOT
REPORT THEIR SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
AND OF COURSE IF YOU EVER READ
ABOUT.
FOLKS LIKE THE WOMAN IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHO -- WENT TO THE
TROUBLE OF GETTING HER WHOLE
MEDICAL EXAMINATION AND HER
EVIDENCE.
SUBMITTED AND THEN IT WAS NEVER
SUBMITTED TO THE IT WAS NEVER
TESTED.
AND SHE KEPT RETURNING TO THE
POLICE OFFICE POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND WOULD NOT GET ANY ANSWER.
I MEAN THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WOULD DISCOURAGE
THERE'S ALREADY SHAME -- FOR IT
MEETING THAT YOU WERE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED THERE'S ALREADY SHAME
TO EVEN REPORT YOUR CRIME.
SO WHY WOULD YOU REPORT IF YOU
THINK THERE IT I WILL THE LAN
PERSONS NOT GONNA TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY SO.
I THINK THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
THE PRIMARY REASON IT DIDN'T
HAVE.
SHOULD -- SHOT WHATEVER.
SHALL.
USE ME IN MY ORIGINAL BILLS
BECAUSE AT THE TIME AND I WAS
CARRYING THE BILL WE HAD SHE
LOST I THINK WE HAD JUST ENDED
OUR DEFICITS ANYWAY IT WAS WE
KNEW THAT IT WOULDN'T GET
THROUGH A PROPS.
SO BUT WE'RE IN BETTER SHAPE NOW
SO I APPRECIATE THAT BROUGHT IT
FORWARD AND I HOPE WE GET TO THE
POINT WHERE.
EVERY SIX SINGLE SEXUAL ASSAULT
IS REPORTED.
ALL EVIDENCE IS TESTED.
AND WE CAN ANDERSON RESOLVE THE
CRIMES.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES.
WE THIS IS WE DON'T A QUORUM YET
[inaudible]
SO.
WE'LL JUST KEEP IT TO LOOK AT
PORN.
RIGHT IN THERE WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION THAT OKAY SO -- WITH THAT
I THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING AN
WILL TAKE A LITTLE WHILE FORGET
OUR CAR IF I MAY CLOSE YES OF
START THAT'S OKAY.
I I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
AGREE WHOLE HEARTEDLY WE ALL
AGREE WHOLE WHOLE HEARTEDLY AND
EVERYTHING IN ITS TIME THE WORK
THAT YOU DID WHEN YOU DID IT WAS
IN ITS TIME AND NOW WE THINK
IT'S TIME TO CHANGE IT TO SHALL.
AND PUT IT INTO THIS SO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND WHEN APPROPRIATE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
GREAT AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST.
DONE SO THAT WE DO KNOW THERE
ARE STILL.
AND THEY'RE STILL EVIDENCE.
ON THE SHELVES THAT HAS NOT BEEN
BECAUSE RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO SB
TWENTY THREE CENTER WINNERS YEAR
NO.
RIGHT THAT'S MEMBER ANYWAY
POLICIES.
HE GETS BIG NORD FOR NOW.
BUT WE'LL GO TO ITEM THREE SB.
THIRTY FIVE IS ARM IS OUR
PRESENTER YET IN THE ROOM WE
HAVE NO ONE WHAT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE ARE A GREAT THANK YOU.
SO WILL HOLD OFF FOR A MOMENT
UNTIL WE GET A PRESENTER
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
FOR CENTER
TANK THANK -- SB THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES.
DESPITE YEARS A COMMENDABLE
EFFORTS TO COMBAT SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING THIS IS STILL A
CRIME IN CALIFORNIA -- HUMAN
TRAFFICKING REMAINS WIDESPREAD
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING RESOURCE CENTER
DURING THE PERIOD. TWENTY TWELVE
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
HAS CONSISTENTLY RANKED AT THE
TOP OF ITS HOTLINE CALLS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE HOT WHEN
WAS THE NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND
CALLS IN CALIFORNIA.
RESULT IN JUST OVER ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CASES REPORTED.
THAT NUMBER REPRESENTS NEARLY
210065% INCREASE IN REPORTED
CASES SINCE.
TWENTY TWELVE SADLY MANY OF
THESE VICTIMS CYCLE THROUGH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AND ADDS
HOMELESSNESS GROWS.
CALIFORNIA BECOMES MORE
VULNERABLE TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IMPACTS ALL
WALKS OF LIFE BUT YOUNG GIRLS
ARE OFTEN THE TARGETS OF
TRAFFICKERS.
JUST LAST WEEK A MAN WAS
ARRESTED IN SANTA ANA ON
ALLEGATIONS OF THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THREE MINERS.
THEY FOUND HIM IN A HOTEL WITH
TWO GIRLS AGES THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN LAST YEAR THE ORANGE
COUNTY HUMAN TRAFFICKING TASK
FORCE.
HELP FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS AND MORE
THAN 25% OF THOSE WERE MINORS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOR CALIFORNIA
ENACTED ITS FIRST.
ANTI TRAFFICKING LAW WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA LINES
COMBAT TRAFFICKING AND SLAVERY.
WHICH IS CALIFORNIA ACTS TASK
FORCE IS TWO THOUSAND FIVE
REPORT LAID THE GROUNDWORK FOR
COORDINATED COLLABORATIVE
RESPONSE TO COMBATTING SEX.
AND LABOR TRAFFICKING IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE TASK FORCE CONVENE AGAIN IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND ONCE
AGAIN IN.
TWENTY TWELVE EACH TIME
REPRESENTATIVES FROM GOVERNMENT
AND PRIVATE SECTOR AGENCIES
IDENTIFIED LEGISLATIVE POLICY.
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE STRATEGIES
AS WELL AS SUPPORT FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES AS PART OF A HOLISTIC.
RESPONSE ENDING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CALIFORNIA.
SB THIRTY FIVE WILL COOK
RECONVENE THE CALIFORNIA LINES
COMBAT TRAFFICKING SLAVERY TASK
FORCE TO HELP.
RECALIBRATE THE STATE'S HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SUPPRESSION STRATEGY
AS WELL AS MEASURE THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF THE GROWING CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE.
THERE IS MUCH MORE WORK TO BE
DONE.
THE TASK FORCE OUTLINED IN THIS
BILL LARGELY MIRRORS THE ONE
THAT CAME BEFORE IT BUT MAKE
SOME IMPORTANT CHANGES.
IN PARTICULAR THE TASK FORCE
WILL LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR
PREVALENCE STUDY FOR CALIFORNIA.
THERE SIMPLY ISN'T ENOUGH DATA
FOR US TO TRULY UNDERSTAND THE
SIZE AND SCOPE OF THIS ISSUE.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THIS
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE AT A MORE
DETAILED LEVEL THE TIME IS RIGHT
TO RECONVENE THESE LEADERS AND
REALIGN OUR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SUPPRESSION STRATEGY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY IN WOULD NEED TO
EXPAND ON WHAT THIS TASK FORCES
ABOUT IS STEPHANIE RICHARD.
REPRESENTING THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING.
WHO HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES
OF THIS ISSUE FOR YEARS
INCLUDING PARTICIPATION IN THE
LAST STATE TASK FORCE?
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK.
I'M IN A ESTABLISH QUORUM POLICY
SO IF YOU'RE POSSIBLE FOR A
MOMENT AND SECRETARY CAN YOU
CALL THE ROLL SKINNER.
I'M HERE MOORLACH BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL HERE BROWN'S
[inaudible]
MORRELL WIENER.
OKAY DON'T WORRY DON'T WORRY --
WE ARE ALSO OING TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ADOPT OUR RULES BEFORE
WE PROCEED.
GREAT SAYS THEIR SECOND NO WE
DON'T NEED A SECOND POLICY I'M
STILL.
LIKE YOU KNOW.
ANYWAY WE HAVE A MOTION TO ADOPT
OUR RULES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SKINNER.
HI MOORLACH.
BRADFORD JACKSON MITCHELL.
BROWN RELY WIENER [inaudible]
EXCELLENT.
AND I I APPRECIATE AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS WHO MIGHT HAVE NINE
THIRTY I HAD NINE THREE ON MY
CALENDAR FILL IN THE DAY
YESTERDAY -- ALL RIGHT SO.
WITNESS YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC
AGAIN MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
RICHARD I'M THE POLICY LEGAL
SERVICES DIRECTOR OF THE
COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING COMMONLY KNOWN AS
CAST.
CATS IS THE FIRST SERVICE
BRIGHTER IN THE UNITED STATES IS
CLOSELY SERVING SURVIVORS OF
MODERN SLAVERY WE OFFER
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES INCLUDING
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT LEGAL
AND SHELTER WE OFFER DIRECT
SERVICES IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA
AND OPERATE THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
HOTLINE THAT'S POSTED ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR WE SERVED OVER A
THOUSAND SURVIVORS OF SEX AND
LABOR TRAFFICKING AND THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS.
CAST SPEAKING TODAY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AS A SPONSOR OF SB
THIRTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
RECONVENE THE CALIFORNIA LINES
TO COMBAT TRAFFICKING AND
SLAVERY.
ACTS TASK FORCE.
HAVING WORKED ON ANTI
TRAFFICKING POLICIES AND
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA FOR
ALMOST FIFTEEN YEARS I'VE
PERSONALLY BEEN A MEMBER.
OF THE ALL THE PREVIOUS TASK
FORCES AND I HAVE PERSONALLY
SEEN THAT THERE'S NO OTHER PRO
CHOICE THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
BRING TOGETHER THE EXPERTISE
NEEDED TO REALLY ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE COMPREHENSIVELY INCLUDING
LOOKING AT THE ISSUES OF SEX AND
LABOR TRAFFICKING IMPACTING MEN.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN STATEWIDE IN
THE PAST TO SEIZE TASK FORCES
PROVIDE INVALUABLE INFORMATION
FOR THE STATE AND WHAT HAS BEEN
WORKING AND WHAT MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE BASED ON EXPERT AGENCY
INPUT.
THE TASK FORCE IN THE PAST HAS
BEEN CONTRIVED OF TWENTY TWO
APPOINTED MEMBERS AND WE
RECOMMEND THE SAME FORMAT AND
STRUCTURE.
THAT HAS WORKED CONSISTENTLY IN
THE PAST WITH THE ADDITION OF
SIX NEW MEMBERS TWO OF THE NEW
MEMBERS INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE HOMELESS INITIATIVE
BECAUSE OF THE RECENT HOMELESS
FOR EXAMPLE.
CON LA WE FOUND THAT FIVE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS OF THE
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
HOMELESS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ITSELF IDENTIFIED AS VICTIMS OF
TRAFFICKING.
ALMOST ONE IN TEN WE FURTHER
RECOMMEND INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF SURVIVORS APPOINTED THE TASK
FORCE FROM ONE TO THREE GIVEN
THE DIVERSE FORMS OF TRAFFICKING.
THAT THE TASK FORCE REVIEWS AND
LOOKS INTO ONE SURVIVOR
APPOINTMENT JUST ISN'T ENOUGH
FOR THE SAME REASON WE RECOMMEND
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SERVICE WRITERS APPOINTED THE
TASK FORCE SO YOU DO HAVE THAT
WIDE RE OF EXPERTISE.
IN THE DIFFERENT SUB CATEGORIES
OF TRAFFICKING WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE TASK FORCE DOES NEED TO BE
COMPRISED OF THIS DIVERSE GROUP
OF MEMBERS TO TRULY BRING
TOGETHER.
AND TO THE TABLE A WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CANNOT JUST HAVE A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE LANDS BUT TO
PREVENT EARLY IDENTIFY AND
ULTIMATELY AND THIS GRAVE HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSE IN OUR STATE.
WE MUST BE ABLE TO COORDINATE
THIS DIVERSE GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS OF STATE PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT ACTORS -- AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT AB ARE SB THREE
THIRTY FIVE REQUIRES.
NOW SB THIRTY FIVE ALSO REQUIRES
THE TASK FORCE PRODUCE THREE
REPORTS TO ARE EXPECTED TO BE
QUITE SHORT AND FOCUS ON VERY
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
TASK FORCE MEMBERS ON TWO AREAS.
BUT COST AND DATA COLLECTED
NEEDED FOR THE PREVALENCE STUDY
TO LOOK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE SECOND IS HOW TO BEST
EVALUATE THE TWENTY ONE SERVICE
PROVIDERS RECEIVING NEW STATE
MONEY AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND THE DATA THEY SHOULD BE
COLLECTING.
THESE REPORTS ARE EXPECTED TO
TAKE ONE MEETING OF INPUT EACH
FROM THIS GROUP OF EXPERTS AND
THEREFORE HAVE EARLIER REPORT
OUT.
A FINAL REPORT ME YEARS.
THE REPORTS WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
PRODUCED IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
AND THEN AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE AND THE TIMELINE FOR THE
REPORT TO BE PRODUCES THE SAME
AS IT'S BEEN IN THE PAST -- CAST
BASED ON A TWENTY YEARS OF ON
THE GROUND EXPERIENCE OUR
INTERESTS ARRIVE AS A
TRAFFICKING HERE IN OUR STATE
BELIEVES THE TIMING IS RIGHT TO
RECONVENE THE STATE WHITE.
FORCE AND ASK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF SB
[inaudible]
THIRTY FIVE RIGHT -- ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PINE SCHIRMER THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU COUNTER
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LUCIA MUCH LOWER ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION LESLIE CALDWELL IN
SUPPORT.
MORGAN GUY ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LINES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER EMPOWER FAMILY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE -- NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM.
MY COLLEAGUES -- I WANTED TO
RAISE A COUPLE OF THINGS I'M
CENTER DURING THE TIME FRAME
SEEM -- DIFFICULT THERE ON
IMMEDIATE.
IT ALSO SEEMS LIKE A VERY LARGE
TASK FORCE [inaudible]
ON SO I EIGHT I THINK AS YOU
PROCEED IF IT GETS THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE THAT YOU MIGHT
CONSIDER.
THE SIZE AND ALSO THE TIME
FRAMES AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
ABSOLUTELY SO THE THE SIZE OF
THE HOUSE FORCED INCREASE
BECAUSE WE WANT TO INCLUDE MORE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS AND
ALSO HOMELESS ADVOCATES AND
THAT'S WHY THE US SIZE HAS --
HAS GROWN BUT WE ARE DEFINITELY
OPEN.
TO HAVING A DOWN.
AND WILL DEFINITELY LOOK AT THE
TIME.
MMHM -- WE NOW HAVE QUORUM SO WE
CAN -- SORRY WE ALREADY HAVE A
POLICIES POLITICS WE DID ROLL
CALL EVEN -- I CAN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION [inaudible]
ON WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE TO
SERVE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE THANK YOU EXCELLENT.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL --
LET'S DO ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE MORE LOCK.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MOREAU WELL I
WIENER.
ARE WE THE BILL.
WILL HOLD IT OPEN WHETHER OTHER
MEMBERS COME.
LOOKING GOOD AND WE WILL THANK
YOU WILL NOW GO TO OUR NEXT BILL
THANKS TO THE MONITOR HERTZBERG.
AND THAT'S SB.
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU AMEND
SHERRIN MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS.
THE JOINT AUTHORED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL RESEARCH ON THIS
COMMITTEE SO TO THE EXTENT --
YOU LIKE TO PARTICIPATE THIS IS
OF SOMETHING THAT SHE HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN FOR MANY YEARS.
AND WITH RESPECT TO LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR AS WELL.
RECOGNIZE THAT THE ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY FROM NEW JERSEY TO
TEXAS TO ALASKA.
THERE HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT.
MOVEMENT TO FOCUS ON REFORMING
THE PRE TRIAL JUSTICE SYSTEM PRE
TRIAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS THAT.
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE YOU'RE
INNOCENT YOU'RE PROVEN GUILTY
AND WERE YOU ARRESTED WHEN THE
HANDCUFFS ARE PUT ON UP UNTIL
THE TIME WHEN YOU ACTUALLY ARE
DETERMINED BY A JURY. TO IT
WHETHER YOU'RE GUILTY OR NOT
GUILTY WHAT DO YOU DO HOW DO WE
DEAL WITH THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
AND IT'S IT IT IT PROVES TO BE
SOMETHING THAT -- TREATS PEOPLE
BASED UPON THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THEY GREW UP.
IN VERY DIFFERENT MEANS WE'VE
DEALT LAST YEARS YOU KNOW --
WITH THE BAIL ISSUE.
ON IN OTHER ISSUES OF PRE TRIAL --
BUT JUSTICE.
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY
IS A BILL THAT LOOKS AT THESE
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT Là
WORKING GROUP -- IN A STUDY
GROUP IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THAT RECOMMENDED ABOLISHING
MONEY BAIL AND REPLACING IT WITH
VALIDATED RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS.
TURNS OUT THAT. FORTY NINE OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOLS WAS A RISK ASSESSMENT TOOL.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT -- IS SIS
THE JUDGE IN DETERMINING FLIGHT
RISKS AND PUBLIC SAFETY RISKS BY
ANSWER ASKING A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS LOOKING INTO THE
BACKGROUND OF THE PERSON BEING
CHARGED. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE TREATED JUSTLY.
TURNS OUT THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE STUDY BY THE PRE
TRIAL JUSTICE INSTITUTE
INDICATED ONLY TWO POINT 9% OF
CALIFORNIANS.
LIVE IN A COUNTY THAT USES A
VALIDATED RISK ASSESSMENT TOOL.
AND SO WHAT THIS WHAT THIS BILL
DOES FOR THE FORTY NINE COUNTIES
THAT CURRENTLY HAVE THESE TOOLS
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PROCESS
FOR THESE TOOLS ARE IN FACT.
VALIDATED.
ON THE CUT THESE TOOLS COME IN
MANY SIZES AND SHAPES SUMMER
PRODUCED BY FOR PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS SUMMER BY
CHARITABLE.
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THEY THEY MANY OF THEM DON'T
COVER THE MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
EFFECTIVELY ASSESSING RISK.
SAFEGUARDS ARE ESSENTIAL FOR TWO
REASONS MEMBERS ONE RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOLS LACK OPENNESS
AND TRANSPARENCY NECESSARY FOR
AN HONEST EVALUATION.
ELIMINATION OF DISPARATE INCOME
OUTCOMES EXCUSE ME BASED UPON
RACE ECONOMIC STATUS AMONG OTHER
FACTORS AND SECONDLY. TO ENSURE
THE ACCURACY THE TOOLS NEED TO
GO THROUGH WHAT IS CALLED THE
VALIDATION PROCESS OUR REGULAR
CALIBRATION.
OF THEIR PREDICTABLE CUP OF
PREDICTIVE CAPACITY USING
LOCALIZE DATA.
AND SO WITH THIS BILL WE ARE
PUTTING ON WE WERE NOT REQUIRING
COUNTIES TO USE VALIDATED THE
THESE TOOLS BUT ONCE THEY USE
THEM WERE BASICALLY PUTTING ON
BUMPERS.
YEAH EIGHT YOU'VE GOT IT TO THE
BOWLING LANE IF YOU WILL WORDS
ARE BALLS COULD MEAN UNNECESSARY
DEPRIVING SOMEONE OF THEIR
PERSONAL LIBERTY OR COMPROMISING
PUBLIC SAFETY THIS BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING BY SETTING UP THREE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS.
ONE ANY COUNTY THAT USES IT A
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOL MUST
VALIDATE THAT TO ON A REGULAR
BASIS EVERY SIX MONTHS.
TO BOMB ANY TOOL USED IN
CALIFORNIA MUST BE TRANSPARENT
THAT MEANS THE COUNTIES NEED TO
TELL THE PUBLIC EXACTLY HOW THE
RISK.
ASSESSMENT SCORES ARE BEING
CALCULATED NOTHING WORSE THAN
YOU HAVE A TOOL SOMEONE SAYS --
YOUR HIGH RISK WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHY OR WHAT THE FACTORS ARE
WHAT THEY CONSIDERED WHETHER
COMMUNITIES OVER POLICE TO
WHATEVER IT WAS.
AND THREE COUNTIES DUE TO
COLLECT AND RETAIN AND PUBLISH
DATA ON THEIR PRE TRIAL RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOLS SO THAT THEY
CAN BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
SO THIS IS IT'S CERTAINLY GREW
OUT OF THE EFFORTS THAT WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGED IN THIS LONG
DISCUSSION ON BAIL.
ARM IN DEALING WITH THIS VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUE OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE ADMINISTER JUSTICE IN A
FAIR AND UNBIASED WAY -- IN
TREATING PEOPLE -- A
APPROPRIATELY BEFORE JURY HAS
MADE A DETERMINATION WITH THAT A
GOOD WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY AND
FAVORS MEASURE.
ARE YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU FOR HAVING MADE A
MY NAME IS TOM HOFFMAN I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS.
THIRTY ONE YEARS SO -- DIVIDED
BETWEEN INGLEWOOD PD FOR ABOUT
TWENTY WAS SACRAMENTO PD FOR
ABOUT.
ELEVEN I RETIRED AND THEN IN --
TWO THOUSAND SIX LIFE CHANGING
EVENT.
I WAS ASKED TO BECOME THE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA DOLE
PAROLE.
WELL IT WAS LIFE CHANGING IN
MANY WAYS -- MOST -- GRAPHICALLY
THAT THERE IS SO MUCH OF SCIENCE
RESEARCH AND DATA ANALYSIS
AROUND THE CALIFORNIA.
A CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND OR
INMATES AND PAROLEES
SPECIFICALLY THAT I HAD NOT BEEN
AWARE OF PRIOR TO BEING THE
PAROLE DIRECTOR.
IN THE PROCESS OF EDUCATING
MYSELF AROUND THE DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE ROLE I
WAS AND I WAS INTRODUCED TO THE
CONCEPT OF A RISK ASSESSMENT.
SOMETHING THAT I HAD NOT HAD
EXPOSURE TO AS A POLICE CHIEF OR
IN ANY OF THE PREVIOUS THIRTY
ONE YEARS.
THE RISK ASSESSMENT PROCESS IS
CERTAINLY NOT INTENDED TO BE THE
SOLE SOURCE OF A DECISION MAKING
AN UNDERTAKING.
A RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS ARE
DESIGNED TO BE ABOUT 75%
ACCURATE.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND IF YOU AND I WERE TO
MAKE A CLINICAL JUDGMENT OF
SOMEBODY'S RESEARCH WILL HE OR
SHE COME BACK WILL HE OR SHE
COMMITTED AN OFFENSE.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE RIGHT ABOUT
HALF THE TIME.
AND SO BY OVERLY IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS WITH A VALID A
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOL WE IMPROVE
OUR CAPACITY TO BE RIGHT BY
ABOUT 25%.
NOT PERFECT BUT CERTAINLY I
THINK THIS MEETS A THRESHOLD AS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST
RESPONSIBILITY THE PUBLIC SAFETY
LEADERS IN IS THAT IT IS TO BE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE TO OUR
PUBLIC.
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO SERVE AS
OUR LEADERS IN THE IN THE U. A
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
ARE TAKING EVERY REASONABLE STEP
TO MITIGATE.
THE RISKS THAT ARE DECISIONS
MAKE TO THE LOWEST COMMON
DENOMINATOR WE CAN RISK
ASSESSMENT ACCOMPLISHES THAT --
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO TO KNOW
THAT THE THE AND MORE ROOMS ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF SB THIRTY SIX
AS HAVING A TOOL IS ONE THING.
THE VALIDATION PROCESS IS
ENTIRELY ANOTHER AND AND AND IT
VERY IMPORTANT BUT IN A NUTSHELL
WHAT A VALIDATION PROCESS DOES
IS IT'S IF YOU HAVE ANY NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT YOU RATED OVER
THE COURSE OF THREE YEARS OR
WHATEVER TIME PERIOD.
LET'S JUST SAY YOU RATED.
A LOTS OF THEM AS LOW RISK.
AND DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW RISK
PEOPLE OF ARE COMMITTING CRIMES
ARE NOT SHOWING UP -- FOR THE
TRIAL THE TOOLS CAN BE ADJUSTED
SO THAT THE THRESHOLD FOR THE
RATINGS REFLECT THE REALITY THAT
YOU'RE GETTING OUT OF THE TOOL
AND HOW THE COMMUNITY YOU'RE
SERVING.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE SEEN
IN THE GROWTH OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM EFFORT WERE
SOMEBODY'S STEPPING FORWARD AND
AND A DEFINED GUIDELINES.
OUTCOMES INFO AND IT PROCESS BY
WHICH WE CAN HAVE SOME
CONTINUITY AND CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE FOR A FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WE HAVE IN OUR STATE.
I HISTORICALLY HAS NOT BEEN THE
CASE WE HAVE FIFTY A COUNTIES
AND THEY DO THINGS IS RIGHTFULLY.
OF THEIR OWN WAY BUT IN THE THE
INSTANCE OF THIS THE APPLICATION
OF THE SCIENCE IN THE RESEARCH
IS IMPERATIVE AND I VERY MUCH
ONCE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY SIX
BECAUSE OF THAT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IS FOR
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
THIS MEASURE.
HELLO BAKER CENTERS BASED IN
OAKLAND WE DO NATIONAL LOCAL AND
STATE POLICY. TO HELP -- ADVANCE
RACIAL ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND TO
ENSURE DIGNITY AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE ITS PRIMARY ROLE IS TO
ENSURE THAT.
ANYONE HO ANY COUNTY OR COURT
THAT ELECTS TO USE THESE TOOLS.
THAT WE HAVE A PROCESS FOR
IDENTIFYING AND MITIGATING BY A
CEASE BY FEES BASED ON RACE
GENDER.
INCOME DISABILITY STATUS IT'S A
DATA BILL IT'S PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD WE NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER THERE ARE PATTERNS THAT
ARE OBVIOUS AND CAN ONLY BE
IDENTIFIED BY COLLECTION DATA.
THAT SOME PEOPLE.
ARE BEING TREATED UNFAIRLY AND
THEREFORE THE TOOLS HAVE TO BE
ADJUSTED -- MR HOPPER SOMEBODY
JUST IN THERE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
ELEVATORS TALK ABOUT ADJUSTING
AND FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ONE MINUTE YOU'RE
MEMBERS ARE NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TREES
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE -- INTO A
LONG LINE WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
BETWEEN I APOLOGIZE -- WE'RE
STATE HUESO STATION GRILL
OFFENSE LAWYERS DOING SOME
INTENSE RESEARCH ON THIS ISSUE
WE HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR RESPONSES WILL TALK TO
THEM GOING FORWARD.
SO DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION UPPER HOPING TO GET
THEIR LESLIE CALDWELL PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WARREN WASHBURN WITH THE CENTER
ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT.
RENEE MANNER WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT.
IF ANYONE WITH THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT AND ALSO
A CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL THANK
YOU.
JERRY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT -- MY
LOOK I FOUND THOSE WITH ME BEIN
SPORT.
ISRAEL VIA WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
LINES FOR YOU THE COMMUNITY
JUSTICE IN FULL SUPPORT.
MICHAEL WINDOWS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION FOR SUPPORT.
YOUR MIND BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
I LAND ALONG WITH THE WEATHERMAN
GROUP HERE ON BEHALF OF NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DANIELLE CANNOT
CONSERVE THE HAVE THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION APOLOGIES
THAT ARE LETTER DIDN'T MAKE IT
INTO THE ANALYSIS WE ARE SUPPORT
AGAINST OUR SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
MADOC ASALA COMMUNITIES UNITED
RESTORE YOU DOES THIS SUMMER
SUPPORT. ONE LOOTERS ME BONDS
WONDERFUL SUPPORT.
GREAT DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NINETY WE HAVE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY -- OR
MEMBERS.
OKAY NEVER HEARD BURKE.
SENATOR MOORE Là.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT ONE PROVISION IN --
PROPOSAL THIS BILL REQUIRES ANY
PRE TRIAL RISK ASSESSMENT TOOL
USED BY PRE TRIAL SERVICES
AGENCY. TO BE VALIDATED ON A
REGULAR BASIS BUT NO LESS
FREQUENTLY THAN EVERY SIX MONTHS
AND PROVIDES THAT A PRETRIAL.
SERVICES AGENCY MAY COORDINATE
WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
VALIDATE A PRE TRIAL RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOL.
HOW DO WE COME UP WITH SIX
MONTHS THAT SEEMS?
VERY FREE.
WELL THERE IS DISCUSSION AMONG
THE VARIOUS GROUPS TO FIGURE
WHAT THAT ISN'T RELATED TO COSTS
THE IDEA IS IS S TO JUST GATHER
DATA AND CONTINUALLY JUST TO
MAKE SURE AS ELLA BAKER.
TESTIFIED TO GET THIS THING IS
FARING JOSH AND HOW IT WORKS
IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE KIND OF A
BROAD SENSE FROM THE EXPERTS IN
THE COMMUNITY BUT WE ARE STILL
IN DISCUSSIONS TO SEE IF THERE
SHOULD BE ADJUSTMENTS ON THAT
NUMBER.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU MA'AM.
CURRENTLY CENTER MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I IF I COULD
BE GIVEN THE PRIVILEGE OF MOVING
THE BAIL OUT APPRECIATE THAT
JUST HAS BEEN A PLEASURE --
WORKING WITHYOU IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP -- SENATOR HERTZBERG
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE -- YOU
KNOW THE WHOLE NOTION OF THE
ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND HOW WE TRY
TO MINIMIZE THE NOTION OF BIAS
IN THE TOOLS I THINK IS.
AN ON GOING TO WORK IN PROGRESS
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
WORK -- AND I THINK -- THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WILL ONCE AGAIN LEAD
THE NATION IN TERMS OF RE
DIRECTING THIS WHOLE CONCEPT.
OF BAIL ALL WHO FALLS VICTIM TO
IT AND WHO DOESN'T SO I
APPRECIATE -- WORKING WITH YOU
ON THIS BILL -- AND I MOVE IT
MADAM CHAIR.
GREAT WE HAVE A MOTION -- CENTER
HERTZBERG WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
TAKE THE MONEY JOINT AUTHORED
JUST DID THAT THANK YOU ASHMAN
ITEM.
ALL RIGHT -- WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
QUESTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER. FIVE
SKINNER AYE MORE LACKEY.
BRADFORD MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL.
AYE MITCHELL AYE MORALE MORRELL
AYE WIENER.
ALRIGHT SO WE WILL HOLD THAT --
RULE -- BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MANY GREAT
YOU CERTAINLY THANK YOU CENTER.
OKAY [inaudible]
YES.
ALRIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
NUMBER -- SEVEN SB ONE SIXTY ONE
SENATOR BATES [inaudible]
BECAUSE HI GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS LAST SENATE
BILL I WON SIXTY ONE HELP STEM
THE INFLUX OF DANGEROUS NEW
DRUGS.
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES BY ADDING
FAT NOW TO A CATEGORY OF DRUGS
SUCH AS HEROIN THAT PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENTS BASED ON
THE WEIGHT.
AN INDIVIDUAL POSSESSES FOR SALE
OR DISTRIBUTION THE BILL
SPONSORED BY THE ORANGE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND I AM
PLEASED TO HAVE A GROUP OF A CO
AUTHOR SAW WHO ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY BY
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
VAN ELLS OFFICIALLY THE
DEADLIEST DRUG IN AMERICA.
THIS UP TO FIFTY TIMES MORE
POTENT THAN PHARMACEUTICAL GRADE
HEROIN OFTEN MIXED INTO HEROIN
AND OTHER DRUGS WITHOUT THE
KNOWLEDGE OF USERS.
IS ALSO CHEAPER TO MAKE IT
EASIER TO TRANSPORT THAN HEROIN
THESE FACTORS COMBINED TO MAKE
FAT NOW THE EMERGING GO TO DRUG
FOR CARTELS AND THAT'S WHO THIS
BILL IS ESSENTIALLY TARGETING.
BECAUSE OF FAN KNOWS POTENCY
OVERDOSES ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
FATAL BECAUSE IT CAN SHUT DOWN
THE LUNGS IN AND IN AS LITTLE AS
TWO MINUTES SO VICTIMS ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE RESCUED.
THAN THOSE WHO OVERDOSED ON
OTHER DRUGS IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT FAT NAIL CAN BE DEADLY
SIMPLY IF IT BECOMES AIRBORNE OR
MAKES CONTACT WITH THE SKIN.
POSING SIGNIFICANT DANGERS TO
FIRST RESPODERS WHO ARE
ATTEMPTING TO RESUSCITATE A
VICTIM.
SADLY WE ARE ALREADY SEEING
DEATHS THIS YEAR BECAUSE MY
PH<c.cyan> N OVERDOSES ACROSS OUR</c>
STATE.
JANUARY SEVENTH IN FRESNO COUNTY
ONE MAN DIED TWO OTHERS
HOSPITALIZED AFTER SNORTING FAN
MAIL THAT THEY THOUGHT WAS
COCAINE JANUARY THIRTEENTH THEN
SHOOK CHICO ONE PERSON DIED IN
TWELVE WERE HOSPITALIZED AFTER
OLD OVERDOSING ON A DRUG.
SUSPECTED TO BE FOUND NOW STATE
TRENCAVEL ODD FIT KNOWS
PROLIFERATION EVEN THOUGH THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS FROM OPIOID
OVERDOSE AS FELL SLIGHTLY.
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DEATHS RELATED TO FAT
NAIL USE INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
PEOPLE DIED FROM FAT NOW
OVERDOSES AND TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS MORE THAN
FOUR TIMES THE EIGHTY ONE WHO
DIED.
ARE FROM THE DRUGS IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN THIS IS MY
FOURTH YEAR ATTEMPTING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL SO I WANT TO
DISPEL SOME OF THE CRITICISMS
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OR READ.
SB ONE SIXTY ONE IN NO WAY
IMPACT SENTENCES FOR END USERS
THOSE USING ON MEDICAL FAT NOW
ALSO FOR IS LEGITIMATE AND
PRESCRIBE PURPOSE.
THIS BILL IS NOT A WAR ON DRUGS
STYLE CRIMINALIZATION OF LOW
LEVEL DEALERS BUT INSTEAD CRACKS
DOWN ON THE DRUG CARTELS AND
HIGH LEVEL DRUG DEALERS.
THAT ARE DISTRIBUTING AND
TRAFFICKING AND SELLING MASS
QUANTITIES OF THIS POISON.
THE BILL WOULD ONLY GOING TO
AFFECT FROM SOMEONE IS CAUGHT
WITH A KILOGRAM OR MORE THAT'S
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF.
POUNDS ODD JUST ILLUSTRATE A
KILOGRAM OF FAT NOW HAS A STREET
VALUE OF ALMOST A MILLION
DOLLARS AND HAS THE POTENCY TO
KILL UPWARDS OF FOUR MILLION
PEOPLE OR ABOUT 10% OF OUR
STATE'S POPULATION.
IT ONLY TAKES POINT TWO FIVE MIL
MIL.
MILLIGRAMS TO TREAT OUR FOR ODD
TINA REVOCATION AND CERTAINLY
THAT'S WITH TERMINAL ILLNESSES.
TO RECEIVE THE MAXIMUM SENTENCE
OF TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
ANY INDIVIDUAL WOULD HAVE TO BE
CAUGHT WITH OVER EIGHTY
KILOGRAMS OF FAN NOW WHICH IS
ENOUGH TO KILL.
OUR THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION PEOPLE ABOUT THE
POPULATION OF THE UNITED STATES.
SB ONE SIXTY ONE DOES NOT
DETRACT FROM CALIFORNIA'S
INCREASING INVESTMENT IN
REHABILITATION SERVICES BUT
COMPLEMENTED BY REDUCING THE
ILLEGAL FAT NO TRADE IS THAT
SOURCE AGAIN.
THE HUGE DRUG CARTELS THAT BRING
IN MASSIVE QUANTITIES OF THOSE
THIS WHICH ARE ACTUALLY --
DISTRIBUTED OR MAKES THE END TO
ARE THE CURRENT HEROIN AND
COCAINE SOURCES.
ARE WITH ME TODAY IS ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
ASSISTANT SURE OF JEFF HALLECK
WHO CAN ELABORATE ON SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOUSE AND WHY THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL.
ARE IN THERE ON THE TOWN.
TO ELIMINATE FAT NOW FROM ITS
IMPORTATION INTO OUR COUNTRY
[inaudible]
MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JEFF
HELLO CAM ASSISTANT SHERIFF WITH
THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
I AM PLEASED TODAY TO REPRESENT
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL ONE SIXTY ONE WHICH
INSURERS THOSE WHO POSSESS FAT
NOW FOR PURPOSES OF DISTRIBUTION
OR SALE WILL BE ADEQUATELY HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL MAKE THE
PENALTIES FOR SUCH TYPE OF
POSSESSION EQUIVALENT TO OTHER
DANGEROUS NARCOTICS LIKE COCAINE
AND HEROIN.
IN MY CAPACITY IS ASSISTING
SHARE FOR THE FIELD OPERATIONS
AND INVESTIGATIONS COMMAND WITH
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I
OVERSEE ALL NARCOTICS TASK FORCE
AND INVESTIGATIONS IN OUR
JURISDICTION.
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WE HAVE SEEN
AN INCREASE IN THE PREVALENCE OF
FAT AND ALL.
AS YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATION WAS
PREVIOUSLY INTRODUCED EACH YEAR
SINCE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN THIS COMMITTEE SAW THE
WISDOM OF THE BILL AND APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY.
THIS WAS FOLLOWED BY UNANIMOUS
APPROVAL BY THE FULL SENATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT LEGISLATION
WAS NOT APPROVED BY THE ASSEMBLY.
IN THE THREE YEARS SINCE THE
BILL WAS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED
THE PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH FAN
ALL HAVE GROWN.
IN THE LAST DECADE STATES ON THE
EAST COAST OF SEEN THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS RELATED TO FANEUIL
SKYROCKET.
THE TREND SEEN ON THE EAST COAST
NOW IS MADE ITS WAY TO THE WEST
COAST HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS THERE
HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THE ILLICIT USE OF THE DRUG
FENNEL.
IN ORANGE COUNTY FROM TWENTY
TWELVE TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
SAW THREE HUNDRED AND 30%
INCREASEIN THE NUMBER OF DEATHS
THAT OCCURRED WITH FEDERAL
PRESENT.
FROM.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE AMOUNT OF A LISTED
FENTON ALL ANALYZED BY THE
ORANGE COUNTY CRIME LAB MORE
THAN DOUBLED.
ALARMINGLY IN ON THE ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
JURISDICTION FENTON ALL SEIZURE
SKYROCKETED FROM LESS THAN ONE
POUND TO MORE THAN FORTY FOUR
POUNDS IN JUST TWO YEARS.
A FATAL OVERDOSE OFFEND ALL CAN
BE TWO MILLIGRAMS FOR A LITTLE
BIT OF PERSPECTIVE THAT IS A
SUGAR PACKET SIZED BAG OF FENNEL
THE CAN CONTAIN FIVE HUNDRED
LETHAL DOSES OF FAT AND ALL.
THE FORTY FOUR POUNDS SEIZE BY
THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CONTAINS MORE THAN TEN MILLION
FATAL DOSES.
ENOUGH AND ALSO OVERDOSE THE
ENTIRE POPULATION OF ORANGE
COUNTY THREE TIMES.
IN ADDITION TO THE DANGERS THIS
DRUG POSES TO USERS IT ALSO POSE
A SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO FIRST
RESPONDERS.
FAT NOT CAN BE ABSORBED THROUGH
THE SKIN.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS WHO
KNOWINGLY OR UNKNOWINGLY COME IN
CONTACT WITH THE DRUG COULD FACE
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH RISKS.
AS A RESULT IN THE LAST YEAR WE
THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AT REVAMPS OUR
PROTOCOL FOR HANDLING OF ALL
NARCOTICS.
SOME MAY QUESTION WHY WE
CONTINUE TO STRONGLY PURSUE THE
LEGISLATION DESPITE ITS CONTINUE
TO FEED.
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND CONCERNS
WITH INCREASED SENTENCING BUT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH NEEDED TO ELIMINATE THE
THREAT OF DRUGS.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON BOTH THE
SUPPLY AND THE DEMAND IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE'RE WORKING TO EDUCATE
OUR YOUTH AND OUR PARENTS THERE
ARE DRUG USE IS LIKE THESE
PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY OUR COUNTIES WERE
TO SAVE THE LIVES OF ADDICTS BY
HAVING ALL DEPUTIES CARRYING
NALOXONE OPIOID ANTAGONIST IN --
TWENTY FIFTEEN ONE CST
IMPLEMENTED A NO LOCKS ON
PROGRAM ONLY THREE DOSES OF
NALOXONE WERE DEPLOYED TO THREE
INDIVIDUALS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE
DOSES WERE USED ON THIRTY EIGHT
SEPARATE INDIVIDUALS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN IS TRACKING TO EXCEED
ALL PREVIOUS YEARS COMBINED.
AS WE ARE EMPLOYING NUMBER
STRATEGIES WE WE NEED.
NOW WE NEED THE FORCE OF THE LAW
TO ASSIST US IN HOLDING
ACCOUNTABLE THE PROFITEERS OF
ADDICTION.
THIS LEGISLATION IS NEEDED TO
ASSIST LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FINALLY GETTING AHEAD OF THE
ILLEGAL CELL OFFEND ALL BEFORE
WE START SEEING THE HIGH LEVEL
OF OVERDOSE WE TELL THESE BEING
EXPERIENCED IN OTHER STATES.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY ONE
APPROPRIATELY TARGET STEELERS
RATHER THAN USERS.
IN MANY CASES DEALERS WILL LESS
FAT AND ALL AND OTHER DRUGS
PRIOR TO THE SALE UNBEKNOWNST TO
THE DRUG AND YET END DRUG USER.
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES IS BASED ON
THE PENALTY STRUCTURE WHERE
INCENTIVIZING FENTON ALL OVER
HEROIN AND COCAINE EVEN THOUGH
FAN ALL IS FAR MORE DANGEROUS.
IN APPROVING SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY ONE AND PUTTING FAN ALL IN
THE SAME CATEGORY AS HEROIN AND
COCAINE WE'RE SENDING A MESSAGE
TO DRUG DEALERS THAT THERE WILL
BE CONSEQUENCES IF THEY CHOOSE
TO PEDDLE THIS DEADLY SUBSTANCE.
I ASK YOU TODAY TO JOIN THE
NUMEROUS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB
ONE SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
JOHNSON CLAIMED AFTER THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO HERE IN SUPPORT.
JOHN LEVEL ASSOCIATION OF DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
CALIFORNIA -- COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION LA COUNTY
PROFESSIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ALL IN SUPPORT.
BRENDAN UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LUCIA MUCH LARA BE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
RANGE FROM WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE CAN HAVE A TWO AT
THE TABLE AND THEN THE OTHERS
JUST AT THE MIKE.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE GOING
BACK IS FOR DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IS A
NATIONAL NON PROFIT DEDICATED.
TO REPLACING THE FAILED DRUG WAR
WITH POLICIES BASED ON
COMPASSION SCIENCE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND RESPECT FOR HUMAN RIGHTS --
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S
BUILT ON THE SAME POLICIES THAT
FAILED TO PROTECT US FROM
PROBLEMS RELATED TO HEROIN
COCAINE AND FUN.
IT WILL ADD AN ADDITIONAL THREE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THE SENTENCES
AND WILL NOT REDUCE AVAILABILITY
A FINAL.
IT WILL CONTRIBUTE TO PRISON
OVERCROWDING.
AN OVERLY LONG SENTENCES FOR
PEOPLE INCLUDING LOW LEVEL DRUG
MEALS.
AND PEOPLE IN POSSESSION OF A
SUBSTANCE THAT CONTAINS FENNEL
AND THEY DIDN'T KNOW IT.
TYPICALLY DEFENDANTS WHO HAVE NO
INFORMATION TO TRADE.
LOW LEVEL ON THE TOTEM POLE
[inaudible]
AND NOT EMPOWERED TO SAY NO.
TO DRUG DEALERS ABOUT THEM IN
THE SYSTEM.
IT WOULD APPLY THE SAME
PENALTIES TO SUBSTANCES
CONTAINING FENTANYL THAT HAVE
BEEN APPLIED TO DECADES TO
COCAINE AND HEROIN.
AND WE KNOW THAT APPLYING THESE
ENHANCEMENTS DIDN'T WORK.
COCAINE AND HEROIN ARE MORE
WIDELY AVAILABLE MORE POWERFUL
AND CHEAPER THAN EVER BEFORE SO
WHY WOULD WE USE THE SAME FAILED
APPROACH FOR FEDERAL.
ALSO THERE'S THE COST BENEFIT
QUESTION. ONE YEAR OF PRISON
COST EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE
YEAR OF METHADONE TREATMENT.
IS FOUR THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
WE BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT IT'S
MORE INTELLIGENT TO SEND
SEVENTEEN PEOPLE TO METHADONE
THEN PUT EVEN ONE PERSON IN
PRISON FOR ANOTHER YEAR.
IT'S MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND
ENHANCES PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE APPROACH SUGGEST SB ONE
SIXTY ONE DIDN'T WORK FOR
COCAINE AND HEROIN IT WON'T WORK
FOR FEDERAL.
WE STRONGLY ADVISE THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY TO INVEST IN
TREATMENT.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HARM REDUCTION
POLICIES.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA HERE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB.
ONE SIXTY ONE I WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE ON AND
ALSO ADD THAT THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT THERE HAS BEEN AN INCREASE
AND FINAL RELATED DEATHS AND
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT.
FINAL IS AN EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
DRUG.
HOWEVER SB ONE SIXTY ONE IS NOT
GOING TO CHANGE EITHER OF THOSE
FACTORS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THEIR EXISTING
PENALTIES THAT ALREADY ADDRESS.
THE ISSUE THE CONDUCT AT ISSUE
IN SB.
ONE SIXTY ONE A PERSON WHO
POSSESSES FINAL FOR SALE CAN BE
PUNISHED BY UP TO FOUR YEARS IN
JAIL UNDER EXISTING LAW.
AND A PERSON CAN BE PUNISHED BY
UP TO FIVE YEARS IN JAIL FOR
SIMPLY OFFERING TO GIVE AWAY
FINAL THERE IS NO NEED TO EXPAND
THE LAW FURTHER.
SECOND SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS
HAVE BEEN STUDIED EXTENSIVELY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND HAVE
GENERATED NO CONCLUSIVE EVIDENCE
THAT THEY DID TO HER OR PREVENT
CRIME.
AS TO THE PARTICULAR TYPE OF
ENHANCEMENT AT ISSUE IN THIS
BILL AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID WE
NEED LOOK NO FURTHER THAN OUR
OWN BACKYARD TO SEE THAT THIS
ADDITIONAL PUNISHMENT AS APPLIED
TO OTHER DRUGS.
HAS NOT WORKED.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THESE
ENHANCEMENTS ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE TO HEROIN AND COCAINE
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE NUMBER OF
HEROIN RELATED OVER DEATH
OVERDOSE DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA
INCREASED BY 21% BETWEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN ANDTWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
THE NUMBER OF COCAINE RELATED
DEATH -- INCREASED BY 18% GIVEN
THAT THE EXISTING ENHANCEMENTS
HAVE NOT IMPROVED OUR SAFETY
THERE IS LITTLE SENSE AND
EXTENDING THE POLICY TO YET
ANOTHER DRUG.
AND LASTLY AND WITH RESPECT TO
THE SENATOR THE EXISTING HAND
ENHANCEMENTS ARE REMNANTS OF THE
WAR ON DRUGS.
WHICH WITH A HARMFUL FAILED
APPROACH TO DRUG POLICY THAT HAS
BEEN CHARACTERIZED BY
DISINVESTMENT IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WASTED RESOURCES
REJECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACHES APPROACHES TO
SUBSTANCE USE.
AN EXCESSIVE PRISON AND JAIL
SENTENCES THAT FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. FOR ALL OF
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB.
ONE SIXTY ONE OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING EMILY HARRIS AT THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LESLIE CALDWELL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME BONDS IN
OPPOSITION.
JANUARY TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NINE
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING AMBER ROSE HOWARD
WITH CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND WE OPPOSE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING -- NINE WE'LL
TAKE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR MITCHELL.
SURVEYS I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
HOWEVER.
I AM CLEAR THAT FINN TO KNOW IS
A BAD ACTOR THAT DOES GOES
WITHOUT SAY.
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE I THINK WE
ALL CAN AGREE ON THAT.
I SPENT -- QUITE A BIT OF TIME
IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
LEARNING -- AND WORKING HARD TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE GOT TO THE
PLACES POLICY MAKERS WERE WE
THOUGHT SINCE ENHANCEMENTS.
WHERE THE THING TO DO? THIRTY
PLUS YEARS AGO I HAVE WORKED TO
PEEL SOME OF THOSE BACK
[inaudible]
AND WHAT.
I HOPE TODAY.
IS THAT WE ALL CAN DO BETTER --
AND TALK ABOUT FROM WHAT WE KNOW
TODAY BASED ON DATA IN RESEARCH.
ABOUT WHAT WILL WORK.
I THINK WITH POLICY MAKERS WE
GET INTO THIS WE DISABILITY
HEARING COMMITTEES UP OR DOWN.
AND WE COLLECTIVELY DON'T
PERHAPS BEEN ENOUGH TIME.
THE AISLES EVEN HAVING
MEANINGFUL PUBLIC POLICY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT.
CAN BE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
SHOULD BE DIFFERENT.
CENTER STONE SCHEDULED TO MEET
WITH ME ABOUT A WEEK AGO WE HAD
A CONVERSATION ON FEDERAL HE
WANT TO COME TO ME TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
IN MY SUGGESTION TO HIM THEN WAS
LET'S CALL ALL OF THE INVESTED
INTEREST TOGETHER AND HAVE
CONVERSATION AS OPPOSED TO US AS
POLICY MAKERS INTRODUCING
LEGISLATION WE INTRODUCE A BILL
THAT'S WHAT WE COME HERE TO DO.
AND TALK COLLECTIVELY AND LEARN
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT --
SUBSTANCE.
ABUSE A DISORDER -- POLICY
SPECIALISTS -- SURVIVORS IF YOU
WILL AND AND AND HAVE A
MEANINGFUL COP PUBLIC POLICY
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT WE KNOW.
TO BE TRUE TODAY -- I CAN'T
SUPPORT. EIGHT A CITIZEN HAND
SMIT BILL WEYAND THE RESEARCH
STACKS AS HIGH AS I AM TALL
ABOUT HOW THAT DIDN'T BOLD WHALE
FOR US AS THE STATE --
ECONOMICALLY IT HAD ZERO IMPACT
ON THE AVAILABILITY OF DRUGS ON
THE STREETS IT HAD NO IMPACT ON
IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY AND SO
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN CONTINUING
POLICIES THAT WE KNOW DON'T WORK --
I THINK IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE OF US
TO SIMPLY DO THAT AS OPPOSED TO
STEPPING BACK AND REALLY TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT A BRIEF ALL THE
PARTIES TO TOGETHER THAT IN A
DISCUSSION.
ABOUT WHAT CAN SO I'M HOPING --
SENATOR STONE -- ON AND PERHAPS
JOINED BY YOU MISS BATES AND I
AM MORE THAN WILLING TO TO BE A
CO CONVENER IN THAT KIND OF
CONVERSATION.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME I I I CANNOT
AND WILL NOT CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
BILLS -- THAT THAT WE HAVE
PROVEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN DON'T
HAVE THE OUTCOME WE ANTICIPATE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT
WANT TO BE A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
OTHER REAL SOLUTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FIVE SENATOR.
MOORLACH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I'M
I'M SORT OF IN THAT NO BETTERNO
WORSE CATEGORY -- IF WE'RE
FOCUSED ON HEROIN AND COCAINE.
WE SHOULD ALSO PROVIDE SOME KIND
WE HAVE THAT
DISCUSSIONS -- OFFICE SUPPORTING
THE BILL AND I JUST WONDER
CENTER BATES BE ANY REACTION TO
OUR COMMENTS.
CERTAINLY I DO YOU AND I I GUESS
WHAT IS FRUSTRATING ALL ABOUT
THIS BILL IS THAT WE WE VIEW IT
FROM THE EYES OF THE USER.
AND THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WE
ARE REALLY TRYING TO HELP WITH
OUR REHABILITATION EFFORTS.
IN OUR NONSENSE ENHANCEMENTS
SENDING THEM TO REHABILITATION.
THIS BILL AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS NOT ABOUT THE GUY THAT
USE IT IS ABOUT ABOUT THE GUY
WHO IS PRODUCING IT IN MASS
QUANTITIES AND BRING IT INTO
THIS COUNTRY.
I GUARANTEE YOU AND ALL OF THE
LITERATURE AND CERTAINLY THE
MOVIES THAT HAVE BEEN ABOUT THIS
BOTH DOCUMENTARY AND IN
FICTIONAL.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT THE HEAD
OF THIS DON'T USE.
THEY REALLY ARE PROFITEERS AND
THE RINGING IN LARGE QUANTITIES
THAT ARE THEN BROKEN DOWN AND
LACED INTO THESE OTHER DRUGS.
THEY DO HAVE SENSE ENHANCEMENTS
BUT INTO YOU CUT OFF.
THE IMPORTATION OF THESE LARGE
QUANTITIES YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM THAT FELT NOW
IS PRODUCING AND CREATING IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THERE'S A NATIONAL CONCERN NOW
IT'S BEEN ON CNN.
IT'S BEYOND ME AND ON NBC AND
WHAT THIS DRUG IS DOING AND I'D
LIKE TO SUGGEST IT IS SO
DANGEROUS THAT IT CAN BE USED WE
CERTAINLY KNOW BY TERRORISTS.
IN IF WE DON'T STOP THE
IMPORTATION IN THESE LARGE
QUANTITIES THAT IT WILL BE ON
SERVE OUR WATCH THAT SOMETHING
HORRIFIC OF HAPPENS SO I AM.
I THINK WHAT SENATOR MITCHELL
SAID HERE PERHAPS THAT'S THE
PATH WE OUGHT.
TO DO A LITTLE SIDE STEP ON THAT
I WILL NOT FEES TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE IMPORTATION.
OF THIS DRUG WHICH IS KILLING
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE DOING IT.
IF NOT TOUCHING THEM IT'S NOT
TOUCHING THEM THERE BRING IT IN
HERE IN TRUCKLOADS AND YOU KNOW
THAT FROM WHAT THE SHARE SAID
ABOUT THIS FORTY POUNDS.
ARE THAT WAS SIDE YOU KNOW
CAPTURED AT THE BORDER ALL OF
THAT SO THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO
PAY ATTENTION TO AND MAYBE WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IS HAVE THIS
CONVENE.
LET'S TALK WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO
THE FENCE AND HANDS FROM THE WAY
TO GO WOULD SURELY IF YOU PUT
THE GUY WHOSE TRUCK LOADING IN
HERE FOR TWENTY AWAY FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS.
THAT LEAVES ONE TRUCKLOAD OR
TWENTY TRUCKLOADS IT HE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR GOING TO START
COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON HOW DO WE STOP IT.
AT THAT LEVEL AND WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
RESUSCITATION OF THE POOR VICTIM.
AND A OF THE THE GUY ON THE
STREET WITH YOU KNOW SOMETHING
WASTE INTO A PATH OF COCAINE OR
WHATEVER USE FOR THAT.
SO I WANT US TO CONCENTRATE ON
THAT THAT'S WHY I KEEP BRINGING
IT UP.
NOW I'M GETTING NATIONAL
ATTENTION ON IT NOT ME
PERSONALLY BUT THE DRUG AND
WOMEN DOING IN THIS COUNTRY.
ATTENTION GUY NOT BECAUSE I
THINK WE NEED TO SO I'M I'M
HAPPY TO TO GO WITH SENATOR
MITCHELL WHAT I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU TO DO TODAY IS ON GIVE ME A
RECONSIDERATION OR YOU KNOW HOW
OFTEN OF THE STUDY BILL DO
SOMETHING WITH IT.
SO WE KEEP THE DISCUSSION AND
THE DEBATE -- ALIVE BECAUSE I
JUST DON'T WANT TO SEE US IN TWO
OR THREE YEARS TALKING ABOUT AN
ENTIRE POPULATION OF SOME SMALL
CITY WIPED OUT SOMEONE FIGURED
OUT HOW TO DROP IT IN THE WATER.
OR FLIGHT OVER THE CITY ARE IN A
DRONE WHO KNOWS I MEAN THOSE ARE
THERE'S CRAZY PEOPLE OUT THERE
WE KNOW THAT AND THEY ARE NOT
THE USERS.
MIND YOU THEY ARE NOT THE USERS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE GOT TO
STOP THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTENTION INTENDED TO DO HARM.
TO US THIS COUNTRY IN OUR PEOPLE
AND OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THE MANAGER -- SENATOR JACKSON
AND SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU I
I AM INTRIGUED BY THE IDEA OF
MAKING THIS A STUDY BILL.
AND WONDER IF THERE WOULD BE
SOME CONSIDERATION I'LL TELL YOU
WHY -- YOUR YOUR FRUSTRATION I
THINK AS WELL NOTED.
I THINK AS SENATOR MITCHELL
INDICATED THE GUYS THAT ARE
DOING THIS ARE BEYOND REACH
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DISCOURAGE
THEM FROM MAKING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BY SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
PUT YOU IN JAIL FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT EVEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND IT IS THOSE MULES IT IS THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE -- IS SORT OF THE
LOW HANGING FRUIT WHO WERE THE
ONES THAT WE CATCH AND THE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY
MANUFACTURING AND SMUGGLING THIS
STUFF IN.
NOTHING HAPPENS TO THEM
SOMETHING SHOULD HAPPEN TO THEM
AND I'M ALL FOR THAT AND I THINK
WE ALL ARE BECAUSE YOU YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT FENNEL IS A
DISASTROUS DRUG AND I'M.
NOTING HERE YOU'VE BROUGHT THIS
BILL TWO OTHER TIMES I'VE BEEN
STAYING BOTH OTHER TIMES NOT
VOTED NO BUT NOT VOTED YES.
BECAUSE I THINK THERE MAY BE
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE DONE TO
TRY TO ADDRESS WHETHER WE HAVE
INTERDICTION REAL INTERDICTION --
WE KNOW THESE THINGS GENERALLY
pNOT MISTAKEN AND IT AND THIS IS
WHAT WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING.
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING
SOMETHING WE HAVE TRIED FOR
YEARS THINKING THAT WOULD
DISCOURAGE PEOPLE IF WE GAVE
THEM LONG PRISON SENTENCES BUT
IT HASN'T DONE A THING.
SO I WOULD -- I WOULD SUPPORT A
MEASURE THAT THAT THIS MEASURE
IF IT COULD BECOME A STUDY BILL
TO TRY TO FIND OUT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY. TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF FENNEL OR TO TO GET
RID OF FENNEL OVERALL THERE MUST
BE SOMETHING WE CAN DO BUT I I
AGREE I DON'T THINK THAT.
ADDING AN ENHANCEMENT OR PENALTY
IT HAS IN ANY WAY DONE ANYTHING
TO REDUCE OUR DRUG -- ISSUES IN
THIS STATE AND COUNTRY WHICH I
KNOW IS WHAT YOU WANT TO DO SO
IF YOU WOULD BE WILLING TO DO
THAT I WOULD CERTAINLY.
BE SUPPORTIVE BUT AS THE BILL IS
NOW I I ALSO CANCER.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU --
THE DEBATE I HAVE A DEEP AND
PROFOUND RESPECT FOR YOU YOU
KNOW THAT AND I SHARE YOUR
PASSION I HAVE SEEN.
THE DOCUMENTARIES.
BUT WHAT CONCERNS ME IS THIS
SOUNDS.
EERILY SIMILAR TO THE DEBATE IN
THESE HALLOWED HALLS THIRTY
YEARS AGO.
WITH AROUND CRACK COCAINE.
AND WE THOUGHT CALMED -- TO
AARON EERILY SIMILAR BECAUSE THE
FOCUS THEN WAS ON THE CAR TALES
WE LOVE YOU THAT WORK GUARDED --
AND IT BECAME A SLIPPERY SLOPE
IN TERMS OF THE POLICIES THAT
THE OF MICHELLE AIM WITH THE
CARTELS THAT WE'RE BRINGING IT
INTO OUR CUT COUNTRY.
AND WE KNOW WHAT HAS HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS IN
TERMS OF WHO ULTIMATELY ENDED UP
SERVING -- MANY MANY YEARS
LOCKED UP.
IT WAS NOT JUST THE CARTELS AND
SO THAT'S WHAT I MEAN I DON'T
WANT US TO GO TO ONCE AGAIN
WILLINGLY KNOWINGLY ENGAGE IN A
SLIPPERY SLOPE PROCESS.
OF POLICY MAKING.
I HEAR YOU WHEN I GET IT AND IF
I COULD BE CONVINCED THAT WE
COULD CRAFT LEGISLATION IN SUCH
A WAY.
THAT JUST THOSE WHO BRING IN HE
LARGE AMOUNTS WOULD BE IMPACTED
THAT IS NOT BEEN THE EXPERIENCE
OF THIS BODY.
AND WE CAN GO BACK AND DOCUMENT
THAT IT IS NOT BEEN EXPERIENCE
WE NOW HAVE FOUR HUNDRED SINCE
ENHANCEMENT LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
HAS THAT HELPED.
I WOULD ARGUE NOT AND SO THAT'S
WHY CAN'T SUPPORTTHE BILL AND
AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO THINK IT'S
NOT BECAUSE I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE PROBLEM I DO -- BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE DEFINITION OF INSANITY
DOING THE SAME THING AND
EXPECTING A DIFFERENT OUTCOME.
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH THE NEW
OUTCOME THAT TO REAL THAT'S
GROUNDED AND WHAT WE KNOW TO BE
DIFFERENT TODAY BASED ON HAVING
MADE THESE POLICY DECISIONS
THIRTY YEARS AGO.
THAT THAT DID NOTHING BUT
DECIMATE MAJOR COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND DID NOT
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY OR DEATH
DECREASED ACCESS TO A DRUG WE'VE
WE DIFFERENTIATE AT THE
ENHANCEMENTS FOR ONE FORM OF THE
DRUG OVER THE OTHER.
AND THAT GOT US NO WHERE SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I CAN'T SUPPORT
[inaudible]
CENTER WIENER.
I THANK YOU ON CHARGES DODD
BRIEFLY ICE IS ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AND
I'M PASSION AROUND BUT NO THIS
IS JUST A HORRIFIC.
I SUBSTANCE THAT IS DESTROYING
LIVES AND KILLING PEOPLE -- AND
I AM VERY APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
TENACITY -- BUT I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT OF ENHANCEMENT FOR
REASONS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ARTICULATED BY DO MY SISTER
KNOWLEDGE YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE CENTER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
pCLOSE I JUST WANT TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS I HAD NOT -- AS WAS
COMMUNICATED TO YOUR OFFICE MADE
AN OFFICIAL RECOMMENDATION ON
THE BILL BECAUSE ARE ONCE AGAIN
WAS STRUGGLING WITH -- THE
KNOWLEDGE JUST AS YOU DESCRIBED
HOW MANY OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
ARE NOW BEING IMPACTED BY THIS
EXTREMELY LETHAL DRUG WHICH IS
LEGAL IN VERY SMALL QUANTITIES --
AND SO I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
THE APPROPRIATENESS OF HOW YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THIS
FACT THAT WE KNOW MORE FEDERAL
IS COMING IN WE KNOW THAT TIME.
IT'S IT'S USES EXPANDING.
AND WHERE I A FINALLY LANDED --
BASICALLY.
IN REVIEWING AGAIN MATERIALS
LAST NIGHT AND THEN HEARING THE
DISCUSSION TODAY IS THAT.
YES WE WANT.
TO IMPACT THE TRADE WE WANT TO
STOP THE CARTELS WE WANT TO STOP
THIS FROM COMING INTO OUR
COUNTRY [inaudible]
BUT IF [inaudible]
THE IF.
ADDING PENALTIES DID THAT THEN
WE WOULDN'T HAVE HERE ONE ON THE
STREET BECAUSE WE HAVE VERY
SERIOUS PENALTIES FOR HEROIN.
AND YET.
WE HAVE HERE ONE ON STREET
[inaudible]
SO.
WHERE I LANDED WAS THAT THIS
WILL NOT ACHIEVE THE GOAL THAT
IS BEING SENT OUT?
EVEN KNOWING.
HOW LEGAL AND HOW DANGEROUS THIS
DRUG IS AND HOW [inaudible]
IT'S PREVALENCE IS INCREASING
[inaudible]
I'M.
SO I THINK THAT SENATOR MITCHELL
SUGGESTION.
I IS PROBABLY GOOD ONE I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE STATE CAN DO TO
TRY TO AFFECT THIS TYPE OF THREE
BUT IT IS WORTH IT FOR SOME OF
US TO SIT DOWN WITH EXPERTS AND
THINK ABOUT IT -- I WOULD NOTE
THAT.
KIND OF QUANTITIES THAT YOU HAVE
LISTED IN THE BILL ARE ALREADY --
HAVE CERES PENALTIES UNDER
FEDERAL AND USUALLY IN THIS TYPE
OF TRADE WHICH GOES BEYOND STATE
BORDERS THE FEDS DO STEP IN --
SO AT LEAST I FEEL THAT IN MY
NOT SUPPORTING THIS TODAY IT'S
NOT LIKE I'M COMPLETELY IGNORING
THERE IS FEDERAL STATUTE -- SO
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SUGGEST IS
THAT IF THE BILL DOES NOT PASS
TODAY WE GRANT YOU
RECONSIDERATION AND IF YOU WANT
TO MODIFY. FOR TO SOME SORT OF
STUDY OR EITHER IF YOU WANT TO
BRING US BACK SOMETHING OR IF
YOU JUST WANT.
US.
TO AGREED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONVENE SOMETHING EITHER WAY --
BUT RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE AND
THEN WILL AS SORRY SENATOR
MOREAU.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR BATES YEAH
I JUST WANNA MAKE A COMMENT I AM
GOING TO BE SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
I I HAVE NO SYMPATHY FOR PEOPLE
OF PUSH DRUGS AND RUN OTHER
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN CELL.
I WISH THE SENTENCES WERE EVEN
STRONGER SO -- I WILL.
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL THANK
YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE ARE
YOU I'M I DON'T COUNT VOTES IN
UPPORT OF THE BILL YET SO.
OF CERTAINLY ALL ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION IF IT DOES NOT
PASS AND THEN TAKEN UNDER A
CONSIDERATION WHAT THE WHAT YOU
CHAIRMAN HAVE SUGGESTED I THINK
THAT'S THE ROUTE WILL TAKE.
AND SEE IF WE CAN'T GET FROM
CONVENE SOMETHING THAT GETS LEFT
FILE AT LEAST FARTHER DOWN THE
THE PATH TO DO -- IT FROM THIRTY
INTERCEPTION OF THE DRUG COMING
INTO THIS COUNTRY AND I THINK
THAT THAT WILL CALIFORNIA'S LEAD
ON SO MANY.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IT IS A
HUGE ISSUE FOR OUR NATION NOW.
SO LET SOME WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASKED RECONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION LET'S
DO ROLL CALL.
THIS IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL MORALE HIGH MORALE AYE
WIENER.
WIENER NOW.
SO WE WILL GRANT RECONSIDERATION.
THE BILL FAILED -- BUT AS YOU
REQUESTED WE WILL GRANT
RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU OKAY
THANKS SO MUCH [inaudible]
I'M.
WE WILL NOW MOVE -- TO ITEM.
NINE NO SKEWS ME YES BELT SB TWO
EIGHTY THREE SORRY RATHER BILLS
I CONSENT.
ITEM NINE SB ONE NINETY THREE
SENATOR NIELSEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
OF BRING BEFORE YOU TODAY.
SB ONE NINETY THREE AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CONSULTANT FOR
WORKING WITH.
ON THE BILL.
RELATED TO SOME CLARIFYING OR
NARROWING AMENDMENTS.
WE WOULD ACCEPT THOSE AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS THAT APPLIES TO THIS
BILL SOLELY TO THE SALES OF
SMOKE.
AND HEAD SHOTS.
AS AMENDED THIS PROHIBITS
RETAILERS OF TOBACCO AND TOBACCO
RELATED PRODUCTS.
IN OTHER WORDS WHAT ARE.
CALLED SMOKE SHOP YOUR HEAD
SHOPS.
FROM SELLING NITROUS OXIDE.
CANISTERS.
THESE CANISTERS ARE SOLD WITH
THE CRACKER AND WE HAD ONE
AVAILABLE TO SHOW YOU BUT WOULD
LIKE TO BRING IT IN HERE BUT
IT'S IT'S A IT'S A DEVICE.
THAT ALLOWS.
AN INDIVIDUAL. TO INGEST IF YOU
WILL NITROUS OXIDE AS MODIFIED
THIS PRODUCTIVE DEVICE HAS GOT
TO BE MODIFIED. FOR THAT PURPOSE.
THEN THE OXIDE NECK NITROUS
OXIDE IS PROVIDED BY.
CANISTERS WHICH ARE SEPARATELY
PURCHASED.
THE HEAD OF THEY'RE CALLED IN
THE STREET NAME.
WEAPONS.
SEEMS TO BE AN APT.
TERM FOR SOMETHING THAT IS AS
DANGEROUS IS THIS.
THE DEVICE ITSELF IS THE
INDUSTRIAL THAT CREAM DISPENSER
WHICH HAD A GOOD THE NOBLE
PURPOSE OF WOULD YOU OBJECT TO
HER JUST LIFTING THAT UP AND
JUST SHOWING.
THAT'S THE DEVICE.
THE CANISTERS ATTACHED THERE TO
MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
WE DON'T HAVE A THE CANISTER
HERE -- ALTHOUGH -- ACT
ANECDOTAL POINT -- I'M AWARE OF
SOMEONE WHO WENT AND TRIED TO
BUY A BOX OF CANISTERS TO SEE
WHAT.
HOW THAT PROCESS WORKS?
ENTER SOME INTEREST.
THE INDIVIDUAL.
ASK DAN UPON THE COMPLETE I WANT
THAT NITROUS OXIDE SO SHE WAS
HAND THIS BY THE WHOEVER WAITED
ON AND SHE SAID ANY THING YOU
WANT.
ANY INFORMATION FOR ME.
AND THE PERSON WHO WAS SELLING
IT SAID YES DO YOU WANT MORE
[inaudible]
OF THE MAYBE TWICE.
THAT IS SOMEWHAT INSTRUCTIVE OF
THE ATTITUDE IN THESE HEAD SHOPS.
INHALING IT IS DANGEROUS.
IT IS ILLEGAL.
AND IT GIVES LONG TERM HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
IT CAN BE MENTAL IMPAIRMENT.
IT CAN BE [inaudible]
DEATH. ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS.
MISS BETTER BRIAN CONTACTED MY
OFFICE.
AFTER HIS SON SHANE WHO IS HERE
WITH US TODAY.
WAS HOSPITALIZED USING WEAPONS.
HE THOUGHT THEY WERE SAFE.
THEY'VE BEEN REPRESENTED HIM AS
SUCH BUT HE WILL SPEAK FOR
HIMSELF HERE.
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER.
MOTHER AND WHOSE SON ALSO WAS
AFFECTED.
HE FORTUNATELY IS DOING FINE
RIGHT NOW.
BUT MY POINT IS [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
NITROUS OXIDE [inaudible]
IS HORRIBLY.
ADDICTIVE.
VERY MUCH AFFECTING INDIVIDUALS.
IN SOME CASES HUNDREDS OF
CANISTERS HAVE BEEN FOUND.
WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE UC'S.
SO BY VIRTUE OF THE BILL WE ARE
SIMPLY LIMITING [inaudible]
THE ACCESS [inaudible] TO THE
NITROUS OXIDE.
AND THAT.
WOULD BE GOOD [inaudible] FOR
HUMANKIND.
IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
WITNESSES YES THEY BROUGHT --
CENTERS SOME FOR WE GO TO YOUR
WITNESS IS I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT TO THE COMMITTEE THAT --
THIS BILL NOW WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IS VERY COMPARABLE TO
THE BILL THAT WE PASSED IN
[inaudible]
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THERE IS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION BUT WITNESSES
IN.
PLEASE PROCEED.
IF I NEEDED [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS BARBARA LARGE.
NATIVE OF LOS ANGELES LIVING IN
WEST LA.
I'M AN ATTORNEY A WRITER A
MOTHER OF TWO ADULT CHILDREN.
AND I AM HERE BECAUSE MY TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD SON SUSTAINED
BRAIN DAMAGE FROM A SEVERE
ADDICTION TO NITROUS OXIDE.
WHICH HE FED.
BY REGULARLY PURCHASING THIS
DRUG IN SMOKING TOBACCO SHOPS
ACROSS LOS ANGELES.
HERE'S A PICTURE OF JUST SOME OF
THE USED CANISTERS HE
ACCUMULATED ALL OF WHICH I FOUND
IN HIS CAR I CAN PASS THESE
AROUND ANYBODY INTERESTED.
I'LL HAVE TO START [inaudible]
OKAY.
FOUND IN HIS CAR IS ROUGH ON HIS
CAR THOUSANDS AND YES IN HIS CAR.
MANY WHO ABUSED NITROUS DO SO AS
SOON AS THEY BUY IT OFTEN
INHALING IT IN PARKING LOTS OR
EVEN WHILE DRIVING.
RECENT NEWS REPORTS HAVE
DISCUSSED THE RASH OF FATAL CAR
ACCIDENTS IN LOS ANGELES.
WHERE THE DRIVER HI ON NITROUS
PASSED OUT BEHIND THE WHEEL?
NO JUST OXIDE BECAME MY SON'S
DRUG OF CHOICE BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHEN HE WAS LIVING IN A
LOCAL SOBER LIVING.
A ROOMMATE INTRODUCED IT TO HIM
AS A WAY TO USE AND NOT GET
CAUGHT.
NITROUS IS 1100% UNDETECTABLE ON
DRUG TESTS.
AND HE LIKED IT.
YEARS LATER FRIENDS TRIED TO
HELP HIM BY DOING A NITROUS
OXIDE INTERVENTION AND I
PICTURED MY SWEET BOY CRUMPLED
ON THE COUCH WILD EYED TWITCHING
CLUTCHING THE CRACKER LIKE IT
WAS HIS BABY BOTTLE.
THIS DRUG IS ABSOLUTELY
ADDICTIVE.
AND HAILING WHIPPETS PROVIDES A
SHORT YET INTENSE EUPHORIA
SOMETIMES DESCRIBED AS FORTY
SECONDS OF ABSOLUTE BLISS.
A LITTLE LIKE BEING BACK INSIDE
THE WOMB.
BY MOST DRUGS THIS POWERFUL ONE
WOULD NORMALLY NEED TO FIND A
SHADY DEALER OR CONSULT THE DARK
WEB.
BUT THIS.
THIS HI IS OFFERED IN PLAIN
SIGHT.
SIMPLY ONE IN THE CORNUCOPIA OF
INHALANTS OFFERED FOR SALE AND
SMOKE AND TOBACCO SHOPS.
AND THAT BLISSFUL ROOM LIKE
FEELING.
THAT'S THE FEELING OF BRAIN
CELLS SUFFOCATING AND DYING.
WHEN A PERSON INHALES NITROUS
OXIDE HE'S PLAYING RUSSIAN
ROULETTE WITH HIS LIFE?
THIS MEANS THERE'S A VERY REAL
CHANCE HE COULD DIE DURING HIS
FIRST INHALE OR ANY OF THE ONES
THAT FOLLOW.
THE BROTHER OF A GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE AND HELD NITROUS AND DIED
INSTANTANEOUSLY.
AND THE FACT THAT THIS COULD
HAVE BEEN MY SON TERRIFIES ME TO
MY CAR.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH INHALING
NITROUS CAN ALSO DAMAGE ONCE
LIVER KIDNEYS AND BONE MARROW.
IT CAN CAUSE CONVULSIONS
CAESAR'S DEMENTIA BLINDNESS
PARALYSIS COMA HEART FAILURE AND
DEATH FROM ASPHYXIATION
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SUDDEN
SNIFFING DEATH SYNDROME.
ALTHOUGH MY SON HAS SINCE
COMMITTED TO A LIFE OF SOBRIETY.
THE REALITY IS THAT ANY DAY OR
NIGHT HE CAN WALK INTO ANY SMOKE
SHOP AND BE TEMPTED TO BUY
EVERYTHING HE NEEDS. TO RESUME
THIS DEADLY JACK GAME OF CHANCE.
RECENTLY I PAID A VISIT TO A
LOCAL SMOKE SHOP I TOLD THE
SALESMAN I WAS LOOKING FOR
NITROUS OXIDE FOR A PARTY I WAS
GIVEN.
HE POINTED TO THE CORNER OF A
STORE AT A PLASTIC TUB BREAM
BRIMMING WITH VIBRANT COLORED
BALLOONS.
BOOKENDED BY BOXES UPON BOXES OF
WITH IT THE ORIGINAL.
WITHIN MINUTES I'M WALKING OUT
THE DOOR WITH A TWELVE DOLLAR
CARTON TWENTY FOUR CREAM
CHARGERS AND ORANGE AND BLUE
BALLOONS IN A DISCREET BLACK BAG
FOR A PARTY I'M GIVING.
BY CONTINUING TO TURN A BLIND
EYE TO THE WIDESPREAD AND
RECKLESS SALE OF NITROUS OXIDE
IN SMOKE AND TOBACCO SHOPS.
WE ARE SENDING A MESSAGE THAT IN
HAILING THIS DEADLY DRUG IS AS
INNOCENT AND FUN AS ITS COLORFUL
BALLOONS AND NEON CANISTERS
SUGGEST.
WHILE I'M NO EXPERT I KNOW WE
CAN DO BETTER.
THIS LONG OVERDUE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS CALIFORNIA'S
CHANCE TO STEM THE FLOW OF THIS
DEADLY DRUG AND TO HOLD THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS ILLICIT SALE
ACCOUNTABLE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
SENATE BILL ONE NINETY THREE
CALIFORNIANS ARE DESPERATE FOR
YOUR PROTECTION.
THANK YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WITNESS WE'RE HAVING ONLY
TWO AT THE TABLE [inaudible]
THANK.
OF MONEY MISSION BRIAN AND I'M
SPEAKING YOU BECAUSE I'VE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE ABUSING
NITROUS.
AND SEEING FIRSTHAND MY OWN BODY
THE NEUROTOXIC EFFECTS IT HAS.
A FEW YEARS AGO I STARTED DOWN
MY PATH WITH NITROUS STARTED
WITH SMALL AMOUNTS OF FIRST
ROUND TWENTY CANISTERS YOU COULD
EASILY BY FROM SMOKE SHOP.
AND THEN WORKING UP TO AROUND
TWO HUNDRED CANISTERS PER DAY.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THE DANGER
BECAUSE I KNOW THE DENTIST USES.
AND IF THE DENTISTS ARE ABLE TO
USE THAT THEY CAN'T POSSIBLY
DANGEROUS RIGHT.
BUT WAS UNTIL I LEARNED WITH
NEUROLOGISTS LATER THAT EVEN
UNDER THE CAREFUL CONTROL OF
DENTISTS THERE ARE SOMETIMES
PERMANENT DAMAGE FROM NITROUS.
IT WAS BECAUSE OF MY HIGH
NITROUS INJECTED I LOST MY
ABILITY TO WALK OVER THE COURSE
OF MORE THAN A YEAR AFTER BEING
BOUND TO A WHEELCHAIR I SLOWLY
BEGAN TO REGAIN MY ABILITY.
I WENT FROM A WHEELCHAIR TO A
WALKER FROM THE WALKER TO A CANE.
AND FROM THE CAME TO A PAIR OF
ORTHODONTICS TO FINALLY BE ABLE
TO WALK ON MY OWN FOR YOU TODAY.
EVEN THOUGH I CAN NOW WALK I
WILL LIKELY HAVE PERMANENT NERVE
DAMAGE IN MY PERIPHERALS.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO
HELP ENSURE THAT NOBODY ELSE
GOES THROUGH THE PHYSICAL PAIN
AND TO BUILD DEBILITATION THAT I
WENT THROUGH BY ADDING YOUR
SUPPORT TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW YOU MAY --
INDICATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND THEN WE'LL ASK
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
WELL MY NAME'S PATRICK BRANHAM
FATHER SHANE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
BRENDAN UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT SUPPORT AND ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
RIVERSIDE DIPPY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
JOHN LEVEL CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND LA
COUNTY PROFESSIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IS AN
SUPPORT MORGAN GUY ON THEIR
BEHALF.
CANON PRIMER EMPOWER FAMILY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE WHO HAVE A GENETIC
DEFECT IN THF FAR I MAY NOT KNOW
IT.
THAT THIS DRUG COULD KILL JUST
ON THAT THE FACT ALONE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NINE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THE ONE NINE THREE
YES.
OKAY AS AMENDED.
ON ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION
CENTER NIELSEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE COMMITTEE LET'S TRY TO AT
LEAST.
ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS VERY DANGEROUS [inaudible]
NITROUS OXIDE [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
AND AS I STATED BEFORE FOR TO
GROW CALLS IS VERY COMPARABLE TO
THE BILL THAT WE PASSED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO WE WILL NOW.
HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
ACTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
BE IN PAIN SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE MORALE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
I WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPENED BUT
YOU DO HAVE ADEQUATE VOTES FOR
THE BILL TO PASS BUT IT WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
MISSING MEMBER AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS.
WE GOT.
RIGHT THROUGH THAT THEM NOTICES
THAT BILLS OUT [inaudible]
UNANIMOUS.
ALRIGHT SO WE WILL NOW GO TO
YOUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS SB.
ONE NINETY FOUR MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE INTENTION OF SB ONE
NINETY FOUR IS.
TO MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY.
AND THE EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT.
ON OUR CAMPUSES OF HIGHER
EDUCATION [inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE INSTITUTIONS SHOULD BE THE
MARKETPLACE OF GOOD IDEAS.
OPEN EXCHANGE OF THOSE IDEAS.
WHERE INDIVIDUALS CAN?
EXERCISE THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
FREELY AND OPENLY.
IN RECENT YEARS THOUGH.
THAT HAS BEEN COMPROMISED ON
SOME CAMPUSES.
BY INDIVIDUALS WHO COME ON TO
THE CAMPUS.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE NO AFFILIATION.
A REASON TO BE THERE
[inaudible]
MASKED.
NOW THERE THERE ARE.
TWO PROTEST OR MAKE STATEMENTS
[inaudible]
WHATEVER.
THAT IN CASES THESE.
VISIT SEVEN VERY DESTRUCTIVE
[inaudible]
OF PROPERTY.
LIVE IN VIOLENT ACTS.
AND WITHOUT QUESTION THEY HAVE
INTERFERED WITH THE EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSES.
OF THE INSTITUTION.
AND THE INTIMIDATING ASPECT OF
THIS.
IS THE MASK.
MASK SHOULD HOLLOW WE MAY BE
YEARS UP AND WERE USED.
TO BUT NORMALLY WHEN SOMEONE IS
TRYING.
TO HIDE THEIR IDENTITY.
IT'S FOR SOME PARTICULAR REASON.
THAT THEY ARE AFRAID OF AND IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
THEY'RE AFRAID OF BEING A
DOLLARS FOR WHO THEY ARE ON THIS
CAMPUS DISRUPTING.
THE CAMPUS ENVIRONMENT.
SO WHAT THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES.
THAT ALLOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUILDING ON EXISTING LAW. TO
STOP ANY INDIVIDUAL.
IF THE OFFICER HAS A REASONABLE
SUSPICON THAT THIS INDIVIDUALS
HERE.
COULD BE.
OR IS INTENDING TO BE INVOLVED.
IN A CRIME.
AND THEY SIMPLY HAVE.
WOULD.
TELL THAT INDIVIDUAL. TO REMOVE
THE MASK.
AND TO DISCLOSE THEIR IDENTITY.
BY SO DOING.
IT IS A VERY SIMPLE BILL.
AND IT WOULD PRESERVE I THINK.
A MUCH SAFER ENVIRONMENT WITHIN
OUR CAMPUSES.
AND AN ASSURANCE OF OUR STUDENTS
TO GO THERE [inaudible]
THAT INDIVIDUALS.
WHO DO NOT WANT TO SHOW THEIR
IDENTITIES?
ARE NOT THERE FOR THE PURPOSE.
AGAIN A BIT TO BILL AND AN
EXISTING LAW.
AND THE ESSENCE OF IT IS THE
OFFICER ENQUIRING WILL YOU.
DISCLOSURE IDENTITY BY REMOVING
YOUR MASK.
DO I HAVE NO WITNESSES THAT CASH
STAFF MEMBERS CERTAINLY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
AUDIENCE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I WANT TO JUST COME TO THE MIKE.
JOHN LEVEL WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
THIS DOES HAVE PUBLIC SAFETY
IMPLICATIONS ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS
ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
IS THE PROSPECTING FOR AT OF
ACTIVE SHOOTERS IN COLLEGE
CAMPUSES IS A CHILLING STAT BUT
LAST YEAR.
WAS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT
ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS SOMEPLACE IN
THIS COUNTRY ONCE EVERY EIGHT
DAYS.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SHAUN RUN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA HERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB.
ONE NINETY FOUR FIRST WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL IS UNNECESSARY IT IS
ALREADY A MISDEMEANOR IN
CALIFORNIA. TO WEAR A MASK FOR
THE PURPOSE OF EVADING OR
ESCAPING IDENTIFICATION IN THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME.
IT IS ALSO A MISDEMEANOR IN
CALIFORNIA TO WEAR A MASK FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONCEALMENT
FLIGHT OR ESCAPE WHEN CHARGED
WITH ARRESTED FOR OR CONVICTED
OF A CRIME.
THESE LAWS APPLY TO PEOPLE ON
SCHOOL COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES AS THEY DO AND ANY
OTHER PUBLIC SPACES.
SECOND WE ARE CONCERNED THAT SB
ONE NINETY FOUR COULD BE USED.
TO VIOLATE CALIFORNIANS RIGHT.
IN PARTICULAR WE FEAR THAT SB
ONE NINETY FOUR COULD BE USED AS
A PRETEXT FOR CONTENT BASED
CENSORSHIP IN THE CONTEXT OF
LAWFUL CAMPUS PROTESTS.
PERMITTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO REQUIRE A PERSON TO
REMOVE A MASK WHEN THERE IS NO
PROBABLE CAUSE TO BELIEVE WHEN
THERE IS NO PROBABLE CAUSE FOR
ARREST AS SB ONE NINETY FOUR
PROPOSES -- COULD EASILY LEAD TO
DIFFERENTIAL ENFORCEMENT OF THE
PROPOSED LAW BASED ON THE
CONTENT OF A MASS PERSONS
MESSAGE THE PERSON'S APPEARANCE
OR IDENTIFYING CHARACTERISTICS
OR THE MANNER OF PROTEST.
IT IS ALSO UNCLEAR WHETHER THE
STANDARD OF REASONABLE SUSPICION
THAT THE PERSON HAS BEEN OR IS
CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN A CRIME.
IS SUFFICIENTLY TAILORED TO
BALANCE LEGITIMATE STATE
INTEREST AGAINST LAWFUL FIRST
AMENDMENT SPEECH.
AND LASTLY WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THERE HAVE BEEN SUFFICIENT
SUFFICIENT DEVELOPMENTS SINCE
THIS COMMITTEES REJECTION OF
THIS BILL LAST YEAR TO WARRANT
PASSAGE NOW. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CAN JUST COME TO THE MIKE.
ON THE FLOOR.
HI LIZ ONE GRADUATE STUDENT AT
UC DAVIS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
RIGHT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
MY COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
CENTER MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR JUST
SKINNER -- THIRTY NIELSEN I
COMPLETELY YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATE THE HISTORY OF OF
MASKS OR HOODS WORN BY PEOPLE
WHO WERE INVOLVED IN RIOTOUS
BEHAVIOUR IN.
MORE RECENT YEARS TIKI TORCHES
BUT I GUESS MY QUESTION OR
CONCERN IS IT OTHER THAN THE UC
BERKELEY EXAMPLE -- IT IN MANY
INSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN -- PROTESTS YOU'LL
SEE THEM TIED BANDANNAS ACROSS
THEIR FACE PRIMARILY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM.
OF THE THE THE GAS.
CANISTERS THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT --
ARE PRONE TO USED TO GO TO BREAK
UP -- PROTESTS.
AND SO.
WOULD IT INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
COVERED THEIR FACE TO PRODUCE
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM TEAR GAS
DIDN'T HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
POTENTIAL CHARGE LEVIED AGAINST
THEM BECAUSE IT'S NOT THEIR
EFFORT TO EBAY LOG FORCE WAS
THEIR EFFORT TO TRY TO PROTECT
HIMSELF FROM TEAR GAS COULD THAT.
PERSON YOU GET CAUGHT UP IN IN
THIS LEGISLATION AS WELL BECAUSE
BECAUSE I WOULD HOPE NOT.
YOU MAY ANSWER SENATE A MEASURE
THAT IS NOT AT ALL THE INTENT.
IT WOULD AND WHAT WHAT THE MASK
COVERING THE NOSE WITH IT
TOTALLY.
THIS.
THE SKY'S THE IDENTITY
[inaudible]
NOT NECESSARILY.
THERE'S PLENTY OF OTHER VISUAL
IDENTIFICATION.
AND THIS DOES NOT MEAN THEY'RE
GOING TO BE CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR THIS SIMPLY MEANS
THE OFFICER.
HAVING SUSPICION WOULDN'T SIMPLY
INQUIRE WOULD YOU REMOVE IT.
WHATEVER WOULD HAPPEN AFTER THAT
THAT WOULD BE DEPENDING ON
WHATEVER THE CIRCUMSTANCES WAS
DISCLOSED TO THE INDIVIDUAL IT
WOULD BE PROBABLY SOMEWHAT
DETERMINED BY THE BEHAVIOR OF
THE PEOPLE.
TO I CANNOT SPEAK FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEIR PROTOCOLS BUT
WHAT THEY ARE TRAINED TO DO
[inaudible]
BUT AGAIN.
IT IS NOT OUR INTENT FOR SOMEONE
WHO WANTS TO AVOID THE THE THE
THE GAS.
WHAT I WANT TO HAVE A MASK ON
FOR THAT PURPOSE OR IF YOU SAID
A BANDANNA?
AND THAT WOULD BE THEIR
OPPORTUNITY WHEN THEY THEN WERE
CONFRONTED TO THE OFFICER THEY
COULD SIMPLY EXPLAINED THAT AND
I WOULD EXPECT THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS WOULD
BE VERY COGNIZANT.
AND SENSITIVE TO THAT CONCERT.
BUT SIR YOU SAY THAT THAT IT IT
WOULD NOT LEAD TO A DISTRIBUTOR
BUT IF I'M LOOKING READING THE
ANALYSIS CORRECTLY PAGE TWO IT
SAYS THAT THIS BILL SAY FOR THE
PERSON WHO FAILED TO COMPLY WITH
THE OFFICER.
OR OFFICIAL DEMAND HAS WILLFULLY
DISRUPTED THE ORDERLY OPERATION
OF A CAMPUS FACILITY AND IS
GUILTY OF A MISDEMEANOR AND SO
IF I SAY I'M NOT GONNA REMOVE MY
MASK.
THEN I AM SUBJECT SUBJECT TO A
MISDEMEANOR I WILL NOT DISPUTE
THAT OKAY.
RIGHT THANK YOU SIR.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
BY SENATOR MORE LIKE.
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL AYE
AYE I THINK SOMETHING DISTURBING
EVEN HISTORICALLY OF OF WEARING
MASKS.
INAPPROPRIATE TIMES THAT
FUNCTIONS FIGHT.
I THINK THIS IS LONG OVERDUE.
SUPPORT THE BILL [inaudible]
I'M.
I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY JUST AS I DID NOT IN
THE LAST YEAR -- AND MY REASON
IS DUE TO THE NOTE THE STATE IN
THE ANALYSIS THAT IT IS ALREADY
A MISDEMEANOR IF YOU ARE WEARING.
A MASK AND YOU ARE AND THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- BELIEVES THAT YOU
ARE ENGAGED IN A CRIMINAL ACT
THEN THEY CAN.
BOTH DEMAND YOUR REMOVAL OF THE
MASK AND CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR JUST FOR WEARING THE
MASK.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME AND THAT
WORKS ON CAMPUSES OR IN PUBLIC
SETTINGS OR WHEREVER SO THAT LAW
IS IT ALREADY APPLIES TO OUR
CAMPUSES.
SO I DON'T SEE THE NEED TO ADD
AN ADDITIONAL LAW -- SO I WILL
BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY -- BUT
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION ON
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION -- THE
MANAGER I THINK THE TESTIMONY OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS
HERE TODAY GIVE SOME INDICATION.
OF THE NATURE OF THE PROBLEM.
AND THAT THAT IS A REAL PROBLEM.
ON OUR CAMPUSES.
AND IT DOES HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT.
ON OUR CAMPUSES.
AND I WILL INTEND TO CONTINUE TO
RAISE THIS CONCERN. TO ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
I ASKED AND I WILL.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION --
LOOKS TO ROLL CALL.
MOST IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER NOPE
SKINNER NOW MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MORALE.
HI WIENER.
WIENER NOW.
THANK YOU MAY FEEL FEELS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR NEXT
ITEM WHICH WOULD BE -- IEM
TWELVE SENATOR BILL.
IT IS SB.
TWO EIGHTY FOUR I'M WHILE YOU'RE
BRINGING UP YOUR WITNESSES LET'S
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL RIGHT CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL. FIVE I OR LACK.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON MITCHELL.
KIDS CONSENT FIVE MITCHELL AYE
MORALE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
RIGHT -- SENATOR BAIL YOU MAY
BEGIN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- THIS BILL
SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR IS THE KEY
VIEWS CLOSE TO HOME ACT.
THE ANNUAL COST -- TO CONFINED
YOUTH AT THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AVERAGES.
ARE MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER USER PER
YEAR.
OF THAT AMOUNT THE COUNTIES
UNDER CURRENT LAW ONLY
CONTRIBUTE TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
WITH THE STATE PAYING THE REST
OF THE COST.
NOW THE BEST PRACTICES SHOW THAT
LOCAL REHABILITATION IS MORE
EFFECTIVE YET THE CURRENT LO FI
INCENTIVIZE IS COUNTIES. TO SEND
USED TO THE REMOTE STATE
FACILITIES.
THE STATE FUNDS COUNTIES WITH
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY -- TO SERVE YOUNG
PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
INCLUDING FUND SPECIFICALLY
EARMARKED FOR TREATING HIDING
ISSUE.
IN LOCAL FACILITIES AND INSTEAD
OF THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE DENNIS
WOULD BE PLEASED TO KNOW THAT
YOU'RE COUNTIES.
ALL OF YOU HAVE -- BELOW AVERAGE
IN TERMS OF THE RATE OF
COMMITTING YOU'VE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
HOWEVER ALL CALIFORNIANS
TAXPAYERS ARE SUBSIDIZING THE
COST FOR SMALL NUMBERS OF
COUNTIES THAT ARE HIGHLY
DEPENDENT ON THE STATE FACILITY.
THE LEGISLATURE CREATED THE
ANNUAL FEE BACK IN NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE AND MAINTAINED.
IT WITH THE INTENT OF TO
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL REHABILITATION.
YET WE ARE SEEKING EXTREME
BACON'S WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW
EXTREME VACANCIES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL OVER OVER HALF THE THE
BEDS AT THE LOCAL EVER ACTUALLY
VACANT.
AND WE ALSO -- HAVE DISTRICT A
GREAT DEAL DISCREPANCIES IN
VARIATION IN THE COUNTIES RATE.
OF SENDING YOU TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
THE BILL AIMS TO CLOSE -- A KEEP
YOU OF CLOSE TO HOME AND SPUR
LOCAL REHABILITATION COMMUNITY
BASED SUPPORT.
BY INCREASING THE COUNTY FEE
FROM TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR YOUTH.
WHO -- COMMITTED OFFENSE UNDER
THE AGE EIGHTEEN AND USED TO
COMMIT AN OFFENSE WHICH WILL
CARRY A SENSE OF FEWER THAN
SEVEN YEARS.
ADD THE BEEN TRIED AS AN ADULT.
THE TO THE TWENTY TWELVE DATA
SHOWS THAT 74% OF THE U. FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
RESERVE IT'D -- WITHIN THREE
YEARS OF RELEASE.
THE STUDIES ALSO SHOW THE JUST
DO YOUTH ARE EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE AS THEY MOVE FROM
ADOLESCENCE TO ADULTHOOD.
THESE LEARNING YEARS ARE
CRITICAL TO THEIR GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
WE KNOW THAT THE TRAUMA
CONFINEMENT THE STATE FACILITIES --
TRAUMA IS A HAS AN IMPACT ON ON
USE AT THE STATE FACILITIES AND
WE KNOW THAT LOCAL
REHABILITATION.
AND COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT AS
PROVEN FAR MORE EFFECTIVE.
CLOSE REGULAR CONTACT WITH LOVED
ONES AND SUPPORT SYSTEMS ARE
BENEFICIAL USE WELLNESS AND
INSURERS THEIR SUCCESS UPON
RELEASE.
THIS BILL AIMS TO PROMOTE LOCAL
REHABILITATION FOR ITS SUPPORT
OF SAFE ENVIRONMENTS AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
OF TURN OVER TO MY WITNESSES --
THE RESTAURANT.
GOOD MORNING MAUREEN WASHBURN
WITH THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT FEE FOR
COMMITTING USED TO DJJ JUST
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YOU.
REPRESENTS A FRACTION OF THE
TRUE COST OF THE STATE SYSTEM.
WHICH NOW EXCEEDS THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'S NOW LESS
EXPENSIVE FOR COUNTIES TO PAY
THE CITY.
THE TO KEEP YOUTH IN LOCAL
FACILITIES.
THIS CREATES A PROBLEMATIC
INCENTIVE FOR COUNTIES TO SEND
YOUTH TO DISTANCE STATE
INSTITUTION.
AND THE RESULTS IS STARK
GEOGRAPHIC DISPARITIES WITH THE
STATE FOOTING THE BILL. FOR A
SMALL NUMBER OF COUNTIES THAT
RELY HEAVILY ON THE STATE SYSTEM.
WHILE MOST JURISDICTIONS SAID
FEW OR NO USE TO DJJ.
A RECENT RESEARCH FINDS THE DJJ
FACILITIES CONTINUE TO OPERATE
AS THEY HAVE FOR DECADES.
AS PRISON LIKE SETTINGS.
THAT EXPOSE YOUTH TO SERIOUS
TRAUMA.
YOUTH CANNOT FLOURISH IN
DANGEROUS AND ISOLATING
ENVIRONMENTS.
INSTEAD THEY FARE BEST WHEN THEY
ARE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO THE
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY SUPPORT
THEY'LL NEED WHEN THEY'RE
RELEASED.
THESE CLOSE TO HOME SETTINGS
ALREADY EXIST AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL.
AND THEY'RE OPERATING AT JUST
30% CAPACITY.
WHICH MEANS THEY COULD ABSORB
DJS POPULATION MORE THAN
THIRTEEN TIMES OVER.
AND COUNTIES RECEIVE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS EACH YEAR IN STATE
pFUNDING FOR LOCAL SERVICES AND
ALTERNATIVES TO DJJ.
AND TWENTY TWO COUNTIES HAVE
pRENOVATE LOCAL FACILITIES THAT
MEET YOUTH TREATMENT NEEDS.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF STATE
DOLLARS AND LOCAL INVESTMENT.
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS HAVE
DEVELOPED MODEL PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY TREATMENT
AND CARE IN A SECURE SETTING.
SO TO BRING YOU CLOSER TO HOME
AND EXTEND THE LOCAL INNOVATION
ALREADY HAPPENING IN COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MISS WASHBURN.
HELLO GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY --
MY NAME IS ELISA REMEMBER IS I'M
HERE TODAY WITH -- MILPA -- AND
TODAY I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
MY MY VERY OWN EXPERIENCE THAT
I'VE HAD WHILE I'M WHILE BEING
IN DJJ -- WHAT BEEN AND JJ?
FIRST ARRIVING I WAS -- SIXTEEN
I RETURN HOME WHICH IS THREE
YEARS LATER AT ADULT AT AN ADULT
WHICH WAS AGE -- TWENTY I WAS
NOW A LEGAL ADULT AND NOW HELD
TO THE ADULT STANDARD YET I
STILL FELT SIXTEEN AND WHERE IT
WAS VERY PERPLEXED AS TO HOW TO
OR TO WHERE TO EVEN START TO
REBUILD MY MY MY LIFE AND MY
RELATIONSHIPS -- ME PERSONALLY --
I'M REAL CLOSE TO MY FAMILY SO --
OF HAVING.
A REAL CLOSE RELATIONSHIP I'VE
ALWAYS TURN TO THEM FOR FOR
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE HOWEVER
BEING A DJJ IF ALTERED THAT ONCE
THIRTY RELATIONSHIP THAT I'VE
I'VE HAD WITH MY FAMILY -- AND
IT'S DUE TO EXPENSIVE TRAVEL AND
AND AND AND THE DISTANCE WHAT
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR MY
FAMILY TO BE ENGAGED TO AND AND
SEE ME MORE OFTEN HAVE THAT
SUPPORT -- AND WHICH IS THE BEEN
DID WAS IT CREATED DISTANCE --
INTERFERENCE WITH OUR BONDAGE
AND A TIME OF CRITICAL NEED -- I
WAS YOU KNOW I NEED MY FAMILY
AND AND AND AND AND WAS VERY
DIFFICULT TIMES WHEN I WAS I WAS
BEING MOVED OUT OF MY MY
DISABILITY ROOM.
YOU KNOW WAS IT BEING PROVIDED
MY PHYSICAL REHAB -- AND AND ALL
THESE -- UNFORTUNATE EVENTS THAT
I THAT I THAT I WENT THROUGH AND
I WAS VERY LIMITED TO THE ACCESS
OF OF HAVING THAT THAT FAMILY
CONTACT -- AND YOU KNOW THIS ON
THE INTENSIFIED THE TRAUMA OF
LIFE AT DJJ WHERE STAFF ABUSE
THEIR AUTHORITY AND AND VIOLENCE
IS FREQUENT -- AND THE FACT THAT
MY FAMILY YOU WERE WANTING AND
WILLING TO BE THERE.
BUT WERE MET WITH SUCH
RESISTANCE AND CONFLICT IT ONLY
ADDED.
GRIEF TO THE ALREADY EXISTING
BURDEN THAT I CARRY.
ON AND AND ALSO THE FACT THAT
THAT I WAS A KID.
GROWING AND DEVELOPING IN THOSE
THOSE FOUR YEARS OF BECOMING AN
ADULT WITH A LITTLE TO NO FAMILY
CONTACT -- N. -- IN THE END
MAKING ME FEEL REALLY HELPLESS
AND AND DEFEATED -- AND AND AS
SOON AS I GOT AS I GOT OUT
ALMOST ANY.
REALLY ANXIOUS AND DISCONCERTED
IN.
MY SURROUNDINGS AND MYSELF.
DUE TO BEING ISOLATED AND
SEVERAL HOURS AWAY AND REMOTE
LOCATIONS WHICH IS -- OUR DJJ --
SO I I AM -- I'M ASKING.
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR
WHICH MY HOPE IS FOR KEEPING
YOUTH CLOSER TO HOME HAVING.
HAVING THEM HAVE THE AXIS AND
MORE FAMILY CONTACT AND SUPPORT.
THEN TO REINTEGRATE BACK INTO
THEIR VITAMINS -- MORE SMOOTHLY
AND PRODUCTIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
JUST COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
ON THE FLOOR TO SYNDICATE YOUR
NAME.
JUST COME UP TO THE MIKE
INDICATE YOUR NAME AND A THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING THANKS FOR HAVING
THIS MY NAME IS KATIE DIXON I'M
A POLICY FELLOW ELLIS PC IN ALL
OF US ARE NONE.
I SUPPORT SB TO EIGHTY FOUR A
ONE ECHO WITH ALLY JUST THERE.
I TO STAR FIVE YEARS IN A
JUVENILE FACILITY JJ FACILITY IT
WAS VERY MUCH A PRISON.
IT WAS VERY MUCH DRAMATIC IN A
DEFINITELY READ ME AWAY FROM MY
FAMILY PLEASE SUPPORT SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
I'M IN MY AREA COME FROM OAKLAND
I COME FROM COURAGE I'VE BEEN
INCARCERATED -- I DO NOT GET THE
SUPPORT I NEED A AND THE LOVE
FOR MY FAMILY.
SO NOW THAT I'M IN MY COMMUNITY.
AND OURS ARE SUPPORT USED TO BE
IN CLOSE TO HOME.
MY NAME IS TATUM BELIEVE I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR SORT OF YOUTH JUSTICE
IN OAKLAND I AM FORMALLY
INCARCERATED MYSELF.
IN MY HANDS I HAVE A REPORT FULL
OF REASONS WHY WE SHOULD KIDS
KEEP KIDS CLOSER TO HOME I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS ON BEHALF.
OF EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARLENE SANCHES ON WITH
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR RESTORED
IF YOU'VE JUSTICE COURAGE ORACLE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
WE KNOW THAT SENDING YOUNG
PEOPLE TO DJJ AS EXPENSIVE AS
INEFFECTIVE.
AND IT RIPS YOUNG PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT -- SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MY NAME IS ASHLEY AND
I'M FROM OAKLAND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS.
BJJ.
MY NAME IS MORE TASIA I'M FROM
OAKLEY RIVERS ENCOURAGING AYE
STARLEY STRONGLY REPRESENTS
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
SHOULD HAVE MORE PEOPLE LIKE ME
TO LIVE CLOSE TO THE FANCY ABLE.
TO HAVE THE SUPPORT LOVING CARE
FROM THEM AND I HAD THE YOU
SCARED OF BEING ALONE AND NEW
VIOLENCE SCARY PLACE.
OF MY NAME IS CHECK WITH
HERNANDEZ THANK YOU YEAH YEAH.
MY NAME IS CHECK WITH HERNANDEZ
AND I'M FOURTEEN YEARS OLD --
NINE FROM OAKLAND I REPRESENT.
COURAGE IN HOMES.
AND I SAID -- MY NAME IS MY AND
I WORK WITH THE ORGANIZATION
CALLED COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
STUDY OF YOUTH JUSTICE.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY YOUNGEST ALLAH FROM
COMMUNITIES AFTER SORT OF
JUSTICE ON FORMALLY INCARCERATED
DROUGHT JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL TO KEEP OUR
FAMILIES TOGETHER.
PLACES WHERE THEY CAN BE
PROVIDED SERVICES THEY NEED.
A GOOD MORNING EMILY HARRIS OF
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ISRAEL VIA WITH ME BY SALINAS
SPROUT A CO SPONSOR OF HIS BILL
I WAS ALSO IN SEE YA FROM.
NINETY FIVE TO NINETY NINE AND
IT'S SAD WHEN THE SAME.
A TRUSTEE THEY'RE STILL
HAPPENING WITH OUR YOUTH SO AND
AGAIN HAVE STRONG SUPPORT.
AMONG THE COFFEE ARNOLD WOULD
MEET BUFF RECENTLY INCARCERATED --
TO FULL SUPPORT.
TO HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA FROM
COMMUNITIES UNITED FIRST OR IF
YOU'VE JUST THIS AND AT A VERY
YOUNG AGE I HAD IT TO MY COUSIN.
BE LOCKED UP IN THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM AND FOR ME NOT TO BE
THERE WITH HIM.
WAS VERY SCARY AND FOR HIM NOT
TO HAVE MY SUPPORT WHICH IS YOU
KNOW WRONG BECAUSE AS A YOUNG
PERSON YOU KNOW YOU LOOK UP TO
FAMILY MEMBERS AND TO NOT BE
THERE FOR A FAMILY MEMBER AND A
HARD TIME.
IT WAS REALLY HARD FOR THE BOTH
OF US AND OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH.
YOU KNOW BROKEN TOWARDS THAT --
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL -- MY
NAME IS DANYA I'M FROM OAKLAND
AND I'M PART OF THE ORGANIZATION
CALLED COURAGE AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECOMING --
A LOT IN MY STATE BECAUSE
KEEPING YOUTH CLOSER TO THEIR
HOME ACTUALLY ALLOWS THEM TO
BETTER THEMSELVES IT AND INSTEAD
OF SENDING THEM AWAY AND KEEPING
THEM FAR AWAY FROM THE PEOPLE
THAT LOVE THEM.
ACTUALLY DOES THE OPPOSITE AND
WE WANT TO KEEP ARE YOU THAT --
MY NAME IS ALBUM LISTEN IN ON
FROM OAKLAND I SUPPORTERS BILL.
I AM.
HI MY NAME IS THE MARIN FROM
OAKLAND US I HAVE BUTTERFLIES
AND I USED IT IS.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS BILL IF I
WAS GOING TO THE SAME THING I
WOULDN'T WANT TO BE AWAY FROM MY
MOM DAD BROTHER AND SISTER.
WHEN OUR YOUTH IS GOING THROUGH
IT THEY NEED TO SUPPORT FROM THE
PEOPLE THEY TRUST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANDREW WHEN PROUD REBOUNDS
SECOND STATE UNIVERSITY HAS FROM
EXPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELLEN DAHLKE I'M A
TEACHER AT OAKLAND TECH HIGH
SCHOOL I'VE BEEN TEACHING FOR
ELEVEN YEARS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
PRISONS AND JAILS.
I KNOW KIDS DO THINGS ALL THE
TIME THAT WE WISH WE WOULDN'T
BUT I HAVEN'T FOUND ONE WHO
DOESN'T RESPOND WITH GRATITUDE
RESPECT AND GROWTH TO ADULTS WHO
REALLY LISTEN TO HIM REALLY
RESPECT THEM.
AND REALLY KNOW HOW TO GET THEM
TO WHERE THEY'RE GOING.
TEACH TEENAGERS LIKE THE REST OF
US DO THE BEST WHEN THEY HAVE AN
INTERGENERATIONAL COMMUNITY OF
PEERS PARENTS TEACHERS COACHES
NEIGHBORHOOD ORGANIZER
GRANDPARENTS OTHER -- JEEZ WE
KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM IMPACTED
KIDS ARE COMING FROM MAJORITY
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES I WANT
YOU TO THINK ABOUT MINIMUM WAGE
AND BAY AREA RENTS WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THESE KIDS LIKE THE
HEAD OF HAVING A TRUSTED ADULT.
WHO CAN?
GET THE TIME OFF WORK AT THE
SAME TIME THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO THE CAR AT THE SAME TIME THAT
THEY HAVE CHILD CARE SO THE NO
DRIVING ALL OVER THE STATE TO BE
WITH THEIR KIDS.
IF YOU COULD WRAP UP.
EVEN IF IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE
LOCALLY KEEP KIDS AT HOME I'M
HAVING A HARD TIME THINKING
ABOUT WHO IN OUR COMMUNITY
DISPENSED DESERVES TO BE
PRIORITIZED MORE MORALLY AND
FINANCIALLY MORE THAN KIDS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGEL IN KHôNG I'M
FROM OAKLAND I'M WITH COURAGE
AND MY COUSINS BEEN INCARCERATED
SO I KNOW THAT.
TAKING USE FAR AWAY FROM THEIR
HOME BECAUSE THIS TRAUMA IN HER
NOT ONLY TO THEM BUT ALSO TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SO TECHNICALLY THIS PART OF THE
SUPPORT DISPOSED BE YOUR NAME
AND I SUPPORT I WILL.
SAY SOMETHING MORE BUT PLEASE DO
NOT GO ON TO WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE A MOVE FAST.
OKAY GO AHEAD WILL DO JERRY FROM
IN DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE SMART.
HELLO MY NAME IS A PIZZA WITH
THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION OUR
CALLS CO SPONSORS AT THIS BILL
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
PYLE MONTHLY HONEST BECAUSE THE
WITH COMMUNITY WORKS WERE IN
SUPPORT ALSO COSPONSOR THE BILL.
DANIEL TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GET A LITTLE MORE FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA PART OF COURAGE AND I
ALSO SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME'S AT ALEA COME
FROM OAKLAND AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS.
DâN ACCORD ARNOLD HAVE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE UNIVERSITY WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NINE
SUPPORT.
RENAME IN OUR WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE A
CO SPONSOR THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MEADOWS WITH THE
INTERESTS OF THE COLLISION
PROTOCOL SPONSOR THIS BILL IN
FULL SUPPORT.
LOOTERS THE LAND SO BOY THEM IN
A COLOR I SPOKE.
MY NAME IS FERNANDO AND I
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS PEDRO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND I'M SUPPOSED TO LOSE BONE
RAISONNABLE CLOWN WITH
COMMISSIONER FOR SERVE THE
JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GIVEN THE JUSTICE COALITION WERE
ALSO HERE TODAY FOR DION
WHITFIELD WHO WAS FOUND HUNG IN
HIS CELL AFTER SEVEN MONTHS OF
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT SEE YA.
SO FOR DION AND DERAIL AND
EVERYONE ELSE WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MY NAME IS MARY HYATT FROM
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TOMAR TOOK OUT WITH LA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE MY OFFICE ACTUALLY DOES
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
BUT WE ARE.
LISTED AS SUPPORTING SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE IT CLEAR WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER AT THIS POINT.
THANKS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AWAY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I SEE ONE STILL COMING
QUICKLY PLEASE.
JIM WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THE BOTTLE NECK BACK THERE
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ONE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
AND SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT SO NOW WE ARE HEARING --
FOR THIS IS STILL IN SUPPORT GO
AHEAD.
THESE WITH AFFORDED SOME
RECOVERY IN SACRAMENTO
COLLABORATIVE GROUP -- IN
SUPPORT.
ROBERT NGUYEN FROM ANTI RESIDENT
COALITION A STRONG SUPPORT.
GREAT.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE WILL HAVE OUR
WITNESSES NOT
.
GOOD.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIORNIA.
HERE TODAY -- RESPECTFULLY AND
IN OPPOSITION TO SB -- TWO
EIGHTY FOUR I DO WANNA THANK ON
THE SENATOR EXCUSE ME IN HIS
OFFICE FOR OUR CONVERSATIONS TO
DATE ON THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE -- MANY MANY OF THE THINGS
IN WHICH THAT WERE DISCUSSED WE
CERTAINLY -- SHARE -- YOU KNOW
MISSION AND VISION -- FOR
WORKING WITH YOUTH IN OUR SYSTEM --
PROVISION APARTMENTS A COUNTIES --
THROUGHOUT THE LAST DECADE IF
NOT MORE HAVE REALLY
DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT TO
SERVING YOUTH LOCALLY WHENEVER
POSSIBLE A C. PARKIN AND
PROBATION HAS BEEN A PARTNER.
WITH THE LEGISLATURE WITH --
MANY ADMINISTRATIONS OVER THE
YEARS TO WORK ON KEEPING KIDS
LOCALLY INVESTING IN THE SYSTEM
AND REALLY MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE ONLY RESERVING.
THE DJJ AND AND SECURE SETTINGS
FOR THOSE YOU TO POSE THE
HIGHEST RISK OF OF RE OFFENSE
AND HAVE THE HIGHEST NEED -- I
THINK THIS -- COMMITMENT TO
THOSE THINGS AS EVIDENCED BY THE
OVER 74% DECLINE IN YOUTH
COMMITTED TO DJJ OVER THE YEARS
AND A 60% DECLINE IN JUVENILE
DETENTION -- IN ITS ENTIRETY --
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND CERTAINLY
WALL -- WE ALWAYS ENDEAVOR TO
SERVE YOUTH AT THE FRONT END OF
THE SYSTEM -- WHERE POSSIBLE
THAT THERE IS A NEED -- FOR THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
THE STATE ROLE -- EGGMAN AGAIN
AT DJJ IS RESERVE FOR THE THE
HIGHEST NEED YOUTH THE HIGHEST A
RISK TO RE OFFEND AND
POTENTIALLY YOU THAT NEED MORE
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMMING -- THAT
COUNTIES ARE CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE.
I KNOW PART OF THE STATED GOAL
OF THIS BILL TIME IS TO
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES -- TO KEEP
MORE YOUTH LOCALLY AND AND IN
DOING SO REALLY GOES BACK TO
KIND OF THE THE REFERENCE TO THE
SLIDING SCALE THAT WAS PUT INTO
A FACT -- IN THE NINETIES BUT
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW WAS
THAT THAT SLIDING SCALE WAS
REALLY -- PUT INTO PLACE AT A
TIME WHEN THE DJJ POPULATION WAS
VERY VERY HIGH -- AND AND THERE
WAS A LARGE POPULATION OF KIND
OF LOWER RISK OFFENDERS THAT --
THE STATE WAS TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES TO KEEP
LOCALLY -- IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
WITH SB EIGHTY ONE ON THAT SET
FOR THE JUVENILE REALIGNMENT IN
WHICH PROBATION WAS A PARTNER OF
AND THAT ENDED COMMITMENTS OF
NONVIOLENT YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS TO
DJJ SO THAT REALLY WAS THE
CATALYST -- FOR KEEPING THOSE
LOWER RISK -- YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS
OUT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND SO NOW --
REINSTITUTING KIND OF THIS
SLIDING SCALE -- AT A TIME WHEN
THE SYSTEM LOOKS MUCH DIFFERENT
THE SAME INCENTIVES -- I THINK
AS AS IS -- FOR IT AS THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL REALLY DON'T HOLDEN
AND INSTEAD WERE ACTUALLY VERY
CONCERNED THAT IT'S GOING TO
HAVE THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
OF IMPACT DEAN OTHER PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE TO
THOSE YOUTH LOCALLY IN OUR CARE --
ULTIMATELY THE HEALTH WELFARE
AND WELL BEING OF YOUTH IS OUR
PRIMARY GOAL IN MAKING SURE
THEY'RE IN THE MOST APPROPRIATE
PLACEMENT WHETHER THAT BE
LOCALLY OR THE STATE AND AND
CERTAINLY WE WORK WITH THE THE
COURTS TOWARD THAT END AS THEY
MAKE THE ULTIMATE DECISION ON IN
IN PLACING.
AND DJJ -- BUT FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS -- WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE TODAY WE CERTAINLY LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE SENATOR AND THE SPONSOR.
THANKS NEXT -- WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING JESSICA DIMENSIONS
THE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AT ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION I DO
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
SENATOR AND HIS OFFICE.
HAVING NUMEROUS MEETINGS WITH US
AND LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS
AND WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
A CONTINUE DIALOGUE.
SO WITH REGARD TO TWO EIGHTY
FOUR COUNTY SHARE IN THE GOAL OF
TREATING HOUSING AS MANY JUSTICE
INVOLVED YOU AS POSSIBLE AND
THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND THIS HAPPENED 90% OF THE
TIME.
COUNTY PROBATION HAS WORKED HARD
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF YOUTH IN
THEIR JUVENILE HALLS AND REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF COMMITMENTS TO THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
INNOVATIVE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING COUNTY THE KEPT MORE
YOUTH IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF YOUTH THAT
THEY SEND TO DJJ BY 74%.
AND BACKED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE WERE.
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED FELONY
JUVENILE ARRESTS.
LA ONLY HAS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
YOU ROUGHLY AND DJJ.
MEANING THAT LESS THAN 3% OF
LA'S FELONY JUVENILE ARRESTS.
LED TO A DJ COMMITMENT.
ALEX HAS DONE THIS THROUGH
PROVIDING INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING
AND THE COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR CONCERN IS
THAT THIS LEGISLATION COULD
IMPACT THAT PROGRAMMING.
THE VAST MAJORITY THAT IS THE
VAST MAJORITY OF YOUTH THAT ARE
BEING SENT TO DJJ OUR YOUTH THAT
CANNOT BE HOUSE LOCALLY BECAUSE
THE COUNTY OF NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED.
LIKE HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
PROGRAMMING SUCH AS YOU THROUGH
COMMITTED SEX OFFENSES AND NEED
THE STATE'S SEX OFFENDER
TREATMENT PROGRAM.
AND IF APPROPRIATE PROGRAMMING
IS NOT AVAILABLE THE COURT WHO
ACTUALLY MAKES THE ULTIMATE
DECISION AS TO WHETHER TO SEND A
YOUTH DJJ WILL HAVE TO COMMIT
THAT YOU.
SO YOUTH WILL CONTINUE TO BE
COMMITTED TO DJJ AND COUNTIES
WILL JUST BE FORCED TO PAY MORE
TOWARDS OUR COMMITMENT.
IT IS UNLIKELY THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL CREATE AN
INCENTIVE TO HOUSE MORE USED
LOCALLY.
AND THAT IT WILL INSTEAD PLACE A
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON THE COUNTIES
THEREBY DIMINISHING PROBATION
BUDGET AND PUTTING EXISTING
PROGRAMMING IN JEOPARDY.
I DO WANT TO ADD THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS OFFICE ON BINDING
MAYBE ALTERNATE SOLUTIONS.
AND WITHOUT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FIGURED ABOUT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT -- I CENTER BILL MAY I
FIRST ASK IF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ANY.
OTHER COMMENT A CORRECTION OR
LET ME SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND ALL
THAT [inaudible]
ARE THERE.
ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD OF WE HAVE A
LETTER FROM JACQUI LACY --
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IT WAS INDICATED THERE BY A
TESTIMONY THAT WE THAT THE DA EN
LA WAS NOT IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
OR NEUTRAL.
HERE'S A LETTER IF YOU WANNA
[inaudible]
RESERVE.
OKAY WE HAVE DELEGATED -- MARCH
SIX WHICH TO THE COMMITTEES ON A
LOT WE DO WE DO HAS WATER AND A
BELIEVE IT'S IN THE BACK -- SO I
I AM SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
AND I WANT TO RAISE A COUPLE
ISSUES THOUGH.
I THINK IT IS -- WHAT I THINK IS
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS RIGHT AT
GIVEN THEIR?
SO ARE -- THE AUTHOR HAS
PROVIDED US A CHART WHICH SHOWS
US HOW MUCH ROOM IS IN OUR
COUNTY FACILITIES NOW WE KNOW
THAT.
OUR DJ JAY POPULATION ALONE HAS
GREATLY DECREASED. FOR MANY
REASONS THE BEST OF WHICH IS
THAT ACTUAL YOUTH CRIME IS
SIGNIFICANTLY DOWN AND HAS BEEN
FOR TWENTY YEARS. FOR TWENTY
YEARS YOUTH SERIES YOUTH CRIME
IS DROP DROP DROP DROP.
AND SORE DJJ POPULATION IS DOWN
THERE ALSO OTHER ON POLICIES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S ENACTED
THAT IS REDUCE THAT POPULATION
BUT OUR POPULATION IN THE
COUNTIES IS SIGNIFICANTLY DOWN
TO THE POINT.
WHERE IF YOU LOOK AT THIS CHART
YOU'LL SEE THERE ARE MANY
CONTIES FOR HOLDING ONLY FIVE
YOU [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
IRONICALLY.
A RECENT OUR INVESTIGATIVE
REPORT BY THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE SHOW THAT WE HAVE
COUNTIES THAT ARE SPENDING.
IT DID. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY K. AND
A BUFF ALAMEDA COUNTY FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ANNUALLY
ON THE HOLDING OF USE.
US IN A CLEAR COUNTY THE
DOCTOR'S OWN COUNTY FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND A YEAR
HOLDING YOUTH.
SO THERE ARE VERY FEW COUNTIES
FOR WHOM THAT THE COST TO THEM
WOULD BE LESS.
THAN THIS COST THAT WE WOULD NOW
BE RACING.
SO IT'S I GUESS WHAT I'M REYES
IS I'M NOT SURE IF IT WILL
CREATE THE FISCAL INCENTIVES
THAT WE QUITE HOPE.
BUT I CERTAINLY THINK IT IS
LEGITIMATE TO DO SO BECAUSE
CERTAINLY WE WOULDN'T WANT TO BE
IN THE SITUATION WHERE WE WERE.
AS WE HAVE.
ONLY BE EXPECTING A TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND BECAUSE THEN THAT WOULD
REALLY HAVE A VERY SIGNIFICANT
MOTIVATION TO SEND MORE USED TO
DJJ GIVEN THE COST.
THAT OUR WN COUNTIES ARE
SPENDING.
BUT I THINK WHAT IT RAISES IS
THAT [inaudible]
OBVIOUSLY.
WE ARE WE NO -- THAT.
BY REMOVING YOUTHS FROM
PROXIMITY TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE DON'T IMPROVE OUTCOMES BUT
WHAT.
WE SEE NOW IS THAT ARE COUNTY
FACILITIES EVEN ARE NOT
NECESSARILY GIVING US GREAT OUT
COMES.
AND THAT IT MAY BE JUST THE
ENTIRE.
HOLDING OF YOUTH IN A ARE CALLED
A PUNITIVE SETTING.
DOES NOT PROVIDE.
THE TYPE OF WORK.
THAT THE YOUTH NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO TO ADDRESS WHATEVER ISSUES
CAUSE THEM TO TO ENGAGE IN THE
BEHAVIOR THEY ENGAGED WHICH THEN
COULD.
LEAD US TO A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE
WE POTENTIALLY WOULD HAVE USED
THAT ARE NOT.
ON COMMITTING THOSE ACTS AND THE
THE DATA WOULD SEEM TO INDICATE
THAT JUST BY VIRTUE OF BEING
HELD EVEN IN A COUNTY FACILITY.
YOUR LIKELIHOOD TO GO INTO AN
ADULT FACILITY.
INCREASES ITS I FORGET THE EXACT
PERCENT BUT IT'S IN THE THIRTY
YEAR PERCENT OR WATER SO SO
ANYWAY.
SO I THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO GO BUT I THINK THAT
WE AS A LEGISLATURE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THIS WHOLE QUESTION.
OF HOW WE DEAL WITH YOUTH AND
YOUTH OFFENDERS -- BOTH DUE TO
THE COST IN THE COUNTIES AND DUE
TO THE WE'RE NOT ACHIEVING NOW
COMES WE HAD WE HAD INTENDED AND
I ARE.
IT IS REMINISCENT OF SENATOR
MITCHELL'S COMMENTS REGARDING
OUR THINKING THAT CERTAIN OF OUR
SENSES WOULD CREATE A A
INCENTIVE OR A MESSAGE THAT.
YOU KNOW -- TO SUPPRESS THAT
ACTIVITY WHICH THEY HAVE NOT.
IN SO SIMILARLY I THINK IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO LOOK AT
WHETHER WE ARE ACHIEVING WHAT WE
INTENDED TO WITH THE WAY THAT
WE'VE EVEN DESIGNED.
ANY OF OUR USE AT ADDRESSING
YOUTH DEFENSES ESPECIALLY GIVEN
HOW SIGNIFICANTLY.
YOUTH CRIME IS DROPPED -- BUT
WITHOUT SAID AS I INDICATED I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
THE FIRM.
NHIáU DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR AND SENATOR BILL DO
YOU WANT TO CLOSE AND THEN I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
OF YES WE'RE SPENDING THE HUGE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND DEPARTMENT
GIVING -- A YOUTH OFFENDER BLOCK
GRANT TO COUNTIES.
TO SERVE LOCAL USE THAT --
OTHERWISE WOULD BE COMMITTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE WE'RE ALSO GIVING A
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT.
THE THIRTY EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN OUR
BUDGET FOR AT RISK YOU WOULD
JUSTICE INVOLVE YOU.
AND WE'RE ALSO -- FUNDING LOCAL
OFFENDER REHABILITATION FACILITY
CONSTRUCTION FINANCING TO THE
TUNE OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND CONSTRUCTION FOR
FACILITIES.
WERE ALSO -- WE HAVE A USE FOR
INVESTMENT GRANT -- THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS -- TO SUPPORT
OUR DIVERSION PROGRAMS.
FOR YOU FOR THE LOW LOW LEVEL
OFFENSES SO.
AND WE HAVE A IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE FACILITIES ARE ONLY A
THIRD FLOOR.
AND WE HAVE FOUR FACILITIES WITH
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND OR SIX SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE A YOUNG PEOPLE
IN OUR FACILITIES SO.
WHERE WE HAVE THESE FACILITIES
AS YOU SAID THAT ARE?
HELP FOR A THIRD PHONE NINE AND
WE'RE NOT EVEN IF WE'RE ENDING
WE'RE SPENDING THE MONEY ON THE
OPERATING EXPENSES FOR ALL THAT
AND THE SAME THING THAT THE
ACTUAL SAME THINGS HAPPEN AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL I MEAN.
SO WE'RE WE'RE IN A IN A PLACE
WERE.
WE HAVE TO TRANSFORM THINGS AND
AND THIS BILL GOES IN THAT
DIRECTION SO.
SO I ARE CHEN AYE VOTE ON THIS
AND OF THE TRANSFORMATION ASTOR
CURVE WE'RE SPENDING.
WAY OVER.
THE TYPES OF MONEY WE SHOULD BE
SPENDING.
ON THINGS THAT DON'T REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
AS AN ADULT.
I'M THERE'S A MOTION BEFORE US
LED SEVERAL CALL.
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
RIGHT SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL HIGH MORALE.
WIENER.
RIGHT I'M WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME MISSING
MEMBERS BUT YEAH LOOKING GOOD.
ALL RIGHT -- LET US MOVE NOW TO
ITEM THIRTEEN SB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT SENATOR ARE TO LETTER
.
LIKE [inaudible]
THIS
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR IN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- I AM SO EXCITED TODAY
THIS IS MY FIRST BILL AND BEFORE
I GO ANY FURTHER I JUST LIKE TO
THANK YOU ALL SENATORS WHO BEEN.
SO HOSPITABLE AND AND AND
EXTENDED YOUR FRIENDSHIP I
APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS IS MY FIRST BILL ALSO TODAY
THIS BILL I PRESENT A SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY EIGHT SIGN TO
EXPAND THE PROTECTIONS OF THE
PEACE OFFICER BILL OF RIGHTS.
OF THE POOR BAR TWO OFFICERS IN
MODIFIED COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE GREAT
RECESSION FORCED THE CLOSURE OF
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES ADMINISTERED BY SMALL
MUNICIPALITIES.
THESE FACILITIES REMAIN CLOSED
UNTIL TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN THE
STATE BEGAN TO CON CONTRACT WITH
IMPACTED MY DISPARITIES TO BEGIN
RETROFITTING THE CLOSE
FACILITIES. TO ACCOMMODATE THE
RE OPENING OF THESE CORRECTIONAL
CENTERS IN TWENTY TWELVE THE
STATE ENACTED SENATE BILL.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE TO CREATE NEW
CLASSIFICATION OF PEACE OFFICERS
THAT PERFORMED THE SAME DUTIES
AT THE STATE CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS.
THESE OFFICER DID THE SAME WORK
AS THE OTHER PIECE BY PIECE
OFFICERS IN THE STATE FACILITIES
BUT WITH THE NEW NAME AND A NEW
BRAND.
HOWEVER THIS NEW CLASSIFICATION
FOR OFFICERS.
IN THE NEWLY CREATED MODIFIED
COMMUNITY CORRECTION FACILITIES
WOULD NOT AFFORDED NOT ADDED TO
THE CALIFORNIA PLEASE THE POLICE
OFFICER PROCEDURAL BILL OF
RIGHTS.
THE FACT THAT THEY WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PEACE OFFICERS
BILL OF RIGHTS IS AN OVERSIGHT
THAT WE CAN FIX TODAY.
BRING IN FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY
TO ALL THOSE WHO DO THE MEN WHO
DO THE WORK BOTH MEN AND WOMEN --
NEED TO BE TREATED FAIRLY IN
EQUITY ACROSS THE BOARD.
THE SPIRIT OF SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY EIGHT IT'S TO PROVIDE A
FAIR APPLICATION OF THE LAW TO
ALL DOING THE SAME WORK THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE -- THESE
INDIVIDUALS DOESN'T CHANGE YOUR
PAY -- DOESN'T HURT A CHANGER
WORK DUTIES OR RESPONSIBILITIES.
UP.
OR ANY OTHER TITLE THEY MAY HAVE
INSTEAD IT ENSURES THAT ALL THAT
ARE DOING THE SAME WORK ARE
TREATED EQUALLY AND FAIRLY
ACROSS THE BOARD.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY EIGHT IS
NECESSARY DUE TO THE FACT THAT
SOME ADMINISTRATORS IN THESE
FACILITIES HAVE BEGUN PICKING
AND CHOOSING THE SOME
INDIVIDUALS THAT THESE
PROTECTIONS APPLY.
TO THIS ARBITRARY APPLICATION OF
THE LAW IS COMPLETELY AGAINST
WHAT THE STATE STANDS FOR AND
SHOULD NOT BE A PRACTICE IN
ANYWHERE IN OUR STATE FACILITIES.
AGAIN FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY IS
WHAT I'M SHOOTING.
FOR BY INCLUDING THESE OFFICERS
IN THE PEACE OFFICER BILL OF
RIGHTS WILL EXTEND TO THEM THE
RIGHTS THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE.
AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN GRANTED TO
THEM SOME TIME AGO.
AND THE SAME WORK THAT THEY'RE
DOING IS JUST SIMPLY A TOP A
CHANGE OF TITLE.
THIS EXPANSION IS ONLY FOR A FEW
FACILITIES THAT FIT THIS
DESIGNATION BUT WILL MAKE A
WORLD OF DIFFERENCE TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
THAT WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND WITH ME TODAY I WAS ASKED
THE THAT IT NOT YOU HERNANDEZ
BEER BUT HE'S JOB RUNNING A
LITTLE LATE.
SO I HAVE WITH US THE MEMBER THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA.
AND JANET YOUR DAY AND IT
CORRECTION OFFICER AND AND IN
THESE FACILITIES.
AND HER HUSBAND A BRADLEY TO
OKAY A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER IN A
FACILITY UNDER THE PEACE OPTION
BILL OF RIGHTS.
CHAU.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
CONSIDER THIS BILL IS SOMETHING
THAT THAT WILL BE BALLOT TO
SCALE BRING A QUALITY BACK TO IT.
AND TREAT EVERYBODY FAIRLY SO IF
I MAY.
YES YOU MAY PROCEED GO AHEAD.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS SHANNON SHERRILL.
I AM A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AT
THE MODIFIED COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY IN CHAPTER
CALIFORNIA.
THIS FACILITIES RUN BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUT IS DIRECTLY
CONTRACTED WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR INMATES WHO
OTHERWISE.
WOULD HAVE BEEN OUR IN OUR STATE
MAINLINE PRISONS I HAVE WORKED
AT THIS FACILITY FOR OVER TEN
YEARS BEFORE AND AFTER
REALIGNMENT.
I AM A PROUD MEMBER OF THE CW A
LOCAL NINE ONE TEN FACILITY
BEGAN RECEIVING INMATES IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AFTER
REALIGNMENT.
THE FACILITY WAS DESIGNATED TO
RECEIVE INMATES LARGELY TO HELP
REDUCE THE POPULATION AT THE
STATE PRISONS AND TO COMPLY WITH
THE FEDERAL MAGISTRATE.
I AM HERE THIS MORNING TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT THIS BILL IS VERY
NARROW AND WELL JUSTIFIED.
WE HAVE PEACE OFFICER STATUS WE
WORK WITH STATE INMATES EVERY
OTHER OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA IN A
SIMILAR POSITION WITH THE SAME
RESPONSIBILITIES IS COVERED BY
PIECE OFF THE BILL OF RIGHTS ACT.
HOWEVER WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
LABOR RIGHTS AT MC CS WE ARE IN
A LEGAL LIMBO.
OUR SUPERVISORS CAN DETERMINE ON
A CASE BY CASE BASIS WHETHER TO
FOLLOW THE PROTOCOLS LAID OUT
AND PRO BAR.
THEY CAN EVEN PICK AND CHOOSE
WHICH PIECES OF THE PEACE
OFFICER BILL OF RIGHTS TO FOLLOW
WHICH MEANS THAT TIMES ARE CUTE
ARE UNION MEMBERS ARE DENIED THE
RIGHT TO CONSULT WITH THEIR
UNION REPRESENTATIVES.
KNOW WHETHER STATE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS IN THIS SITUATION I
HAVE WORKED AS A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER FOR OVER TWENTY ONE
YEARS AND IN EVERY FACILITY.
AND AGENCY I'VE WORKED.
PROBAR IS APPLIED SO THEY KNEW I
KNEW MY RIGHTS.
PROBAR SIMPLY PROVIDES
CONSISTENCY UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
HOW SUPERVISORS HANDLE INTERNAL
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER DISPUTE.
IT GIVES THE RULES FOR WHEN WE
CAN COUNT CONSULT OUR UNION OUR
LAWYERS AND HOW INTERROGATIONS
CAN BE CARRIED OUT BY OUR
SUPERVISORS.
LABOR RIGHT SHOULD NOT BE
GRANTED ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
THIS GAP IN CURRENT LAW IS A
RESULT OF HOW ARE CORRECTION
OFFICER STATUS CAN CREATE WAS
CREATED BY STATUTE WHEN
REALIGNMENT OCCURRED OUR
FACILITY WAS NOT OPERATIONAL.
OUR CORRECTIONAL STATUS HAD NOT
YET BEEN CREATED.
IN THE FIRST YEAR OF REALIGNMENT
THE STATE CAL STATE A CALIFORNIA
CREATED THE MODIFIED
CORRECTIONAL COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES THERE
ARE FIVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE WERE ALL LEFT OUT.
OF THE PENAL CODE AND CREATED
OFFICER CATEGORY MUST MADE AS
PEACE OFFICERS AND SENT STATE
PRISONERS ARE WAY.
WHAT THEY NEGLECTED TO DO WAS
SPECIFICALLY STATE THAT HE'S OFF
THE BILL OF RIGHTS PROTOCOLS
APPLY TO S. AS A RESULT I HAVE
WITNESSED AND LESS KNOWLEDGEABLE
WORKERS BE DENIED THEIR POBRE
RIGHT?
INSTEAD OUR SUPERVISORS AND
ADMINISTRATORS SIMPLY MADE UP
WHATEVER PROCEDURES THEY WANTED.
WHEN INVESTIGATING AND I WORKER
AT OFFICER THIS IS NOT GOOD FOR
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER RELATIONS I
HAVE SEEN SUPERVISORS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY INVOLVED WITH THE ISSUE
BEING INVESTIGATED BE PUT IN
CHARGE OF THE INVESTIGATION?
AND QUESTIONING OF EMPLOYEES.
THIS IS NOT AN ACCEPTABLE
PRACTICE SINCE IT COULD LEAD TO
COERCION INTIMIDATION AND WILL
PREVENT THE FAX FROM COMING OUT.
OF OUR BRAVE I PROVIDES A
PROTOCOL TO ENSURE THAT ALL
INVESTIGATIONS ARE NEUTRAL AND
FREE IT FROM COERCION AND ABUSES
OF POWER.
IT CAN BE VERY INTIMIDATED FOR
YOUNGER OFFICER TO BE
INVESTIGATED BY AN OUT OF
CONTROL SUPERVISOR WHO IS VESTED
IN THE OUTCOME OF THE MATTER.
IT IS NOT GOOD FOR ANYONE
WITHOUT CLEAR PROBAR STATUS.
WORKERS ARE FORCED TO GO TO
COURT SIMPLY TO DETERMINE WHICH
PROCEDURES WILL BE FOLLOWED
CREATING TENSION CHAOS AND
WASTING VALUABLE TIME AND
RESOURCES.
SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT WILL CLOSE
THIS LOOPHOLE AND PROVIDE CLEAR
DIRECTION FOR SUPERVISORS TO
FOLLOW AND IT WILL LET OUR UNION
MEMBERS KNOW THE RULES THAT
THEIR SUPERVISORS WILL HAVE TO
FOLLOW. FOR THESE REASONS I ASK
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BRADLEY CHOATE I AM A
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISOR IN A
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON.
I WORKED IN CORRECTIONS FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY.
MY SUPERVISORS HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW POOL BAR.
AS A SUPERVISOR MYSELF I HAVE
BEEN REQUIRED TO FOLLOW POOL BAR.
I SHOULD ALWAYS MEANT I SHOULD
ALSO MENTION THAT.
I AM SHANNON'S HUSBAND OVER THE
YEARS WE HAVE SHARED OUR DAILY
EXPERIENCES WITH EACH OTHER IT
IS FRUSTRATING TO KNOW THE
WORKERS AT THE MCC APPS ARE
FORCED TO UNDER.
UNKNOWN LABOR RIGHTS FRANKLY
DOES NOT MAKE ANY SENSE THAT
WORKERS LIKE MY WIFE ARE FORCED
TO GUESS WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE
AND HAVE NO CLEAR ANSWER ON HOW
THEYCAN ENGAGE OUR UNION OR
SIMPLY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT TO DO
OFFICE SUPERVISORS TRYING TO
INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME OF AN
INTERNAL.
EMPLOYEE INVESTIGATION.
AS A SUPERVISOR IT IS BENEFICIAL
FOR ME AND FOR EVERYONE TO KNOW
THAT WE WILL FOLLOW.
UP POOL BAR PROTOCOL.
THE WORKERS KNOW THE RIGHTS WHEN
IT COMES TO DEALING WITH
SUPERVISORS AND WE CAN HANDLE
SENSITIVE EMPLOYEE MATTERS IN A
PREDICTABLE AND ORGANIZED MANNER.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THE POPE POPE
OUR BRAINS AND IMPORTANT
CERTAINTY TO A PROCESS THAT CAN
OTHERWISE BEING MANIPULATED.
IF AN OFFICER DOES SOMETHING
WRONG HERE SEE SHOULD BE SUBJECT
TO INTERNAL.
PERSONAL ACTION HOWEVER IF HE OR
SHE HAS NOT THERE SHOULD BE A
CLEAR PROCESS TO SORT OUT THE
SITUATION AND ASSURE THAT THE
WORKER DOES NOT TAKE THE FALL
FOR SOMEONE ELSE.
INCLUDING AN OUT OF CONTROL
SUPERVISOR.
IT CAN GET VERY TENSE WORKING IN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES IT IS
ALSO AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
SUPERVISORS.
WHO GO UNCHECKED CAN INTIMIDATE
WORKERS AND CREATE AN
UNACCEPTABLE WORK ENVIRONMENT?
SB THREE SIXTY OR CORRECTED
OVERSIGHT.
MADE WHEN HE'S CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS WERE CREATED IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THEY WANT TO JUST COME
UP TO THE MIKE AND INDICATE YOUR
NAME IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LIZ
SORENSON I AM THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT.
NINE AND I'M STANDING IN SUPPORT
BUT WE ALSO HAPPEN TO BE THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THIS COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT WITH AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
THEREFORE WITH THE CHAPTER
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
IS A SHADE IN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I SEE AND TALK TO THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
ALLIED WITH PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND WE ARE POSTED THE BAIL IT
WOULD ACTUALLY M. COST THE CITY
TO HAVE THESE FACILITIES DELANO
CAPTAIN CHAPTER THERE ARE ONLY.
THREE AM OVER MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AT WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE CCR WHICH THE INMATES
ARE CONTRACTED TO BUILD THEIR
WAY PROVIDE THAT MANY IN THE
CONTRACTS.
THESE THIS BILL WAS ALSO
INTRODUCED BY RUDY SALAS AB.
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO YEARS
AGO AND IT WAS DEFEATED.
AND THIS INFORMATION IS ALREADY
INCLUDED IN CODE SECTION THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED SO WE THINK IT'S
REDUNDANT IT'S NOT NECESSARY.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE SPONSORS THE BILL TO TRY TO
WORK SOMETHING OUT BUT WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL FOR THESE
REASONS -- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
BY -- COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
CENTER MORE LOCKED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR.
I JUST HAVE YOUR FIRST BILL I I
GUESS MY QUESTION WAS GOING TO
BE WHAT WOULD THE COST BE AND
WE'VE JUST BEEN TOLD TO MILLION
DOLLARS I'M JUST WONDERING IF
[inaudible]
THAT.
PARALLELS YOUR CAN YOUR YOUR
YOUR ESTIMATE OF THE COST WELL I
I AM UNDER THE IMPRESSION THERE
IS NO SUCH COST OF LIFE THAT
RECURS REMEMBER.
IT JUST LIKE ALL OF US HERE AS
CENTERS WILL HAVE THE EQUAL
RIGHT PEOPLE SAY CALL VOTE.
IN THIS IS WHAT I'M ASKING FOR
THESE -- CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
TO BE ABLE TO BE UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF A PROBAR SO THEY
HAVE THE EQUAL RIGHTS AS
EVERYONE ELSE.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT -- THAT
THAT'S ALL IT IS -- THE THE THE
OPPOSITION NEVR SPOKE TO ME
ABOUT ANY OPPOSITION BUT THIS IS
NOT A FINANCIAL SITUATION IT IS
AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY EQUAL
RIGHTS -- TO BE ABLE TO BE
REPRESENTED EQUALLY AND FAIRLY
ACROSS THE BOARD THERE ARE MEN
AND WOMEN THAT DATA I'M SORRY TO
SAY THIS SCALE IS NOT ALWAYS
EVEN BUT THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY.
TO COME BACK AND DO WHAT WE
PERHAPS SHOULD HAVE DONE YEARS
AGO WHEN THIS THIS THING STARTED.
THE FACILITIES ARE THERE.
BUT THE WORK IS THE SAME THIS IS
WHAT I'M IF THIS IS WHAT I'M
SAYING.
WHEN WHEN -- BUT ALL OF US ARE
ASKED TO PARTICIPATE IN WHAT WE
DO WE DO IT WITH THE THE SPIRIT
OF FAIRNESS TO QUALITY ACROSS
THE BOARD THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL
IS IS DOING THAT'S ALL IT IS.
IS IT'S NOT A PAY INCREASE IS
NOT CHANGING ANYBODY'S TITLE
IT'S NOT CREATED SUPERVISORS
IT'S NOT CREATING CHANGE OF DUTY
STATIONS.
IT IS JUST FAIRNESS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING [inaudible]
FOR WITHIN.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS MILLION
DOLLARS.
I I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT FIGURE
CAME FROM FROM.
BUT IF IF THIS IS NOT
APPROPRIATIONS OF COURSE NOT.
CENTURY STATE SENATOR I'M I'M
SURE YOU WOULD BE MORE THAN
WILLING TO PERSONALLY MAKE UP
THE DIFFERENCE OF A MILLION
DOLLARS CORRECT.
WELL I'M GONNA GO TO YOUR BANK
AND ASK FOR YOUR ACCOUNT.
OF THAT SENATOR JACKSON ASKED ME
TO HAYES YOU FREE ALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I I WAS.
I WAS PRETTY.
I WAS PRE WAR AND THAT IS YOUR
FIRST BILL SENATE ARCHULETA
SOMEONE IS GONNA HATE YOU LITTLE
BIT AND I AND I TAKE THE SPIRIT.
AND AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM
[inaudible]
CENTER WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR -- SO.
MY VIEW IS.
THAT WHO BORE BORE IS THE PLACE
UP I HATE THAT PHRASE PLEASE
OFFICE A BILL RIGHT -- IS MORE
ABOUT WHAT IS COVERED VAN WHICH
OFFICERS ARE OR NOT.
I IN A AND LAST TIME THIS BILL
WAS OUT -- IT WAS A FEW YEARS
AGO AND SINCE THEN WAS WHAT IS
ONE THING THAT IS CHANGES THAT
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
CHAIR.
WE PASSED SENATE BILL --
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE DIED
PROVIDED SOME MUCH NEEDED REFORM --
FOR WHAT WAS GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC IN TERMS
OF SERIOUS COMPLAINTS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUSTAIN THAT I WAS HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THAT -- I DON'T THINK
THE I SUPPORTYOUR BILL BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK IT MAKES SENSE SO.
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN PEOPLE CAN HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS ABOUT WHETHER IT
SHOULD EXIST AT ALL OR OR OR
WHATEVER.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE IT LEAVING
OUT ONE CLASS OF OFFICERS ARE
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME SO -- I
UNDERSTAND WHY -- THIS DIDN'T
MOVE FORWARD WHEN.
FREE SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WHEN.
TRULY THE SYSTEM WAS BROKEN IN
TERMS OF WHAT WAS BEING -- HELD
FROM THE PUBLIC -- BUT WITHOUT
REFORM -- UNCOMFORTABLE --
CHEAPNESS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY SENATOR MITCHELL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR REFERENCE TO
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE I'VE JUST.
SINCE THE SKINNER IS HERE UGH.
MY RECENT UNDERSTANDING IS
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE REALLY ISN'T
BEING.
IMPLEMENTED FAIRLY EQUALLY
EQUALLY ACROSS THE STATE IS THAT
A FAIR ASSESSMENT A SKINNER AT
THE PRESENT MOMENT YES THAT'S A
FAIR ASSESSMENT THANK YOU.
I'M SURE GENERAL YES I YOU AND I
HEARD ON THE YES AND I AND I AM --
I AGREE I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S POSITION I I
AM -- WORLD FRUSTRATED BY THAT
BUT I GOT WILL RESOLVE ITSELF IN
THE RIGHT WAY.
ALL RIGHT -- I WILL NOW ADD MY A
SOME COMMENTS -- FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE WAS ONLY A MODEST IT MOSTLY.
IT DID.
HAVE A MEMBER TO PROBAR BUT ITS
PRIMARY MEMBERS FOR THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT -- I APPRECIATE I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
CATEGORY OF EMPLOYEES THAT WOULD%
LIKE THAT FEEL THAT THIS THEIR
EXCLUSION.
HAS TREATED THEM UNFAIRLY AND AS
A PERSON WHO -- ORGANIZE THE A
UNION -- BECAUSE I FELT THAT THE
CATEGORY AT THAT I WORKED IN AT
THAT TIME WAS NOT BEING TREATED
FAIRLY AND WE SUCCEEDED SO I
TOTALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
MY DIFFICULTY RIGHT NOW.
I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THIS
BILL.
IS THAT IN IN THIS IN GIVEN THE
COMMENTS THAT SENATOR WIENER
MADE IT SORT OF YOU KNOW IT'S AN
ONE COULD SAY WELL LOOK I SHOULD
[inaudible]
JUST ALLOW.
THOSE OFFICERS WHO HAVE -- WOULD
NORMALLY BE IN THIS -- GIVEN OUR
PAST ACTIONS. TO YOU KNOW HAVE
THE SAME THE SAME RIGHTS.
MY PROBLEM THOUGH IS IF BY COULD
REDO -- POLE BARN OF COURSE ANY
OF US COULD INTRODUCE IT BUT
IT'S THE DIFFICULT -- IT'S A
DIFFICULT BILL TO OPEN UP BUT I
FEEL THAT.
IN THE STATE'S.
USE OF IT TOWARDS OUR OFFICERS
WERE IN CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
THAT THERE ARE TWO PROVISIONS IN
KHOBAR THAT ARE PROBLEMATIC.
THAT I THINK PERHAPS ONE WAS NOT
FULLY DEBATED OR UNDERSTOOD.
WHEN IT WAS EXTENDED TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN?
WHO ARE CUSTODIAL OFFICERS AND
THOSE TWO ARE THE ISSUES AROUND?
THE PROHIBITION OF SEARCHING OF
LOCKERS AND PERSONAL.
I'M JUST BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF WHEN YOU'RE A CUSTODIAL
OFFICER IN THE IN.
YOU KNOW NOT MAKING ANY KIND OF
BLANKET STATEMENT THE CAN STUDIO
OFFICERS ARE THE SOURCE OF
CONTRABAND IN -- FACILITIES BUT
SINCE THAT IS ALWAYS A
POSSIBILITY WITHOUT THAT ABILITY
I THINK IT'S IT'S DIFFERENT.
THEN SOME OF OUR OTHER
CATEGORIES OF OFFICERS WHO ARE
UNDER PROBAR I THINK
ADDITIONALLY.
THE PROHIBITION OF THE USE OF A
POLYGRAPH OR LIE DETECTOR AND
THE RULES AROUND INTERROGATION.
THAT [inaudible]
WHILE.
MARCUS THIRTY OFFICERS ARE
ENGAGED IN A TEN CARE CATION
THAT MUCH THE FEW TIMES THEY ARE.
IN OTHER WORDS IT'S JUST THERE A
DIFFERENT CATEGORY.
OF THEIR THEIR ROLES ARE
DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF OUR OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
SO IF I HAD THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
ALLOWING ANY CUSTODIAL OFFICERS
IN PROBAR AS CURRENTLY
CONSTRUCTED I PROBABLY WOULDN'T
BE COMFORTABLE.
SO. FOR TODAY EVEN THOUGH I AND
I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THIS
AS I INDICATED AND I APPRECIATE
THAT IT'S NOT.
FAIR IN FACT TO HAVE.
OFFICERS.
AND DO THE SAME JOB IN EFFECT TO
BE UNDER IT AND THEN OTHER
OFFICERS NOT -- I AM I AM GOING
TO STAY OFF THE BILL TODAY.
SO -- I WANTED TO EXPLAIN WHERE
AND AND I WAS ON GRAPPLING WITH
IT LATE LAST NIGHT AGAIN THIS
MORNING -- BUT THAT'S WHAT I
PERSONALLY HAVE CONCLUDED.
ON ANYWAY SO I'M NOT I WILL NOT
BE SUPPORTING BUT I WILL BE
VOTING NO.
SO LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BEFORE ASK THE AUTHOR TO CLOSE.
OKAY CENTER YES GIVEN THAT
EVERYONE'S COMMENTING ON THIS
WHY THEY'RE VOTING I FEEL
COMPELLED TO SHARE I AM GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS -- THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT POLL BAR I THINK
MAYBE WE NEED TO REVISIT IT BUT
I CANNOT SEE WHY WE WOULD.
REQUIRE.
MOST PEOPLE TO BE UNDER IT AND
NOT OTHERS SO FOR THE PURPOSES
OF UNIFORMITY.
ON THE OTHER HAND I THINK WE
COULD TAKE A SECOND LOOK AT PO
BAR FOR SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN ARTICULATED BUT
THE BILL AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
IS JUST SIMPLY INCLUDING THIS
GROUP UNDER THOSE SAME RULES AND
REGULATIONS SO WITH THAT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL ALTHOUGH
I DO HOPE THAT WE WILL REVISIT.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPRESSED ABOUT THE
SUBSTANCE OF A BAR.
A CENTER MITCHELL.
I HAVE A QUESTION BECAUSE I I DO
HAVE MAJOR CONCERNS ABOUT POOL
BAR AND AND AND DO YOU THINK IT
COMPLICATES OUR ABILITY TO EVER
OPEN IT UP AND REYES SOME OF THE
ISSUES YOU.
YOU RAISED IF WE CONTINUE TO ADD
CLASSES OF PEOPLE TO IT
[inaudible]
I'M. FOR ME IT WAS A INTERNAL
CONSISTENCY SO THAT'S WHY I
CONCLUDED THAT BUT CERTAINLY THE
DIFFICULTY OF OPENING FOUR BAR
UP REMAINS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE NONE OF
PEOPLE YES WILL PULL THAT ALL
RIGHT OKAY.
I MEAN SENATOR JACKSON WAS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND I COULD
HAVE SAID WHAT SHE JUST STATED
JUST AS EASILY.
SO I WANT I WANT THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS AND THE
OFFICERS IN AFFECTED TO KNOW
THAT FROM MY POINT OF VIEW I A
YOU KNOW THIS IS A AT HOME I
FEEL VERY CONFLICTED ABOUT IT --
BUT JUST FOR MY OWN.
BILL ANY FOR INTERNAL
CONSISTENCY I WON'T BE BUT I
CERTAINLY I COULD HAVE MADE.
THE SAME ARGUMENT THAT CENTER
JACKSON AND OTHERS MADE SO JUST
WANTED TO BUT CENTER MITCHELL GO
AHEAD.
I WAS MY QUESTION THAT YEAH THAT
SINCE WE ALL AGREE THAT POLL BUT
NOT ALL SOME OF US AGREE THAT
WHOLE BAR IS IN NEED OF A REVIEW.
I JUST WONDER IF WE WILL EVER
GET TO THAT POSITION IF.
CATEGORIES OF PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
BE ADDED TO IT IF IF THAT WILL
MAKE THAT CONVERSATION ALL THE
MORE COMPLICATED I GUESS THAT
WITH ONLY.
LIKE I SAID WE WILL HAVE YET
ANOTHER GROUP OF PEOPLE
POTENTIALLY OPPOSE ANY CHANGES.
TO THE NEW PROTECTIONS THAT THEY
WILL HAVE GAINED IF THIS BILL
WERE TO BECOME LAW THAT WAS I
WOULD.
ALL RIGHT CENTER ARTILLERY LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU AND IF YOU'RE
IN THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING BUT FAIR AND SHE
QUALITY AND I THINK WHEN THIS
THIS THING STARTED.
NOBODY ACTUALLY REALIZED EQUAL
WORK EQUAL PAY EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
THIS IS ONE THAT WE CAN CORRECT
TODAY BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
WHAT IF WE WERE TALKING.
ABOUT WOMEN DOING A CERTAIN
THING OR MEN DOING A CERTAIN
THING BUT AS I'VE EXPRESSED IN
AND IN THE PAST IN THE MILITARY
IT'S LEVELED OFF IN THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE FOR US TO DO THESAME
THING.
WE GOT A LEVEL OFF THE PLAYING
FIELD IN EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE
THE EQUAL RIGHTS EQUAL SAY AND
EQUAL PROTECTION.
AND THAT'S THE IDEA AND THIS IS
WHY THIS IS COME FORWARD NOW AS
I MENTIONED THERE THERE'S NO
REASON WHY ONE SHOULD A
SUPERVISOR.
SHOULD TREAT SOMEONE DIFFERENTLY
THAN SOMEONE ELSE.
WHEN IF WE'RE ALL UNDER THE SAME
UMBRELLA IN THE RULE OF LAW?
THEN EVERYONE CAN GO RIGHT TO
THE RULE BOOK AND SAY THIS IS
WHAT WAS DONE RIGHT THIS IS WITH
DONE WRONG WE CAN ALL IT HERE TO
IT.
SO THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
WE CAN BALLOTS TO SCALE IN OTHER
THINGS TO DO IN THE FUTURE
PROBABLY SO.
IS YOUR THINGS TO DO TO DO -- I
WOULD IMAGINE AT BUT I THINK
THIS IS THE DOOR OPENER THAT
WILL BRING US BACK TOGETHER SO
WE CAN UNDERSTAND THAT WE'VE GOT
TO TREAT EVERYONE FAIRLY AND
EQUITABLY.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE DOING
THE SAME JOB AT THE SAME PAY AND
THE SAME LOCATION.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLOSE LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL.
BOXING ANY MORE COMMENTS WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER
[inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I AM AROUND.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER HIGH.
SO W WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
THERE ARE.
ENOUGH VOTES FOR PASSAGE BUT WE
HAVE SOME MISSING MEMBER SO WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
AND THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND CENTER TO LET
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL.
SO YES I DO SEE THAT -- SB.
FIVE SEVENTEEN YES SIR -- THIS
IS A BILL THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS --
ENTERTAIN IN THE PAST.
DID.
SO -- HOPEFULLY KNOWING THAT WE
HAVE SUPPORTED IN THE PAST WOULD
ALLOW US TO MOVE.
DISHES LEE ON THIS ONE SO THAT --
WE CAN PROCEED WITH OUR OTHER
BILLS AND STILL CONCLUDE BY
CAUCUS TIME [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND A COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THIS
BILL SENATE BILL -- FIVE
SEVENTEEN HITS HOME WITH ME A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER FOR MAYOR OF
A CITY I WAS ABLE TO OBSERVE.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO THIS
PARTICULAR JOB AND I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
SAFETY -- TODAY I PRESENT SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTEEN THE BILL IS
VERY FILM BARELY FAMILIAR TO THE
COMMITTEE I'M SURE.
IN FACT LAST YEAR -- THE
IDENTICAL BILL WAS CARRIED BY
CENTER GALGIANI AND THAT PASSED.
OF THE COMMITTEE WITH NO NO VOTE.
THIS BILL FIVE SEVENTEEN WILL
EXPAND A LICENSE PLATE
CONFIDENTIALITY TO INCLUDE CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS PARKING
CONTROL OFFICERS AND PROVIDE THE
SAME PROTECTIONS THAT APPLIED TO
THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT COLLEAGUES.
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
PARKING CONTROL OFFICERS ENGAGE
IN WORK THAT EXPOSES THEM. TO
SITUATIONS THAT -- RETALIATION
IS IS NOT OUT OF THE QUESTION.
BECAUSE OF THE RESPONSE TO THAT
SOME PEOPLE -- PUT ON THE TABLE
IN AN EXPRESS -- THE CONCERN FOR
THEIR SAFETY IS IS ALWAYS
IMPORTANT.
AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE ALWAYS
CONCERNED AS THEY ARE AS WELL.
FOR EXAMPLE -- BOTH THESE GROUPS
IN JUROR THREATS ASSAULTS AND
SOME HAVE EVEN BEEN MURDERED IN
THE LINE OF DUTY.
AT PRESENT MANY CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND PARKING CONTROL
OFFICERS DO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES INFORMATION
SEALED FROM OPEN ACCESS BUT NOT
ALL.
THAT WAS IT I'M TRYING TO DO
LET'S BRING IT ACROSS THE BOARD
ALL.
SOME CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
IN PARKING CONTROL OFFICERS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THESE IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS.
THAT IN THAT EXPLOSION IS LIFE
THREATENING IN SOME CASES AND
CAN HAVE SOME DIRE CONSEQUENCES.
THIS BILL FIVE SEVENTEEN WILL
INCLUDE BOTH CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND THE PARKING CONTROL
OFFICERS UNDER THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THAT CURRENTLY APPLY
TO THEIR COLLEAGUES IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT THANK YOU THEY ARE GOT.
SORRY BEFORE I GO TO YOUR
WITNESS IS A JUST WANT TO REMIND --
THE WITNESSES AND COMMITTEE
THERE'S NO KNOWN OPPOSITION THE
COMMITTEE HAS SUPPORTED THIS
BILL IN THE PAST SALUTE --
JUDICIAL STATE BILL OKAY I AM
REALLY HAPPY WITH THAT IN THE
WINDOWS SYSTEM AND THAT JOSH
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS GREAT.
YOU CAN CERTAINLY SAY YOUR NAME
AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL IT'S
PERFECTLY LEGIT.
GOOD MORNING VERY CHAIRMAN CHIEF
OF CODE ENFORCEMENT FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK.
MY NAME IS CARL SIMPSON ON THE
CODE HOUSING FOR CITY FOR THE
CITY SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE HEAD CENTER I
AM MORE LIKE AT QUESTION FOR
VûI [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SECOND.
ONE ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND TAKE YOUR PREVIOUS COMMENT
OF ASKING US TO SUPPORTED IF
YOU'RE CLOSE TO THAT YES AND
I'LL MAKE A VERY SHORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE FAVORITE
VOTE THANK YOU -- THEN WE WILL
HAVE A ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MORE LOCKED.
OR LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE MORALE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
GREAT YOUR BILL WILL BE HELD
OPENED RIGHT NOW ROLL CALL JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE MISSING MEMBERS
BUT IT'S LOOKING FIND SEVERAL
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTING YOUR FIRST TWO BILLS
WE APPRECIATE IT AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE -- TO YOU'RE FINISHED YEAH --
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO SENATOR
JACKSON'S -- WILL KNOW WE COULD
MOVE TO SENATOR.
WINNERS I'M SORRY.
GO AHEAD SENATOR JACKSON'S
YOU'VE GOT ONE HE'S GOT TO SO
WE'LL GO TO SB FIFTY FIVE
SENATOR JACKSON AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO SENATOR WINNERS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
JUST AS GOOD [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY I DON'T KNOW.
THERE WERE MISTER WITHIN HOW
MUCH TIME.
THEN HOW MUCH TIME -- TO CENTER
JACKSON PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
MATT MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
BRING TO TODAY SB FIFTY FIVE
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL
PROHIBIT PEOPLE WHO ARE IKELY
TO ABUSE FIREARMS.
FROM POSSESSING THEM.
DRAWING ON RESEARCH THAT SHOWS A
STRONG CORRELATION BETWEEN
CERTAIN ALCOHOL AND DRUG RELATED
CONVICTIONS AND FUTURE GUN
VIOLENCE.
THIS MEASURE ADD SEVERAL CRIMES
TO THE LIST OF CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS THE RESULT IN A TEN
YEAR PROHIBITION ON FIREARMS
OWNERSHIP AGAIN THE GOAL HERE IS
JUST TO REMOVE FIREARMS FROM
PEOPLE.
FORM WHOM OF RESEARCH SHOWS A
CORRELATION BETWEEN.
VARIOUS TYPES OF CRIME AND THE
POTENTIAL OF IN FUTURE USE OF
FIREARMS IN THE COMMISSION OF
OTHER ACTS GOING FORWARD FIRST
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THIS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS.
THE AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
SO I WILL BE TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS I UNDERSTAND
CONCERNED ABOUT POTENTIALLY
TARGETED COMMUNITIES -- BY
REMOVING OF THOSE OFFENSES OF
ALCOHOL ABUSE.
I I BELIEVE THAT WE ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM AND A I I UNDERSTAND A
MOCK UP OF HAS BEEN DISTRIBUTED --
TO THE MEMBERS AND I APPRECIATE
THE GOOD WORK ON THAT ISSUE.
THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
AGAIN CONVICTIONS FOR PUBLIC
INTOXICATION.
OF FROM THE LIST OF
MISDEMEANOURS RESULTING IN A
FIRE ON PRO HERE -- PROHIBITION
AND CHANGE THE CRITERIA FOR
RECEIVING A DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE FIREARM PROHIBITION.
FROM TWO CONVICTIONS IN THREE
YEARS TWO THREE CONVICTIONS IN
TEN YEARS A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME BUT WITH THESE AMENDMENTS
BOTH THE ACLU AND THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
HAVE REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION.
AGAIN IT'S DOES NOT CREATE NEW
CRIMES.
IT JUST SIMPLY IDENTIFIES
THROUGH THE RESEARCH AND WE DO
HAVE A TESTIMONY HERE TODAY THAT
SHOWS THAT CORRELATION --
BETWEEN OF THESE KINDS OF
OFFENSES AND SUBSEQUENT USE OF
FIREARMS.
WE ARE AS WE KNOW CALIFORNIA GUN
LAWS.
FOCUS ON PEOPLE LIKELY TO ABUSE
FIREARMS AND THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ARGUABLY -- AGAIN PEOPLE
WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED A
PROPENSITY.
WE HAVE DISCOVERED THAT THESE
ARE INDEED VERY EFFECTIVE GUN
VIOLENCE REDUCTION TOOLS TO TAKE
FARMS AWAY FROM THESE FOLKS.
RATHER THAN FOR BID BOTH
RESPONSIBLE AND AND YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS FROM
POSSESSING FIRING.
TO THESE LAWS ONLY TARGET THOSE
WHO HAVE SHOWN BY THEIR PAST
BEHAVIOR.
THAT THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO
MISUSE FIREARMS GOING FORWARD
UNDER EXISTING LAW FELONS AND
PERPETRATORS OF CERTAIN VIOLENT
IN GUN RELATED MISDEMEANORS.
ARE PROHIBITED FROM POSSESSING
FIREARMS AND I KNOW THAT THE
CHAIR HAS ALSO WORKED VERY
CLOSELY ON RESTRAINING ORDERS
RELATED TO PEOPLE WITH THAT
PROPENSITY -- SOME PROHIBITIONS
ARE FOR A LIFETIME OTHERS FOR
FIVE OR TEN YEARS OR DURING THE
PERIOD WHILE A RESTRAINING ORDER
OR A MENTAL HEALTH RESTRICTION.
IS IN FORCE -- IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
ARE THEN COLLEAGUES SENATOR LOIS
WOKE I WAS ABLE TO GET
APPROPRIATED FUNDS FOR THE
CREATION OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
ARM.
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER AT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
RECENT RESEARCH FROM THE CENTER
HAS REVEALED AN IMPORTANT LINK
BETWEEN A CONVICTION FOR AN
ALCOHOL RELATED CRIME AND LATER
FIREARM ABUSE WE ARE TAKING
RESEARCH THAT IS FINALLY BEING
CONDUCTED. TO BE ABLE TO
PINPOINT THE GREATER LIKELIHOOD
OF FIREARM USE WE HEAR FROM
THOSE WHO OPPOSE FIREARM
REGULATION THAT YOU'RE.
TAKING FIREARMS AWAY FROM PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT GOING TO ARE LIKELY
TO BE USING THEM.
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT
IDENTIFIES WHO THE PEOPLE ARE
WHO ARE LIKELY TO USE THEM TO
TRY TO PROTECT AGAINST THAT KIND
OF MISUSE GOINGFORWARD.
THIS MEASURE TRANSLATES THESE
RESEARCH FINDINGS IN THE PUBLIC
POLICY IN AN EFFORT TO PREVENT
FUTURE GUN VIOLENCE SO THIS BILL
ADDS THESE RESEARCH CORRELATED
TO CONVICTIONS TO THE LIST OF
TEN THE TEN YEAR PROHIBITION.
THEY ARE POSSESSION WITH INTENT
TO SELL CERTAIN CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES.
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER WHILE
INTOXICATED AND DRIVING WHILE
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL
IT IS A TEN YEAR PROBATION AGAIN
IN RECOGNITION OF THE RESEARCH
THAT INDICATES THAT PEOPLE WHO
WERE PREVIOUSLY CONVICTED OF
CRIMES BUT HAVE NOT CAN BE A
COMMITTED ANY NEW CRIMES. FOR A
TEN YEAR PERIOD HAVE ABOUT THE
SAME LIKELIHOOD OF COMMITTING A
FIREARM OFFENSE AS THOSE WHO
HAVE NEVER PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED
ANY CRIMES.
RESEARCH PINPOINTED TRYING TO
ADDRESS A PROBLEM TO GET
FIREARMS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE IN ALL OUR COMMUNITIES
WHO WOULD BE LIKELY TO USE THEM.
AND THIS MEASURE IS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO A BILL
THAT SENATOR WOKE BROUGHT --
WHICH PASSED THROUGH BOTH HOUSES
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN -- TWENTY
THIRTEEN WITH SUPPORT OF SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
IRONICALLY THE BILL WAS VETOED
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR SAID AT
THAT TIME WE DON'T HAVE ANY
RESEARCH.
WE HAVE THE RESEARCH WE'RE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE THAT RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT THIS WILL HELP TO
SAVE LIVES AND DO SO IN A WAY
THAT IS DEMONSTRATED BY.
THE GOOD HARD WORK THAT HAS BEEN
DONE BY -- THE DIRECTOR OF THE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION RESEARCH
PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS DOCTOR GEREN
WENT WENT TO MUTE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE WITH US HERE
FROM THE ALAMEDA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE GREAT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY -- MAIL
SO WE'LL HAVE YOUR TO WITNESSES
THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED AS GIVE
US THEIR TESTIMONY AND THEN
OTHER WITNESSES WILL JUST SAY
NAME AND SUPPORT FOR IT.
PRETTY GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
A SENATOR JACKSON DID TALK ABOUT
THEIR RESEARCH WHICH GIVES US
GREAT GUIDANCE.
IN SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THAT THE BILL OULD AS A CENTER
JACKSON SAID WILL PROHIBIT
FIREARMS FOR HIGH RISK
INDIVIDUALS.
AND IT'S REALLY ACCEPTING THE
APPROACH TO PREVENT AN ACCEPTED
APPROACH TO COULD TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE AND AS WE ALL KNOW WE
HAVE TOO MUCH GUN VIOLENCE.
IN OUR STATE AND IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE BILL IS IS QUITE FOCUSED ON
THOSE WHO COMMIT GUN VIOLENCE
AND WHAT OUR EXPERIENCE AND I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT.
I HAVE DONE A LOT OF RESEARCH
RUN GUN VIOLENCE AND WE
PUBLISHED REPORT ON GUN VIOLENCE.
BOTH IN THE STATE IN AN ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
AND WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT THERE
ARE.
GENERALLY FOUR CATEGORIES OF
PEOPLE WHO ENGAGE IN MULTI AND
MASK ON VIOLENCE OUR GUN
VIOLENCE.
ARE ONE IS MENTAL ILLNESS ONE OF
THEM IS PEOPLE THAT FALL IN AN
EMOTIONAL STATE AND THAT
INCLUDES PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL ABUSE
ISSUES ARE DRUG ABUSE ISSUES.
OF THOSE WHO SEEK NOTORIETY LIKE
MASS KILLERS AND ALSO THOSE WHO
ARE WHO ARE USING FIREARMS OUT
OF REVENGE OR ANGER.
THIS BILL RECOGNIZES THOSE AT
HIGH RISK UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT COULD LEAVE THEM IN AN
ALTERED STATE EITHER BECAUSE OF
MENTAL ILLNESS DRUGS OR ALCOHOL
ABUSE.
AND BY VIRTUE OF THE MULTIPLE
CONVICTION REQUIREMENT THAT THIS
BILL IT INCLUDES THERE IS A
TRACK RECORD.
THAT -- THAT IS A MUST BE
ESTABLISHED FOR THOUGH CRIMES
BEING ADDED TO THE STATUTE.
THERE IN THE RESEARCH AS SENATOR
JACKSON SAID SUPPORTS THE ADDED
CRIMES A TO THIS BILL I WILL
ALSO SAY THAT NOT ONLY AM I HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE MY OFFICE AND A
AND THE WORK THAT WE DO AROUND
GUN VIOLENCE AND GUN PREVENTION.
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION BUT I'M
ALSO ON THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
OF THE PROSECUTORS AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE WHICH IS A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION.
OF PROSECUTORS ARE TWO CHAIRS
ARE CYRUS VANCE THE PROSECUTOR
MANHATTAN.
AND MIKE FEWER THE CITY ATTORNEY
FOR LOS ANGELES.
AND OTHER PROSECUTORS GUNS
VIOLENCE ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE BEAUTY A RALLY FOR COMING
CREATED.
AND I'M DOCTOR CARE AND WHEN TO
MUTE I AM DIRECTOR OF THE UC
SENATOR THAT YOU SEE CENTER THAT
SENATOR JACKSON.
REFERRED TO I'M A PRACTICING
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN -- SENATOR
JACKSON ASKED ME TO COME AND
TALK ABOUT THE SCIENCE THAT
YOU'VE.
REFERENCE TO WHEN A SIMILAR BILL
WAS ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN OF
GOVERNOR BROWN VETO AS YOU
MENTIONED -- FOCUSED ON THE FACT
THAT WE DID NOT HAVE GOOD
SCIENCE ON THE FUTURE RISK FOR
VIOLENCE AMONG LEGALLY
AUTHORIZED PURCHASERS OF
FIREARMS THAT'S NO LONGER TRUE
WE NOW HAVE THAT SCIENCE I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU ABOUT IT. TWO
YEARS AGO WE PUBLISHED A STUDY
OF LEGALLY AUTHORIZED PURCHASERS
OF HAND GUNS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
A PAST BACKGROUND CHECK WE WENT
ALL THROUGH ALL THE HOOPS.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS STUDY WAS TO
COMPARE PEOPLE WHO HAD PRIOR
CONVICTIONS FOR DIY AND OTHER
ALCOHOL RELATED OFFENSES.
WITH PURCHASERS WHO HAD NO
CRIMINAL HISTORY AND THIS IS
WHAT WE FOUND.
AMONG THOSE WITH A DO YOU AYE
HISTORY NEARLY A THIRD 33% WERE
ARRESTED AFTER PURCHASING THEIR
FIREARMS FOR A FIREARM RELATED
OR VIOLENT CRIME. ONE IN SIX WAS
ARRESTED FOR MURDER RAPE ROBBERY
OR AGGRAVATED ASSAULT.
EVEN AFTER STATISTICALLY
ADJUSTING FOR DIFFERENCES IN
POPULATIONS THEY WERE SIX TIMES
AS LIKELY AS PURCHASERS WITH NO
PRIOR CRIMINAL HISTORY TO BE
ARRESTED FOR THOSE OFFENSES.
AND WE HAVE JUST LITERALLY THIS
WEEK I'M HAPPY TO FINALLY TELL
YOU JEFF -- COMPLETED A MUCH
LARGER STUDY OF AN ENTIRE YEAR'S
WORTH OF HANDGUN PURCHASERS IN
CALIFORNIA NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
A WITH FOLLOW UP FOR ALMOST
FIFTEEN YEARS AFTER THEIR
PURCHASES THE STUDY WILL BE
GOING INTO THE NEW ENGLAND
JOURNAL OF MEDICINE NEXT WEEK.
IT HAS NOT GONE THROUGH PEER
REVIEW YET SO I'M REALLY NOT AT
LIBERTY TO GIVE THE DETAILS BUT
I CAN TELL YOU IT FULLY SUPPORTS
THE FINDINGS THAT I'VE JUST.
MENTIONED FROM.
OUR PUBLISHED RESEARCH WHAT'S
MORE IS SENATOR JACKSON
MENTIONED WE ALSO KNOW THAT
SCREENING AND DENIAL OF FIREARMS
PURCHASE.
WORKS RESEARCH THAT WE DID THAT
WAS SUPPORTED BY THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE ON FIREARMS
PURCHASERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
DETERMINED WHEN WHEN WE CHANGED
OUR POLICY AND BEGAN PROHIBITING
VIOLENT MISDEMEANORS FOR
PURCHASING FIREARMS.
THAT POLICY CHANGE THAT NEW
PROHIBITION REDUCED THEIR RISK
OF ARREST FOR A VIOLENT CRIME BY
30% WHICH IS A VERY SUBSTANTIAL
AFFECT PORTED MINISTRY OF WE
APPLIED.
POLICY.
FINALLY AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED
THIS IS A VERY NARROWLY FOCUSED
BILL.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TALKS
ABOUT THE FACT THAT SOMETHING
LIKE THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE EACH YEAR RECEIVE A
SECOND DO YOU AYE CONVICTION.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT ONLY A MINORITY OF THOSE
CONVICTIONS OCCUR IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY IN TIME TO THE FIRST
AND THE TO HAVE TO BE CLOSE
TOGETHER OR NOW THREE FOR THEM
TO BE PROHIBITING.
NUMBERTOO MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE ALREADY PROHIBITED FOR OTHER
REASONS MISDEMEANOR VIOLENCE AND
SO FORTH AND FINALLY ONLY ABOUT
ONE ADULT IN SIX IN CALIFORNIA
ON TO FIRE.
SO WHEN YOU ADD THOSE THINGS IN
IT TURNS OUT THAT THE ESTIMATE
OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT BE ADDED TWO APPS BY THIS.
IS ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED A YEAR.
WE ACTUALLY DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
ESTIMATE THAT LARGE STUDY THAT I
JUST MENTIONED OF AN ENTIRE
YEAR'S WORTH OF HANDGUN
PURCHASERS WE'VE LOOKED AT THE
DATA.
OF NEARLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THAT STUDY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HAVE A DO YOU AYE
CONVICTION ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
HAVE TWO OR MORE.
THIS IS A VERY TIGHTLY FOCUSED
BUILT ON A VERY HIGH RISK GROUP.
I'LL MAKE ONE LAST POINT JUST
VERY BRIEFLY OF THERE IS CONCERN
THAT WE SHARE ABOUT DIFFERENTIAL
APPLICATION OF THE LAW ACROSS
GROUPS DEFINED BY RACE AND
ETHNICITY WE HAVE LOOKED
SPECIFICALLY.
AT IN THAT LARGE STUDY AT RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH THE Y. ACROSS
SUBGROUPS BY RACE AND ETHNICITY
AND WE FIND IT IN EVERY CASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL STOP
THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO NOW WE'LL
SEE IF THERE'S OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT WHO WANT TO GIVE
THEIR A NAME AN AFFILIATION AND
THEIR SUPPORT.
DONNA SITES ARE VISITING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
HELLO SUSAN LEVIN BURKE HERE ON
BEHALF OF AMANDA WILCOX -- WHO
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
SHE'S TESTIFYING IN WASHINGTON?
CALIFORNIA RADIUS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL CANDLE KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE DIFFERENCE LAW CENTER TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE AND SUPPORT.
MANY BED REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO
VALLEY BRADY IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR AND HER
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE ALSO REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SO SEEING NONE LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER MITCHELL.
THANKS THANK YOU FOR SHARING THE
RESEARCH -- AND I MAY HAVE
MISSED YOUR LASSEN REGARD TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BECAUSE THE
ONE CONCERN I HAVE WITH THAT
THAT WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN.
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE OVER POLICE
THAT HAVE EXTRA -- D. Y. STOPS --
AND ALL OF THAT AND SO THE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF CERTAIN UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR POOR
COMMUNITIES.
OF OF THE STOP ARE HIGHER THAN
THE OTHER GEOGRAPHIC AREA THAT'S
THE REALITY.
THE OTHER QUESTION IS IF YOU
COULD JUST.
TELL ME WHAT YOU WHAT THE
RESEARCH REVIEW IF YOU CAN APART
ON THAT MY SECOND QUESTION IS.
IN THE MEMBERS POSSESSION FOR
SALE OF SPECIFIED NARCOTICS WE
CERTAINLY HAVE.
I HAVE LEARNED IN GOING THROUGH --
PENAL CODE IN LOOKING AT A
VARIETY OF OF OF POLICIES THAT
YOU KNOW THE THE THE QUANTITY.
THAT THE POSSESSION FOR SALE IS
OFFERED IN THE EYES OF A COULD
BE DETERMINED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY HAVE THE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE IF THEY THINK IT'S AN
AMOUNT THAT'S FOR MY PERSONAL
CONSUMPTION OR FOR SALE SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE.
THA THAT THAT'S TIGHT.
AND THAT WE DON'T -- CONTINUE TO
LEAVE THAT UP TO THE DISCRETION
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR BOTH THOSE
QUESTIONS -- WE SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT DIFFERENTIAL
ARREST RATES AND SO FORTH AND
HAVE ALMOST COMPLETED A SEPARATE
ANALYSIS OF THE DATA I'VE BEEN
REFERRING TO SPECIFICALLY TO
LOOK AT THAT AND WE FIND.
DIFFERENTIAL APPLICATION OF DO
YOU AYE STATUTES IN CALIFORNIA --
WHICH IF YOU WILL CREATE A BIAS
IN THE DATA AS THEY COME TO US.
WE CAN'T TAKE CARE OF THAT BIAS
SO WHAT WE DECIDED TO DO WAS
WITH THE DATA IN FRONT OF US.
DOES IT REMAIN THE CASE THAT FOR
WHITE NON HISPANICS FOUR
HISPANICS FOR NON HISPANIC
AFRICAN AMERICANS WITHIN THE
DATA.
IS IT THE CASE THAT HAVING A
PRIOR DUI CONVICTION IS
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INCREASED
RISK FOR VIOLENCE IN THE FUTURE.
IF THE ARRESTS WERE IF IF YOU
WILL COMPLETELY BOGUS WE
PROBABLY WOULDN'T SEE THE
INCREASE IN RISK.
WE DO SEE THE INCREASE IN RISK
FOR AFRICAN AERICANS IS ABOUT A
FACTOR OF TWO POINT FIVE STILL A
TWO HUNDRED AND 50%.
INCREASE IN RISK ASSOCIATED WITH
THE D. Y. CONVICTION IN AN
ANALYSIS JUST AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
SIMILAR RESULTS -- FOR ANALYSES
AMONG HISPANICS AND SO FORTH AND
WE WILL BE PUBLISHING THAT
INFORMATION AS WELL -- YOU I'M
YOU'RE WELCOME WITH REGARD TO
NARCOTICS.
A BROADER POINT IS IT MANY MANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ARE
AWARE.
THERE ARE MANY CRITICAL
QUESTIONS FOR WHICH WE DON'T
HAVE ANSWERS BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN AN ORGANIZED EFFORT TO KEEP
THE WORK FROM BEING DONE.
RIGHT BEHIND THIS ALCOHOL STUDY
IT USING THE SAME DATA WE'LL BE
LOOKING WITHIN CALIFORNIA AT
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH DRUG
CONVICTIONS WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT
WORK YET.
BUT THE LITERATURE -- WILL
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING GENERAL
STATEMENTS.
THERE IS A VERY CLEAR
ASSOCIATION BETWEEN STIMULANT
USE AMPHETAMINES COCAINE ET
CETERA AN INCREASED RISK IN
EVERY POPULATION WHICH IT'S EVER
BEEN LOOKED AT FOR OPIOIDS THE
ANSWER IS MIXED FOR MARIJUANA
THE ANSWER IS MIXED THERE ARE
STUDY SHOWING.
A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN RISK
FOR VIOLENCE ASSOCIATED WITH
MARIJUANA USE NOT TODAY'S TOPIC.
I DON'T HAVE INFORMATION FOR YOU
ON THE SPECIFIC OFFENSES IN THE
BILL.
I HOPE TO WHEN WE GET THAT STUDY
DONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CENTER MORE LEFT THANK YOU
MANAGER -- DOCTOR WENT TO MAKE
SURE YOU'RE GETTING YOUR ANSWERS
ARE GETTING CLOSER TO WHERE I
WANT TO GO.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
MENTALLY ILL MOVIES REALLY DON'T
WANT TO SEE.
HAVING GUNS AND ERROR.
BUT THEY BUT THEY SELF MEDICATE.
SO THROUGHOUT THE HALL THROUGH
MARIJUANA THROUGH.
ALL THE OTHER.
STATE YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT WAS
THERE A CORRELATION AT ALL COULD
YOU SEE IN THE DATA THAT.
MAYBE THAT EVEN IF THEY HAD A DO
YOU WHY THEY WERE ALSO
[inaudible]
MENTALLY ILL.
NO BECAUSE THAT INFORMATION IS
NOT IN THE DATA -- WE ARE
LOOKING AT RECORDS FOR GUN
PURCHASING AN CRIMINAL RECORDS
SO WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH DATA WE ARE WE
WERE ALSO DOING AN EVALUATION OF
THE APPS PROGRAM WITH SUPPORT
FROM.
DOJ AND FUNDING FROM AND I J.
THERE WE WILL HAVE A LOOK AT A
LARGER COMMENT AND IT'S ACTUALLY
I I'M GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SIDE OF THIS.
ONE OF THE I'M IN A SOME RICE
RESEARCH BRIEFLY HERE.
MENTAL ILLNESS EVEN SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS BY ITSELF.
IS ASSOCIATED WITH A RISK FOR
FUTURE VIOLENCE THAT'S SMALL
ENOUGH.
THAT NOT EVERY CAREFULLY DONE
STUDY HAS EVEN FOUND IT TO BE
THERE.
WHAT HAPPENS IN AS IT DOES IN
THE GENERAL POPULATION IS BAD
MENTAL ILLNESS? TO A PRIOR
HISTORY OF VIOLENCE TO SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND THEN THE RISK IN THE
FUTURE GETS VERY HIGH BUT
VIOLENCE AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE ARE
RISK FACTORS. FOR FUTURE
VIOLENCE IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION SO ONE WAY AND I
TEACH MY STUDENTS ABOUT THIS ONE
WAY TO GET AT THE MENTAL ILLNESS
PROBLEM IS TO GO AFTER SUBSTANCE
ABUSE WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY.
I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY THE LINKS
HAVE TEN YEARS WAS SELECTED.
THE DISSECT CLARIFICATION THERE
ARE. TWO COMPONENTS THERE'S A
THREE YEAR IN A TEN YEAR.
SO THE THREE YEAR.
SO THE IT OUT IN THE AMENDED
BILL OKAY SO THE WE NEED IN THE
AMENDED BILL. ONE WOULD HAVE TO
BE HAVE TWO OR MORE CONVICTION.
OF POSSESSION OF THOSE SPECIFIED
NARCOTICS FOR SALE.
SO YOU'D HAVE TO HAVE TWO OR
MORE CONVICTIONS OF THAT WERE TO
MORE CONVICTIONS OF THE GROSS
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER WHILE
INTOXICATED.
IN A THREE YEAR PERIOD.
THE TEN YEAR PERIOD IS THREE OR
MORE DO YOU ICE.
SO MAYBE I'M NOT ASKING THE
QUESTION CORRECTLY MADAM CHAIR --
WOULD WORK WERE SAYING YOU
CANNOT APPLY FOR A OR PURCHASE A
HANDGUN FOR TEN YEARS.
A TEN YEARS THAT SIX EIGHT AND
IT IS WE'RE JUST MODELING AFTER
EXISTING LIE I JUST WONDERED IF
THERE IS A HISTORY OF WHITE TO
ADD SELECT YES THAT WAS THE
REASON THAT WE LOOKED AT THE TEN
YEAR I THINK ALSO THE RESEARCH
INDICATED.
THAT IF A PERSON IS --
CONVICTION FREE FOR A PERIOD OF
TEN YEARS IT USUALLY IS AN
INDICATION THEY'VE KIND OF
GOTTEN THEIR LIFE BACK TOGETHER
AGAIN SO WE AGAIN THE GOAL IS TO
DEAL WITH THAT HIGH RISK ELEMENT
VERY FOCUSED PINPOINTED.
AND ALSO TO GET THE GUNS OUT OF
THEIR HANDS AND NODDED AND
ADDITIONAL CRIMINAL OFFENSE FOR
WHICH THEY'RE GOING TO BE
PUNISHED WHICH JUST KNOWING THAT
THERE IS SAID GREATER PROPENSITY
FOR THE USE OF FIREARMS.
WHICH IS REMOVING ACCESS TO THEM
FOR THAT FOR THAT TEN YEAR
PERIOD OF TIME.
IN CENTER JACKSON'S YOUR BILL
UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA OR HAS IT
BEEN TRIED YOU'RE DONE SOMEWHERE
ELSE I BELIEVE THIS IS UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
ONE OF THE FEW PLACES WHERE WE
ACTUALLY ARE DOING.
RESEARCH ON GUN VIOLENCE WHICH
ISN'T INTO AN ART AN IRONY OF
COURSE I KNOW THAT I BELIEVE THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL HAS
STUFF MINIMAL -- BUT THERE'S
BEEN -- UP.
SADLY A OF A PUSH AGAINST
KNOWLEDGE FUNNY AREA OF THIS
KIND OF PROPENSITY FOR VIOLENT
FIREARMS RELATED BEHAVIOR AND IT
WASN'T UNTIL I BELIEVE IT WAS
TWENTY FOURTEEN OR TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHEN.
SENATOR WILK WAS ABLE TO GET
THIS BILL PASSED AND FUNDED SO
THAT THE RESEARCH COULD BE DONE
AND THE UC DAVIS WAS A
DESIGNATED FACILITY THAT WE ARE.
NOW ACTUALLY ABLE TO DO THAT-RESEARCH I KNOW OTHERS HAVE
TRIED AND BEEN SOMEWHAT
SUCCESSFUL BUT THIS IS TRULY THE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH.
THAT DEMONSTRATES THE KINDS OF
BEHAVIOR FOR A LOT OF US IT'S
BEEN INTUITIVE -- BUT THIS IS
ACTUAL -- FACT BATES SCIENCE
THAT HAS BEEN PEER REVIEWED AND
ALL OF THOSE IMPORTANT MEASURES
HAVE BEEN UNDERTAKEN TO ASSURE
THE ACCURACY OF THE DATA.
THANK YOU CAN THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON THANK YOU.
GREAT SO DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE BILL.
RIGHT ON THE THIRTY JACKSON AREA
OF YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU FOR
THE VERY BRIEFLY THIS IS FOR
TARGETED THIS IS TO GET FIRE
ARMS OUT OF THE HANDS OF PEOPLE
WE KNOW ARE MORE LIKELY TO USE
THEM.
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE -- I
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN I THINK IT -- HELPS
US ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
MEMBERS WHO SPOKE AND I HAD THE
COMMITTEE HAD SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THOSE WERE TAKEN.
AND I FEEL LIKE IT IS THE AS
CONCURRENTLY CONSTRUCTED IS
BASED ON THE RESEARCH THAT WE
HAVE SO WITH THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT WILL DO A ROLL
CALL.
I FIFTY PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MORE LOCK.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORRELL.
BROWNELL WIENER WIENER AYE.
RIGHT I DON'T THINK I HAVE TO
HOLD THE BILL NOW RIGHT OKAY SO
WE HAVE EVERYBODY HERE BILL
PASSES THANK YOU -- WILL NOW GO
TO CENTER WIENER SPILLS AND I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN CONCLUDE
WITHOUT HAVING.
TO RECONVENE AFTER CAUCUS AND I
SENATOR WIENER I DON'T WANT TO
NOT DO JUSTICE FOR YOUR BILLS
BUT I HOPE THAT WE CAN PROCEED.
AND I GO TO WITHOUT HAVING TO
RECONVENE THE COMMITTEE HAS
HEARD THEM BEFORE SO I WILL BE.
VERY GOOD POINT YES YOUR BILL --
SB TWENTY THREE WE HAVE HEARD
BEFORE YES ON THE OTHER ONE AS
WELL.
RIGHT KEEP IT ON AUTHOR -- WITH
IT.
YOU COULD IF YOU WANT IT.
RIGHT GO AHEAD YOU HAVE A MOTION
ON THE BILL.
OKAY -- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
COLLEAGUES SB TWENTY THREE WAS
PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR.
ODDS CO AUTHORED BY NINE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATORS ACROSS --
THE OFF ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE IN OUR AUTO BURGLARY --
STATUTE WHICH ARE CURRENTLY OF
THESE AS INTERPRETED BY A NUMBER
OF COURTS ARE REQUIRES SAID TO
APPROVE AUTO BURGLARY -- IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO PROVE THAT SOMEONE
BASHED IN A WINDOW YOU HAVE TO
PROVE THAT THE DOOR TO THE CAR
WAS LOCKED WHICH IS OFTEN
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO PARTICULARLY --
IF A TOURISTS WAS INVOLVED THE
RENTAL CAR WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM WITH RENTAL CAR BREAK
INS THAT TAURUSES GONE.
OUR SOMEONE SIMPLY DOESN'T
REMEMBER A AND SO FORTH SO --
THE BILL WILL -- ALLOW A
CONVICTION -- BASED ON FORCIBLE
ENTRY I DO WANT TO KNOW AND WE
MADE THE CHANGE LAST YEAR WE'VE
CP THAT.
THE WAY WE ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED
THE BILL AND THE REASON THIS IS
A SEPARATE NEW CRIME WE
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED IT IS
SIMPLY A MODIFICATION TO THE
EXISTING.
CRIME ABOUT DOT WOULD HAVE HAD
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
POTENTIALLY OF EXPANDING FELONY
MURDER AND SO WE CREATED A NEW
CRIME NOT BECAUSE HE WANTED TO
CREATE A NEW CRIME WE WANTED TO
CHANGE EXISTING.
ONE WE CREATE A NEW CRIME IN
ORDER TO AVOID EXPANSION OF
FELONY.
MURDER -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY IS
MAX ALTHOUGH FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
AND BOARD NEW AND PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF CAL TRAVEL WHO WILL
PROVIDE BRIEF TESTIMONY.
HI MAX ABA FROM THE DA'S OFFICE
IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH ONE BIG
CENTER WIENER FURS I CONTINUED
SUPPORT LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AS YOU MENTIONED THE SASS SIMPLY
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE WHILE IT DEFIES
LOGIC THE FACT THAT A VICTIMS
WINDOW -- WAS BROKEN DOES NOT BY
ITSELF ESTABLISHED THAT THE
VEHICLE WAS LOCKED -- SO IN
ORDER TO PROVE THAT THE DOOR WAS
LOCKED IN THAT AND THE FENDER --
BROKE THE WINDOW IN ORDER TO
GAIN ENTRY WE OFTEN ASK VICTIMS
TO COME BACK TO COURT TO TESTIFY.
THIS PROVES EXCEEDINGLY
DIFFICULT WHEN THE VICTIM IS A
VISITOR AND THAT HAPPENS VERY
OFTEN.
BETWEEN PASSPORTS AND CAMERAS --
VISITING VICTIMS ARE OFTEN ARE
ACTUALLY THE MAJORITY OF VICTIMS --
IN CAR BREAK INS ESPECIALLY IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I GETTING THEM TO COME BACK
WHEN THEY'VE LEFT OUR SUBPOENA
POWER.
BECOMES AN INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT AND THE AS A RESULT WE
HAVE TO PROVE THAT AND THE DOOR
WAS LOCKED THROUGH
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE INSTEAD
OF DIRECT EVIDENCE AND IT'S A
IT'S A IT'S THE DANCE THAT IS.
VERY -- UNNECESSARY CONSIDERING
HOW -- OBVIOUS IT IS THAT THE
DOOR WAS THAT THE WINDOW WAS
BROKEN IN ORDER TO GAIN ENTRY TO
A LOCKED VEHICLE.
SO -- SB TWENTY THREE CLOSES
THIS LOGIC DEFYING LOOPHOLE AND
WE HOPE THAT.
YOU WILL OF THE WOODEN SUPPORTS --
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR OUR LAWS
THAT REFLECT PROJECT.
THANK YOU NEXT TO IT.
HI AMBER NEWTON AT PRESIDENCY OF
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAL TRAVEL
HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER FOR YOUR
HELP ON THIS BILL AND ALSO FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE INDUSTRY IN
GENERAL.
CAR BREAK INS ARE A REALLY
TROUBLING SITUATION FOR OUR
TOURISM INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY IN
THE BAY AREA BUT REALLY ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND AS MENTIONED RENTAL CARS ARE
OFTEN PARTICULAR TARGET THAT
AFFECTS OUR TOURISM INDUSTRY
NEGATIVELY -- COVERAGE THAT WE
GET IN STATE LOCAL NATIONAL
MEDIA AND ON PEOPLE SOCIAL MEDIA
AMPLIFY THAT NEGATIVE EXPERIENCE
AND THAT BREAKING CAUSES.
IN THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL AND
TOURISM INDUSTRY WE TAKE GREAT
PRIDE IN CREATING WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCES FOR VISITORS AND
ALSO FOR OUR RESIDENTS.
WE BRING IN A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF DIRECT
REVENUE EVERY YEAR AND ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE THAN ONE
MILLION JOBS AND ELEVEN BILLION.
DOLLARS IN STATE AND LOCAL TAXES
SO IT IS A SIGNIFICANT INDUSTRY
THAT THIS IS HURTING.
WHEN SOMEONE HAS A NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCE LIKE A CAR BREAK IN?
IT DOES ONLY RUIN THEIR TRIP BUT
IT CREATES A NEGATIVE
ASSOCIATION WITH THE CITY AND
THE STATE OF THAT LINGERS.
SO.
RIGHT NOW CURRENT LAWS YOU HERDS --
STATES THAT PROSECUTORS HAVE TO
PROVE A CAR DOOR WAS LOCKED AS
PART OF A BREAK IN.
BUT WHEN INTEREST HAS THEIR
RENTAL CAR BROKEN THEY'RE
UNLIKELY TO RETURN TO TESTIFY
FOR THAT TRIAL SO IT'S A KEY
PIECE OF EVIDENCE THAT IS
MISSING.
SB TWENTY THREE WOULD HELP
REMEDY THE SITUATION BY
INCLUDING FORCED ENTRY IS AN
ELEMENT OF THE VEHICLE BREAKING
STATUTES.
AND IN OUR EYES THAT'S REALLY A
WIN WIN WIN IT'S A IT'S A WIN
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
RESIDENTS AND FOR VISITORS.
YOU'LL HELP ME QUIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE TOOLS THAT
THEY NEED TO COMBAT CAR
BURGLARIES AND HELP ENSURE THAT.
VISITORS AND RESIDENTS HAVE A
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO ONCE AGAIN WHEN I THINK THE
SENATOR AND LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP AND WORK ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK THANK YOU
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS HO SHALL MUCH CHILDREN
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
AND BRENDAN UP ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION COME TO THE TABLE AND
I WANT IT JUST AS A REMINDER AND
CENTER WIENER REFERENCES BUT
THIS BILL.
WHEN IT WAS BROUGHT TO US LAST
YEAR WE AMENDED IT SIGNIFICANTLY
AND SO THE BILL NOW IS EXACTLY
AS WE PASSED IT LAST YEAR WHICH
HAD THE AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVED --
ACLU'S OPPOSITION -- BUT WE WILL
HEAR FROM OUR GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS LESLIE CALDWELL IN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW WE HAVE ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS LAWYERS
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC -- AND
INVESTIGATORS AROUND THE STATE --
I PERSONALLY RECENTLY RETIRED AS
THE SOLANO COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER FOR NINE YEARS AND
BEFORE THAT.
I PRACTICED ANOTHER THIRTY YEARS
AN INDIGENT DEFENSE -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS UNNECESSARILY
CREATE A NEW OFFENSE WE DO NOT
BELIEVE.
AS IS STATED IN THE NEED FOR THE
BILL ACCORDING TO THE AUTHOR AND
ALL DUE RESPECT -- IT IS NOT A
STRIKE -- IT IS NOT AN
INHERENTLY DANGEROUS -- FELONY
AND THE FELONY MURDER RULE HAS
BEEN CHANGED CONSIDERABLY SO
THOSE CONCERNS I DON'T BELIEVE
ARE VALID CONCERNS -- THERE IS
AN INDICATION THAT IT'S A
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE -- FOR THE
DEATH PENALTY.
AND THE IN FACT IT IS BUT I'VE
ONLY FUND ONE INSTANCE IN A
LONG HISTORY OF IT BEING USED AS
A SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE -- I
LOOKED INTO THE LEGISLATIVE
PURPOSE OF ONE OF THE LOCKED
VEHICLE REQUIREMENT.
AND AT THAT TIME IT WAS PUT IN
THERE TO MAKE THE TRIP CRIME
MORE SERIOUS THAN SOMEBODY JUST
SIMPLY OPENING A DOOR AND TAKING
SOMETHING.
SO SIMPLE PETTY OR GRAND THEFT.
THAT'S WHY IT WAS PUT IN THERE --
YES THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH
GETTING THE WITNESSES BACK WHEN
THEY OUR TOURIST OR SOMEONE IN
ANOTHER COUNTY -- AND PUTTING IN
THIS.
CHANGE DOESN'T ADDRESS.
THE WHOLE PROBLEM BECAUSE IF YOU
NEED A WITNESS TO COME IN AND
SAY THE DOOR WAS LOCKED USE ALSO
STILL NEED THE WITNESS EITHER AT
A PRELIMINARY HEARING IN A
FELONY OR THE TRIAL IN A
MISDEMEANOR. TO SAY.
THE THE CAR WAS ENTERED WITHOUT.
THE DRIVER'S PERMISSION -- THE
CASE LAW IS PRETTY CLEAR THAT
MOST CASES SAY THAT A BROKEN
WINDOW IS ACCEPTABLE AS A SIGN
THAT THE DOORS WERE LOCKED -- SO
THAT EVIDENCE IS ACCEPTED THE
ONLY TIME IT'S A PROBLEM IS
BECAUSE IT'S AN ELEMENT OF THE
OFFENSE -- AND IT HAS TO BE
PROVED AT TRIAL NOW THE
PRELIMINARY HEARING YOU CAN JUST
HAVE THE OFFICER TESTIFY SO THE
ONLY TIME YOU NEED.
A WITNESS IS AT TRIAL.
WILL SAN FRANCISCO MAY HAVE
SLIGHTLY HIGHER NUMBERS BUT ONLY
123% OF ALL CASES IN THE
CRIMINAL DEFENSE UNIVERSE OR THE
CRIMINAL CHARGE UNIVERSE.
GO TO TRIAL SO THIS NEW CRIME.
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE WHOLE
PROBLEM OF NEEDING THE WITNESS --
SECONDLY THE ISSUE OF FORCIBLY
HAS TO BE CLEARLY DEFINED IN THE
LAW AND THE REASON I SAY THAT IS.
IN THE ROBBERY STATUTE THERE'S A
TAKING BY FORCE OR FEAR OVER THE
YEARS THE CASE LAW HAS HAS.
PRETTY MUCH EVISCERATED THE
MEANING OF FORCE SO IT HAS NO
MEANING ANYMORE IN THE ROBBERY
STATUTE.
AND SO IT WON'T HAVE A MEANING.
IN AN AUTO BURKE STATUTE AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AND
ASK FOR NAY VOTE.
ALRIGHT LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEN NINE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE SENATOR
MORLOCK THANK YOU MANAGER I'M
JUST CURIOUS -- ABOUT THE TRIAL
ASPECT IN BRINGING THE WITNESS
BACK ITS ENTERTAINER.
IS THAT BECAUSE OF THE STENCH
HAS CASE.
BECAUSE SOMEONE ELSE SAYING THAT
THE CAR WAS BROKEN INTO BECAUSE
IT WAS LOCKED WOULD BE WHAT HER
SAY IT'S HEARSAY.
THAT'S WHY I CAN'T THAT'S WHY
YOU FORCE INTEREST TO COME BACK
TO TRIAL.
THAT'S WHY THE CONSTITUTION AND
THE LAW REQUIRES THAT THE
TOURISTS COME BACK YES.
AND THEN I'M JUST CURIOUS FROM A
TOURISM.
DEPARTMENT WHO WERE PUTTING
MARKINGS ON RENTAL CARS IS A BIT
MUST BE DECALS OR SOMETHING THAT.
KIND OF INFORMS.
PEOPLE THAT THAT THAT THERE
COULD BE A SUITCASE IN THE TRUNK.
IT I'M JUST TRY TO INFORM TAURUS
TO NOT LEAVE ANYTHING IN THE CAR
THAT LOOKS LIKE IT MIGHT BE A
YOU KNOW FULL OR A TOURIST CAR
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE RENTAL CAR INDUSTRY TO
MINIMIZE THE EFFECT.
THE REALITY IS THAT -- YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE AT PIER THIRTY NINE IN
YOUR PARK THERE'S THERE'S A GOOD
CHANCE YOUR CAR'S GONNA GET.
BROKEN INTO AND IT'S NOT JUST
SOURCES SORCERESS EDINSON ANYONE
WHO HAS SOMETHING IN A CAR AND
SOMETIMES EVEN WHEN THEY DON'T.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
A CENTER BRADFORD ARE YA I AM I
AM IN THINKS SIR WE ARE FOR THIS
BILL BUT AS LARGE YEAR AYE I
REALLY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THIS
BECAUSE AYE AYE SHE BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE BEING ARRESTEDAND
CONVICTED OF AUTO THEFT.
ON A REGULAR OUR BREAK INS ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND IF YOU.
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO EVEN LOSE
YOUR LIFE FOR IT SO -- I DON'T
SEE A NEED TO ADD ANY ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS OR ADDITIONAL LAWS
RELATED.
TO AUTO THEFT I THINK THE LOCAL
LAWS CLEAR AS IT STATES ARE
READY AND I I I I THINK IT'S
GOING TO HAVE AN INHERENT --
FACT ANA.
BLACK BROWN COMMUNITIES SO THANK
CAN'T SUPPORT -- IT'S NOT SEEING
ANY OTHER -- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- CENTER WINNER WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
REGARDING I CENTER BRADFORD
SOLICITING THE NICE -- AS THE
CENTER KNOWS I'M --
OVERWHELMINGLY ALIGNED WITH HIM
ON THESE ISSUES AFFECT MY NEXT
BILL -- WILL BE -- TO ELIMINATE
EVER COMMONSENSE SAYING
ENHANCEMENT.
THIS DOES NOT ENHANCE A AND THE
SENTENCING OF THE BILL -- YOU
KNOW FRANKLY CLARIFIES WHAT I
THINK MOST PEOPLE ALWAYS ASSUMED.
THAT IF YOU BASH SHELL SOMEONE'S
WINDOW TO GET INTO THE CAR
YOU'RE GUILTY OF BURGLARIZING
THE CAR I THINK IT'S COMMONSENSE.
FOR MOST PEOPLE ASSUME -- YES
THERE ARE CASES THAT HAVE HELD
THAT THAT IS ENOUGH BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER CASES THAT
HAVE HELD BY BASHING OUT A
WINDOW IS NOT ENOUGH YOU DON'T
PROVE THAT IT'S LOCKED -- AND WE
KNOW THE CASES THAT ARE PRETTY
CLEAR IN TERMS OF WHAT A NORMAL.
REGULAR PERSON WOULD THANK IN
VIEWING THE FAX OR BEING LOST ON
AS A AS A RESULT -- SO -- I
RESPECT THE OPPOSITION BUT I
DISAGREE -- AND I WOULD SAY THAT
I AM CONFIDENT THAT HAD WE
SIMPLY -- MODIFY THE EXISTING A
CRIME RATHER THAN CREATING A NEW
CRIME TO AVOID FELONY MURDER ARE
PRETTY CONFIDENT THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S WOULD STILL BE
OPPOSING US I DON'T THINK THAT.
DISTINCTION IS A VALID ARGUMENT
BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
WE LIVED IN A LONG TIME TO
GLORIA OF COURSE THAT DID NOT
EXPEDITED OR MORAL OR DID.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND IT WAS MY
THAT'S MY BAD -- YEAH I GUESS
ROOM WAY COMMITTEE CAN UNDER THE
BUS BUT LEAVE IT ALONE -- ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S.
THE MOTION IS -- PAST TWO PROBES.
SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE MORE LACKEY.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MORALE.
WELL I WIENER AYE WIENER AYE.
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN YOUR
MIND AND THEN WE WILL GO TO YOUR
NEXT BILL THANKS.
IF YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED [inaudible]
OKAY.
MILLS MOVE YOU ON THE SET ROLE
REVERSAL.
THIS CALL YOU VERY BRIEFLY I SP
ONE THIRTY SIX R. REPEALS -- A
VERY COMMON ONE YEAR -- SENSING
AND HAS BEEN.
FOR MORE THAN ONE FELONY
CONVICTION EVEN IF THEY'RE
NONVIOLENT NONVIOLENT -- THE
SENSING ENHANCEMENTS DO NOT
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY BUT THEY
DO COST US ENORMOUSLY -- AND
THEY CONTRIBUTE TO MASS --
INCARCERATIONS WHAT EFFECT
CENTER MITCHELL -- FOR CARRYING
THIS IS THE LAST YEAR AND FOR CO
AUTHORING AT THIS YEAR -- AND
IT'S TIME TO ELIMINATE THIS
ENHANCEMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE -- AND WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY BRIEFLY -- ARE --
CHECKED OUT IN THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER AT THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN A
LECTURE AT UC BERKELEY.
AND WHEN A RESEARCHER GRAD
STUDENT AND DIRECTOR OF PROJECT
REBOUND -- CSU SACRAMENTO.
RICK PLEASE PROCEED AND WE DID --
SUPPORT THIS BILL LAST YEAR SO
WE CAN BE EXPEDITIOUS I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU I DON'T
THINK I NEED TO TELL -- THIS
COMMITTEE THAT TELL THE SENSING
LAWS IN CALIFORNIA ARE VERY
COMPLEX AND MY COLLEAGUES AT
BERKELEY LAW -- THE CONSENSUS IS
THAT -- THE CALIFORNIA SENSING
SCHEME IS THE MOST COMPLICATED
AND LABYRINTHINE IN THE ENTIRE
NATION.
AND WE HAVE.
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DIFFERENT -- CONDUCT IN
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS AND THIS
ONE THIS ONE YEAR ENHANCEMENT.
FOR PRISON PRIORS IS ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON -- I CALLED
YESTERDAY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND ACCORDING TO
THEIR LATEST FIGURES THERE ARE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO INMATES WHO ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING A SENTENCE.
THAT INCLUDES AT LEAST.
ONE OF THESE ENHANCEMENTS UNDER
SIX SIX SEVEN POINT -- FIVE SO I
CHECK LAST NIGHT IT'S WHO WE
SPEND ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO INCARCERATED IN IN
MADE FOR ONE YEAR.
IN -- IN A PRISON SO THIS MEANS
THAT THIS ENHANCEMENTS NOT CHEAP
EITHER -- THAT WE ARE IF MY MATH
IS RIGHT WE'RE CURRENTLY
SPENDING ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
THREE BILLION DOLLARS MAYBE MORE --
ON THIS ENHANCEMENT SO THE
QUESTION IS IS IT COST EFFECTIVE.
AND I FEAR THAT IT IS NOT --
EVERY DAY IS A PUBLIC DEFENDER I
WATCHED PEOPLE GO TO PRISON.
AND THEY TYPICALLY FALL INTO TWO
CATEGORIES -- THE VAST MAJORITY
ARE PEOPLE WHO BACK INTO
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
BECAUSE OF MENTAL ILLNESS DRUG
ADDICTION OR POVERTY -- BUT
THERE ARE ALSO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CHOSEN CRIME IS THEIR PROFESSION.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT A SMART
COST EFFECTIVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
STRIVES TO KEEP THE PEOPLE IN
THE FIRST CATEGORY OUT OF PRISON.
AND THE PEOPLE IN THE SECOND
CATEGORY IN -- THE PROBLEM IS
THAT THE ONE YEAR PRISON PRIOR
ENHANCEMENT DOESN'T REALLY DO
THAT IN AN EFFECTIVE WAY IT CAST
THE NET TOO WIDE AND SCOOPS UP
TOO MANY PEOPLE IN THAT FIRST
CATEGORY.
BECAUSE IT APPLIES TO ANY FELONY
CONVICTION AT ALL -- IN AT THE
SAME TIME I THINK IT IS ANOTHER
STEP.
IN TOWARD UNTANGLING THIS
LABYRINTHINE -- CRIMINALS --
SENTENCING SCHEME THAT WE HAVE --
THIS THIS BILL IS NOT GOING TO
SWING THE PRISON DOORS WIDE OPEN.
IT IS NOT GONNA SEND RECIDIVISM
RATES SOARING AND IT'S NOT GOING
TO PREVENT JUDGES FROM STRICTLY
PUNISHING SERIOUS OFFENDERS WHO
COMMIT CRIMES OF VIOLENCE OR SEX.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS TO DO THAT -- WHAT
IT WILL DO IS TAKE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND THAT'S WHY
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY --
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT IT SB ONE
THIRTY SIX AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED --
FIRSTHAND THE COMPOUNDING
DAMAGES AND COMPLICATIONS THAT
THE WANT THE CURRENT WHEN YOUR
ENHANCEMENT FOR EACH PRISON
PRIOR.
CREATES FOR THOSE LIKE MYSELF.
IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND SEVEN I
WAS IN THIS FIGHT WHERE I THREW
ONE PUNCH SUBSEQUENTLY MY FRIEND
DIED AS A RESULT OF THAT PUNCH.
THERE WAS THERE WAS NO MALICIOUS
FOUR DOT COM.
IT WAS A DISAGREEMENT AND I
DON'T AND I DON'T HAVE THE SKILL
THAT THE TIME TO DEAL WITH THE
ADVERSITY ITS SITUATION.
I AM RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT I'VE
DONE.
REMORSEFUL OF THE PAIN IN
DAMAGES THAT COST.
WHILE IN JAIL THE CASE PENDING
THERE WERE NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
MY PUBLIC DEFENDER AND A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
AND THIS WAY I WAS THREATENED
WITH SECOND DEGREE MURDER.
HEY WE DECIDED TO GO TO TRIAL
SCARED FOR MY LIFE I BEGAN TO BE
OPEN TO THE IDEA OF A PLEA
AGREEMENT.
THE FIRST OFFER WORDS OF THE
PLAY TO VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER.
I AT SEVEN YEARS WITH THE STRIKE
HOWEVER I WAS NOT GUILTY OF
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER AS THERE
WAS NO FELONIOUS ACT THAT
TRANSPIRED DURING THE INCIDENT.
I DEPLETED MEANT I THAT I DID
ACCEPT WAS THREE YEARS IN WHICH
I PLAYED TO THE MID TERM OF
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER AN
ADDITIONAL ONE YEAR ONE THIRD
ORIGINAL SINCE WAS ORDERED TO BE
RANKING SECONDLY.
BECAUSE IT THE ENHANCEMENT FOR
PRESS EMPIRE BRINGING SINCE TO
FOUR YEARS TOTAL.
I WON THE POINTS THAT WE WERE
CONTESTING ON DURING
NEGOTIATIONS WAS RECOGNIZING
THAT I HAD ONLY GONE TO PRISON
ONCE.
ALTHOUGH IN THE EYES OF THE LAW
WIN MY PROBATION REVOKED IN
ANOTHER COUNTY BECAUSE THEY HAD
GONE TO PRISON THE FIRST TIME IT
APPEARED THAT BEEN TO PRISON
TWICE.
I NEARLY DODGE ONE PRISON PRIOR
ENHANCEMENT BUT CANNOT ESCAPE
THE CLUTCHES THE OTHER AS I DID
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO MANY
RESOURCES DON'T DO TO MY LOW
SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS.
ARE WHILE SERVING THE
ENHANCEMENT PORTION MY PRISON
TIME I MISSED OUT ON MANY
HOLIDAYS BIRTHDAYS THE DEATH OF
A FRIEND MY FATHER BEING
HOSPITALIZED FOR HEART
COMPLICATIONS MY BROTHER.
HAVING A NEAR DEATH EXPERIENCE
DOOMED TO NEUROLOGICAL
CONDITIONS AND TO CONTINUE
POSTPONEMENT OF ADEQUATE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FOR MYSELF.
I DO NOT WISH TO TYPE OF PRISON
EXPERIENCE THAT ENTERED UPON
ANYONE.
LET ALONE EXTENDING PRISON
SENTENCES BECAUSE ENHANCEMENT
HAS BEEN EMPIRICALLY PROVEN TO
NOT IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY NOR
DOES IT DETER CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
I BELIEVE IT TO CONFUSION DAY
THAT SB ONE THIRTY SIX PASSES SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO MOVE
AWAY FROM PUNITIVE PRACTICES
THAT.
A MOVEMENT MORE TOWARDS RESTORE
METHODOLOGY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF HE CELIA OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE A PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GLAD I GUESS ON BEHALF OF TWO CO
SPONSORS DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS THANK YOU.
PYLE MAGLI HONEST BECAUSE CO
WITH COMMUNITY WORKS IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE CHIRLA
PROBABLY A SPONSOR.
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US AND THEN ALSO
PROUD COSPONSORS THANK YOU.
WAS BERMAN THE HEALTH ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET CO SPONSOR
AND IN SUPPORT.
LENDING CROWDY WILL LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US IN A STRONG
SUPPORT.
WORLD MARYLAND ROSTEN CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER LEAHY CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY FRESNO PROJECT
REBOUND AND SUPPORT.
SENATE TOMSKY PROJECT REBOUND
SAN FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY
IN SUPPORT.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA WHERE A CO SPONSOR
HERE IN SUPPORT.
I'LL HANDLE IT ON HERE REPRESENT
A NEXT GEN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DANNY CORRIDOR MELVIN LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS AND
SAN FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IMPLEMENT BERKELEY LAW SCHOOL
STUDENT IN SUPPORT.
BOB RILEY ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES WITH PRESENTS WITH
CHILDREN STRONG SUPPORT.
MELISSA WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
OSCAR PENA WITH AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE -- AND SUPPORT.
FATIMA CON WITH AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE SENATE SUPPORT.
IGNITES YOUR IS A BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE CUT I MEAN EXCUSE ME
SUPPORT.
RIGHT NOW ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WHO SHOP BY CHARLIE HAVE
TO CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION INTEREST OF TIME --
JUST STOP BASED ON PAST THE
YEARS WEEK CONTINUE TO OPPOSE
THIS POLICY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
RIGHT TIME.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
BY.
OR COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- YEAH
JUST LIKE THAT I DON'T THINK --
THE SENATE IN HAND THE OF THE
JUDICIAL ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FOR WHICH IS
RIDICULOUS.
I KNOW MANY JUDGES AND NOT ONE
OF THEM [inaudible]
A WILL.
ADMIT OR OR THEY ALL ADMIT THAT
THEY CAN'T FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO DO THE SENTENCING THERE
ARE NUMEROUS COURSES THEY TRY TO
GIVE?
OUR TWO JUDGES SO THAT WHEN THEY
ARE ASKED TO TWO SENTENCE PEOPLE --
AND FOR EACH TWO JUDGES THEY'RE
SERVING THIS EXPERT YOU GET
THREE OPINIONS SO I THANK YOU --
FOR A DRESSING THIS PROBLEM.
THE HOPE WAS THE MORE WE PUNISH
PEOPLE THE MORE THEY'LL CHANGE
THEIR BEHAVIOR WE KNOW THAT
HASN'T WORKED AND THIS WHOLE
SYSTEM.
HAS BEEN ALMOST AN EMBARRASSMENT
I THINK TO THE COURTS AND TO OUR
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT BECAUSE I HAVE HAD
MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH JUDGES
WHO ARE -- TRULY VERY FRUSTRATED
BY ALL THE ENHANCEMENTS AND THEN
YOU DEDUCT FOR THIS AND YOUR
SENTENCE WAS IN A AN EXAMPLE.
OF OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE TRY
TO FIGURE OUT A SYSTEM THAT IS
INCOMPREHENSIBLE AND I BET THAT
THIS WILL ALSO IF WE START CLERK
CLEARING UP THIS PROCESS.
IT WILL SAVE THE STATE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY BECAUSE
I KNOW THERE INSTANCES WHERE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS COME IN AND
THEY CHALLENGES SENTENCING.
DECISION SO WE CAN HELP.
ONE THE CORDS -- TRY TO FIND
BETTER WAYS TO ASSURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO COMMIT OFFENSES DO
NOT RECIDIVISTS -- AND THE
CHANGING THIS IS JUST A SMALL
BUT I THINK A SIGNIFICANT STEP
FORWARD SO WITH THAT I ALSO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
VOTE ON THANK YOU SENATOR -- HI.
I THINK THAT THIS MAY BE A
SUBJECT MATTER THAT WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT.
WHETHER WE CONVENE A SIMILAR --
GROUPING AS WAS SUGGESTED BY --
SENATOR MITCHELL AROUND FEDERAL
ISSUE OR WHETHER THERE IS AN
ENTITY THAT WE COULD -- YOU KNOW
I DON THINK IN I DON'T THINK THE
STATE AUDITOR QUITE WORKS BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE BROUGHT
THE BILL BACK I WAS VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT -- SENATOR
MITCHELL'S BILL OF DID NOT
SUCCEED LAST YEAR BUT WHAT IS
VERY FRUSTRATING IS THAT WE'RE
HAVING TO BE IN A SITUATION
WHERE WE RE HAVING TO DO
INDIVIDUAL BILLS.
ON THESE FOR SOME FOUR HUNDRED
NINE I MEAN LOOK THERE MAY BE A
COUPLE OF THOSE OR MAYBE EVEN
MORE THAN A COUPLE OF THAT FOUR
HUNDRED OR SO -- SENSE
ENHANCEMENT STATUTES THAT WE
HAVE THAT MIGHT HAVE SOME
JUSTIFICATION BUT IF WE IMAGINE
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO CARRY AN
INDIVIDUAL BILL FOR THE
ELIMINATION OF WHATEVER SET OF
LET'S CALL LEAST A MINIMUM OF A
HUNDRED OR BAD.
OR NOT USED OR NOT SERVING THE
PURPOSE FOR WHICH THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN INTENDED IT COULD TAKE US
FOR EVER SO YOU KNOW I'D LOVE TO
BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT
WE CAN APPROACH THIS IN MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY BUT FOR NOW I'M
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THIS AND I
WILL.
TAKE YOUR PREVIOUS COMMENTS AS
YOUR CLOTHES AND I WILL ASK FOR
A ROLL CALL VOTE NOW.
THIS IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD PARK
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE AROUND NO
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE.
ALL RIGHT THANKS TO BILLS OUT
WE'RE NOW GOING TO RE OPEN THE
ROLE SO WE CAN GET IN TWO COPIES
A. S. A. P. LET'S START -- VERY
QUICKLY BECAUSE OF THE THIS WILL
BE OUR FIRST OPENING THE ROLE ON
OUR RULES PLEASE ROLL CALL THE
MISSING MEMBERS MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE ALL RIGHT THAT BILLS
OUT WE WILL NOW -- ADOPTION WE
WILL NOW WE NEED A MOTION ON SB
TWENTY TWO THAT SLAVE AS BILL.
ALL RIGHT SO WE WILL NOW HAVE
ROLL CALL ON SB TWENTY TWO WE'VE
NOT HAD A ROLL CALL AT ALL ON
THIS BILL GO AHEAD MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER
HI SKINNER I'M MORE LOCKED.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD RIGHT FOR
AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MOREAU.
ROW I'VE WIENER.
WIENER HIGH RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT
UNANIMOUS WILL NOW GO TO SB
THIRTY FIVE THREE OPEN THE ROLE
FOR SENATOR CHANGES BILL.
GO AHEAD SB.
THIRTY FIVE AM JACKSON.
HI JACKSON I'VE WINNER.
WIENER AYE.
ALL RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT
UNANIMOUS DO WE WANT OPEN
CONSENT CALENDAR.
LET'S OPEN CONSENT CALENDAR.
JACKSON.
I'M SORRY THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
JACKSON I'M AROUND.
EXCELLENT NOW WILL GO -- TO
EXCUSE ME CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT UNANIMOUS.
SB THIRTY SIX HERTZBERG.
MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD ON
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER HIGH.
THAT BILL WAS OUT ITS UNANIMOUS
VOTE WILL NOW GO TO SB FIFTY
FIVE SENATOR JACKSON'S
[inaudible]
SORRY.
IN THE FILE ORDER SORRY.
I THINK THAT IT WAS OUT RIGHT
POLICIES FOLLOW JESUS WILL NOW
GO TO AS CENTER SB ONE THIRTY
SIX IS ALSO OUT THAT WAS DONE --
WILL GO TO SB ONE SIXTY ONE
SENATOR BATES THAT SO FAR THAT
BILL CURRENT STUDENTS.
MODE YES [inaudible]
TWO ONE TWO TWO ONE MITCHELL.
OKAY WE HAVE THAT'S IT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO RECONSIDERATION WAS
GRANTED TO SB ONE SIXTY ONE THE
BILL FAILED WILL NOW GO DO SB.
ONE NINE THREE THAT'S OUT WILL
GO TO SB ONE NINE FOUR SENATOR
NIELSEN.
WE DON'T HAVE THEY'RE STILL IN
MOTION A RUSH WAS THE PASTOR
PROBES THE VOTES.
TO TO JACKSON.
WHERE TO JACKSON?
THIS IS SENATOR NIELSEN SPELL ON
MASKS.
JACKSON DOWN.
A LITTLE SALES OKAY IN SB ONE
NINETY FOUR FAILS THE VOTE WAS.
TWO TO THREE WE WILL NOW GO.
TO SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR SENATOR
BELL THE VOTE TO SO FAR IS --
BORDER ONE FOUR TO ONE MORALE
[inaudible]
AND WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
RIGHT THE BILLS NOW 521- AND IT
IS OUT.
WE WILL NOW GO -- TO SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT THE VOTE AT CURRENT
IS THREE TWO NOT VOTING.
FOR ME. THREE I HAVE FOR VOTING
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR IS YOUR FOURTH
YES.
THE BRADFORD.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW.
THERE YEAH WE HAVE SENATOR
MOROSE THE ONLY NON RECORDED NOW
WE HAVE AROUND WE DIDN'T HAVE
BRADFORD.
RIGHT.
WHAT DID HE DO NOT VOTING NOW
FOREVER JUST NOT?
RIGHT SO WE THIS IS OUR YEAH
OKAY RIGHT SO I NEED
[inaudible]
IN HIGH.
RIGHT SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT IS
OUT. FOR TWO ONE FOUR ZERO ZERO
FOUR ZERO APOLOGIES.
SB THREE SIX EIGHT IS OUT.
FOUR ZERO AND WE WILL NOW GO.
TO SB FIVE SEVENTEEN OR TO LEAD
A FIVE TWO ZERO CURRENTLY
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HIGH MORALE.
OKAY OKAY OKAY.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT.
ASKING US TO CALL YOU WITH THE
WAR THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES RECORDS YEAH YOUR
YEAH YOU'RE GOOD.
ALL RIGHT SO THE BILL.
NOW.
JUST BECAUSE HE'S OUT I DON'T
THINK SO.
THE WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
FUTURE OKAY HOLD ON LET ME
ANNOUNCE THIS VOTE.
SB FIVE SEVENTEEN IS OUT.
SIX ZERO WE WILL NOW RETURN.
TO SB.
TWENTY THREE WIENER WHICH IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AT THE
MOMENTIT IS. FIVE FIVE IT'S
FIVE TWO ZERO TRANSFERRING.
I'M SORRY NOT VOTING MITCHELL
NEED TO OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OKAY. FIVE ITSELF.
FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS NOW OUT
FIVE ZERO SB.
TWENTY THREE ALL RIGHT.
I THINK THAT WE REQUIRE.
YES YOU MAY WHICH BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADD ON TO I CAN'T
BECAUSE I ANNOUNCED IT ALREADY.
POLICIES CAN'T ALL RIGHT
[inaudible]
SO -- WITH THAT AND WITH THE WAY
THAT I ANNOUNCED THE TO THOSE
BILLS.
IT'S WE ARE INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
SAFETY.
COMMITTEE FOR TO DAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
A JOURNAL